séance est ouverte le compte rendu
intégral de la séance du mardi 31
octobre a été publiée sur le site
internet du Sénat il n'y a pas
d'observation le procèsverbal est
adopté j'ai le regret de vous faire part
du décès de notre ancien collègue Daniel
eens sper qui fut sénateur du haut rein
de 1995 à
2004 mes chers collègues les conclusions
adoptées par la Conférence des
Présidents réunies mardi 31 octobre sont
consultable sur le site du Sénat en
l'absence d'observation je considère ces
conclusions comme
adopté j'informe le Sénat que des
candidatures pour siéger au sein de la
commission mixte paritaire chargé
d'élaborer un texte sur la proposition
de loi relative au service express Ré
régionaux métropolitains ont été publiés
ces candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'unehure prévu par notre
règlement l'ordre du jour appelle
l'examen de la demande de la commission
des lois tendant à obtenir du Sénat en
application de l'article 5 TER de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre
1958 relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires qui lui
confère pour une durée de 6 mois les
prérogatives attribuées aux commissions
d'enquête afin de mener sa mission
d'information sur les émeutes survenus à
comptter du 27 juin 2023 il a été donné
connaissance de cette demande au Sénat
lors de la séance du 23 octobre dernier
je vais mettre au voix la demande de la
Commission des loi qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient
elle est adoptée en conséquence la
commission des lois se voit conférer
pour une durée de 6 mois les
prérogatives attribuées aux commissions
d'enquête pour mener cette mission
d'information le gouvernement sera
informé de la décision qui vient d'être
prise par le
Sénat l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi pour
contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration la procédure accélérée a
été engagée sur ce texte dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Géral d'Anin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres
mèes ne soyez ne soyez pas
jalouse
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame la rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sans contestation les deux
grands défis de notre siècle qui déjà se
déroul devant nos yeux sont les
questions
environnementales et les questions
migratoires les questions
environnementales chacun le sait chacun
le commente chacun le voit les questions
migratoires c'est moins évident dans les
débats médiatiques dans les débats
politiques et à la lecture encore de la
presse de ce matin nous pourrions croire
que la France est une île même si on a
vu récemment que le fait de se refermer
sur C île n'était pas très efficace en
matière
d'immigration 110 millions de déplacés
dans le monde c'est le nombre de
personnes que constate le HR le Haut
Commissariat au réfugiés en 2023 du fait
des guerres du Soudan de la Syrie de
l'Afghanistan de l'Ukraine notre
continent l'Europe est entouré de terres
instables le Caucase le Proche et le
Moyen-Orient le Sahel la
Libye les pays du Sud du monde
accueillent tr/4 de ses
déplacés mais l'Europe connaî elle aussi
une augmentation de son immigration
irrégulière de ses demandes d'asile plus
de 60 % depuis le début de l'année
concerne tous les pays concerne tous les
régimes politiques concerne tous les
gouvernants
à cela se rajoute 21 à 24 millions de
réfugiés par an du fait des dérèglements
climatiques 60000 par
jour les pays les plus pauvres sont CIN
fois plus touchés par les dérèglements
climatiques faisant naître encore plus
de départ de leur population vers
l'Occident vers l'Europe en un mot nous
n'avons pas fini de parler
d'immigration et peut-être tant mieux
car mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
parler d'immigration c'est parler de
notre souveraineté
de ce qui fait un état de ses frontières
du choix de ceux qui veul accueillir sur
son territoire de ceux qui veulent
intégrer dans quelles condition de ceux
dont on veut se séparer en parler est
certes difficile car il s'agit de femmes
d'hommes d'enfants mais en parler est
nécessaire et émidemment
politique parler d'immigration c'est
parler de notre modèle républicain
social de sa capacité à intégrer des
moyens qu'on lui octroit des RG qu'on
lui
fixe parler d'immigration c'est aussi
parler de sécurité et parler
d'immigration c'est enfin parler au
français mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs comme moi vous rencontrez vos
électeurs comme moi vous lisez les
sondages les Français sont préoccupés
par l'immigration ils sont parfois
paradoxaux mais il nous demande toutes
et tous de légiférer et de prendre des
décisions le texte que propose le
gouvernement est une de ces propositions
le texte que propose le gouvernement ici
devant vous avec
l'humilité du ministre de l'Intérieur
qui depuis 3 ans et demi est en charge à
la demande du Président de la République
et de la première ministre de ces
questions est ouvert à la discussion
avec le Parlement avec le Sénat pour
construire ensemble un texte ferme un
texte juste et surtout un texte
efficace ce qui va compter pour le
ministre de l'Intérieur que je suis ce
ne sont pas les
postures ce n'est pas les futures
majorités c'est l'efficacité
oui ou non sommes-nous capable de doter
notre pays nos services de police nos
services de
préfecture tous ceux qui travaillent
dans le monde parfois difficile des
questions migratoires pour plus
d'efficacité pour répondre à la demande
d'autorité des Français pour répondre
aux exigences
d'intégration et pour éviter en effet
que les populistes ne surf son
incapacité qu'à l'état qu'on les États à
appliquer leur
décision le gouvernement est cohérent en
vous proposant la loi de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur voilà un an
que vous avez très majoritairement voté
ici ce texte que vous avez très
largement voté y compris au-delà de la
majorité sénatoriale don 25 de plus pour
les crédits d'intégration du ministère
de l'Intérieur et prévoyez le début
d'une refonte extrêmement importante des
préfectures et du travail que font les
préfectures au service de nos
concitoyens je veux ici dire monsieur le
président de la commission des lois que
ce que vous m'avez demandé voilà plus de
2 ans la refondte du travail des
préfecture de France et je veux à
travers ces propos saluer tous les
agents de préfecture tous ceux qui
tiennent les bureaux les accueil dans
des conditions parfois très difficiles
pour accueillir nos compatriotes mais
aussi ceux qui étrangers veulent des
titres de séjour ou à qui parfois nous
disons de repartir chez eux cette
réforme des préfectures qui n'est pas
législatif accompagne ce texte de loi et
la conséquence de la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur une réforme profonde
réglementaire que je m'engage à
présenter devant vous dans les
prochaines semaines pour qu'elle soit
effective au 1er janvier de l'année
prochaine et qui prévoit en quelques
mots de mettre tous les moyens pour
constater l'intégration des personnes
pour regarder les titres de séjour
lorsqu'ils sont déposés la première fois
pour lutter avec force contre tous ceux
qui ont des casiers judiciaires ou qui
font des actes de délinquence dans notre
pays et qui abusent de notre générosité
pour les renvoyer dans leur pays pour
appliquer les fameux eqtf devenu
désormais un mot synonyme d'incapacité
pour les Français à appliquer les
reconduites du territoire et en même
temps de ne pas embêter tous ces é
étrangers qui vivent depuis tant
d'années parfois depuis des dizaines
d'années sur le sol national et qui ne
font de mal à personne et qui parfois
attendent longtemps des renouvellement
titrre de séjour je pense à ce Chibani
de tourcoin celui qui depuis 45 ans est
sur le se national qui certes a gardé la
nationalité de son pays d'origine mais a
combattu dans les armées françaises et
dont la République ne sonore pas à le
faire patienter devant la préfecture du
Nord pour renouveler son titre de séjour
alors qu'à 80 ans il ne fait de mal à
personne et j'allais dire qu'il chante
la Marseillaise comme nous tous mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs après la loi
de programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur après la refonte de la vie
de nos préfectures est venu aussi le
temps européen de modification de nos
règles d'asile et
d'immigration l'Europe n'a pas de
gouvernance politique de l'immigration
elle a une gouvernance économique de
l'immigration
elle a des conseils des ministres de
l'économie et des finances qui se
réunissent pour la zone euro et alors
que nos frontières sont communes alors
que les enjeux sont planétaires nous
n'avons pas ou très difficilement une
seule voix pour parler d'immigration en
Europe il est évident que l'une des
grandes réponses au défi migratoires
c'est
l'Europe tous les gouvernants et compris
ceux qui ont fait campagne électorale
contre l'Europe en sont à appelé la
Commission européenne ou le Parlement
européens ou les collègues des autres
ministères européens de l'intérieur pour
pouvoir répondre aux crises comme c'est
récemment le cas encore à l'ampedusa oui
il faut des règles européennes oui il
faut une libre circulation à l'intérieur
de l'Union européenne que si et
seulement si les frontières extérieures
de l'Europe sont tenues et fermement
tenues aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
cas sous la présidence française le
président de la République a porté le
pacte asile et immigration qui depuis 20
ans traîne dans les bureaux de la
Commission
européenne la France je crois par son
dynamisme mais aussi avec l'alliance
politique de la plupart des pays
européens a réussi à faire adopter deux
textes essentiels pour notre Europe et
pour la
France d'abord
Eurodac jusqu'à présent tout étranger
qui arrive en Europe n'est pas
enregistré ici ou là il connaît un
accueil parfois on le pousse vers
d'autres pays et les Français constatent
comme nos policiers nos gendarmes
courageux qu'on ne sait pas qui ils sont
qu'on ne connaît pas leur âge sont-ils
majeurs sont-ils mineurs qu'on ne sait
pas pourquoi ils viennent chez nous et
lorsqu'on les interpelle ils demande
l'asile les relâchant ainsi pour être
dans un nouveau processus long qui
empêche la République de savoir qui elle
peut accueillir sur le territoire
national Eurodac adopté par le Conseil
européen et j'espère bientôt voté par le
Parlement européen l'élection
européennne permettra d'enregistrer tous
les étrangers sur le sol européen de
prendre leurs empreintes connaître leur
identité de connaître leur âge de
pouvoir reconstituer leur état civil et
de permettre demain grâce à ethas et une
disposition monsieur le président de la
commission des lois et dans ce texte
c'est-à-dire que toutes les polices
européennes pourront connaître ce
fichier et avoir lorsqu'ils
interpelleront quelqu'un l'identité de
cette personne sans refaire le processus
mortifère que j'évoqué tout à l'heure de
l'incapacité des États à agir alors nous
pourrons connaître tous ceux qui arrive
sur notre sol quelles sont leur
identités et nous lutterons ainsi
férocement contre l'immigration
irrégulière deuxième texte très
important porter en européen c'est
évidemment l'asile à la frontière la
fiction de non entrée physique juridique
sur le sol européen il y a tant de gens
qui arrivent en Europe de pays où nous
partons parfois en vacances de pays où
nous avons des relations diplomatiques
extrêmement fortes de pays où il n'y a
aucune dictature aucune difficulté et
pour autant beaucoup de demandes d'asile
et qui on olise bien sûr les services et
qui empêche parfois de rendre une
réponse rapide à ceux qui ont vraiment
besoin de l'asile en France le principe
d'asile à la frontière nous permettra
très rapidement de pouvoir distinguer
ceux qui ont des taux de protection
élevé ce qui mérit évidemment l'oreille
attentif et humaniste de l'Europe et
ceux qui abusent et qui utilisent le
droit d'asile comme un détournement de
procédure ces deux textes sils sont
votés très prochainement par le
Parlement européen aideront tous les
Européens et donc la France à être plus
efficace et être plus rapide mais je
l'ai dit mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est plein d'humilité mais
aussi plein de volontarisme que le
gouvernement se présente devant la Haute
chambre avec un projet de loi qui a été
déposé sur le bureau du Sénat voilà
quelques mois Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs qui a été adopté par la
commission des Lois du Sénat ce que je
l'en remercie à quelques détails près
sur le texte du Gouvernement et qui
arrivant à 27 articles est arrivé à une
cinquantaine d'articles c'estàdire que
que la commission des Lois du Sénat
après avoir supprimé seulement deux
articles du projet de loi en a rajouté
quasiment autant et j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer publiquement et
dans votre hémicycle par ailleurs aux
questions pour dire que le gouvernement
ferait évidemment un avis favorable à la
quasi intégralité des dispositions
présentées par la majorité sénatoriale
trouvant ainsi de l'écho à la
couonstruction partant ainsi du principe
que le texte du gouvernement n'était pas
mauvais puisqu'il a été adopté par la
commission des lois du Sénat mais
partant du principe que le gouvernement
n'avait pas raison tout seul et qu'il
fallait le construire avec l'ensemble
des
parlementaires le texte de loi que j'ai
eu l'honneur de proposer au nom du
gouvernement au nom du Président de la
République et qui prend source
directement dans sa campagne
présidentielle repose sur deux mots la
fermeté et la
simplification fermeté
d'abord fermeté contre les étrangers
délinquants les Français ne comprennent
pas que nous n'arrivions pas à éloigner
ou à expulser du territoire national des
personnes qui ont commis des crimes des
crimes de sang des personnes qui s'en
sont pris à leurs femmes aux policiers
qui trafiquent de la drogue et que ni la
Constitution ni la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme n'empêche
d'expulser mais que la loi française
empêche d'expulser l'ann dernière
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
demandé et obtenu l'expulsion de 2500
étranger délinquant je n'ai pas pu
obtenir et même pas pu demander à la
justice de notre pays l'expulsion de
4000 personnes non pas parce que je
n'avais pas les laissé passer consulaire
des pays non pas parce qu'un juge aurait
trouvé que cette expulsion était
disproportionnée mais parce que le
législateur voilà 25 ans quasiment a
décidé qu'il ne fallait pas en plus de
la peine qu'on courourait un étranger
qui commettait un acte grave qui ne
fallait pas l'éloigner ou l'expulser du
territoire national inventant ainsi les
réserves d'ordre public les personnes
qui sont arrivées avant 13 ans son l'âge
dans notre pays ou ceux qui se sont
mariés par exemple dans notre pays
c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un qui est
arrivé à 12 ans et demi sur le sol
national qui a 19 ans commet un
crime celui-ci je ne peux pas l'expulser
mais celui qui arrive à 13 ans et demi
sur le territoire nationale et qu'à 19
ans pour plein de raisons commet un
délit imaginons qu'ils veulent une
voiture celui-là je peux l'expulser qu'
a-t-il de logique Mesdames et Messieurs
les parlementaires à ce texte de loi je
viens demander au Sénat je viens
demander à l'Assemblée nationale de
lever les réserves d'ord publique et de
permettre au ministre de l'Intérieur
d'appliquer ce que demandent les
Français la fermeté que ceux que nous
accueillons généreusement sur notre
territoire respecte nos règles s'ils ne
les respectent pas s'ils sont en
responsabilité de commettre des crimes
et délits si ils ne respectent pas les
valeurs de la République alors oui
obtenons leur éloignement leur expulsion
du territoire national
fermeté également dans le retrait ou le
non renouvellement des cartes de
résidents quel que soi ces cartes de
résidents quel que soit le statut quel
que soit la nationalité des personnes
qui sont étrangerses en France mais qui
ne respectent pas non plus les règles
aujourd'hui le ministre de intérieur les
Français doivent le savoir ne peut pas
retirer un titre de séjour en tout cas
pas dans tous les cas lorsque nous avons
connaissance des services de la justice
des services de la police des services
de la DGSI que cette personne ne
respecte pas les règles de la République
fermeté contre les
passeurs il y a un écosystème mafieux
qui utilise la misère humaine en faisant
du trafic contre beaucoup d'argent pour
faire venir en France pour faire venir
en Europe des femmes des enfants des
hommes les passeurs ne sont pas de
gentils organisateurs de leur venue en
Occident ce sont des criminels dont
l'argent finance l'argent de la drogue
l'argent du terrorisme l'argent de la
prostitution et nous devons les
combattre et aujourd'hui être un passeur
c'est en courir le risque d'un délit les
27 morts de la Manche les corps de ces
femmes enenceinte repêché à 3 degrés que
les services sauvteurs des policiers des
gendarmes des bénévoles sont allés
malheureusement recourir jusque dans la
mort en novembre dernier ceux qui
étaient respons responsable de leur mort
ce n'étaient pas les policiers français
qui tous les jours plonge dans la mer du
Nord pour essayer de récupérer un peu de
vie et donner un peu d'espoir aux
migrants qui essaient de tenter la
chance en Grande-Bretagne ce ne sont pas
nos règles qui sont responsables de cela
mais des criminels qui aujourd'hui ne
sont responsabl que d'un délit devant la
justice fermeté contre les passeurs
c'est passer de délit à crime jusqu'à 20
ans de prison c'est ce qu'il y a dans ce
texte considérant que trafiquer avec le
terrorisme trafiquer avec la drogue ou
trafiquer avec les êtres humains c'est
la même chose chose et mérite la
sévérité des tribunaux fermeté contre
les marchands de sommeil qui ici n'a pas
été élu local et n'a pas vu son
centre-ville son urbanisme devenu une
passoire une passoire parce que devant
le travail qu'essaient de faire les élus
il y a toutes ces règles d'urbanisme ces
difficultés où l'on voit désormais des
personnes souvent ne déclarant pas leur
recette au fisque parfois étranger
eux-mêmes qui utilisent la misère des
gens pour pouvoir les loger sans
quittant de loyer sans lavabo sans
électricité avec de la mérule avec des
enfants de quelques mois
oui être marchand de sommeil c'est comme
être passeur c'est criminaliser les
êtres humains des dispositions monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
pour la première fois qui attaque aussi
durement les marchands de sommeil sont
dans ce texte de loi pour casser en
effet l'écosystème des irréguliers et en
tout cas de l'immigration irrégulière
fermeté contre certains patrons voyou
qui embauche en le savant pertinemment
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
qu'ils exploitent dans des condition
inacceptaable inacceptable bien sûr pour
la concurrence on est toujours moins
cher lorsqueon emboche les 100 papiers
qu'on a ni inspection du travail ni
cotisation ni charge
patronale mais évidemment inacceptable
pour ces personnes qui subissent le
jou parfois moyenageux de patrons qui
font du chantage à la régularisation de
patron qui utilise la misère pour éviter
de donner des bonnes conditions sociales
et des droits syndicaux aux
salariés la disposition que le Sénat
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois a supprimé en son article 8 est
une excellente disposition et je veux
ici le dire sans aucune espèce d'esprit
de posture nous l'apportons avec Olivier
duoft je proposerai ce sera assez rare
dans ce débat monsieur le Président un
amendement de
réétablissement oui il faut fermer
administrativement les entreprises qui
siamment embauchent les sans papiers
sinon vous allez pas tarir le flux des
personnes irrégulières qui viennent dans
notre pays il est illogique de vouloir
ne pas régulariser des personnes qui
sont sans papier et ne pas vouloir
fermer les entreprises qui les font
venir mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs alors oui votons l'article 8
travaillons-le s'il est mal rédigé mais
luttons fortement contre ceux qui
embauchent les sans papiers et qui ne le
déclarent pas il y a évidemment des
personnes qui parce qu'elles utilisent
un alias ou parce qu'elle devienne
irrégulière parce que la préfecture n'a
pas répondu assez vite devienne
irrégulier le patron n'est pas voyou le
patron parfois vient voir le
parlementaire le député le sénateur le
maire et lui dit ou le préfet voilà j'ai
une situation indésirable elle vient de
tomber sur la tête de mon salarié
comment on peut s'arranger et puis il y
a d'autres patrons don vous le savez qui
malheureusement utilisent cette misère
humaine pour faire plus de profit je
crois que c'est le devoir de la droite
comme de la gauche du centre comme de
tous ceux qui sont indépendants de
lutter contre la filière d'immigration
irrégulière que représente parfois un
patronat sans scrupule et puis fermeté
dans les exigences d'intégration
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
aujourd'hui pour avoir une carte de
séjour long contrairement à beaucoup de
pays du monde il faut prendre des cours
de français mais personne ne vérifie si
ces cours de français ont été
parfaitement effectués et surtout s'ils
ont été efficaces ce texte de loi donne
une mesure qui à mon avis est attendue
par tout le monde et d'abord je crois
par les les étrangers qui veulent
s'intégrer nous mettons beaucoup plus de
moyens d'intégration je dit pour la loi
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous prévoyons que pendant
par exemple le temps de travail on
puisse prévoir voilà un article que le
Sénat a aussi supprimé malheureusement
le temps pour apprendre le français
parce qu'une femme de ménage qui fait
1h30 de ROR pour travailler à 4h30 du
matin et qui repart à 1h30 de ROR à 7h
du matin et qui a deux enfants chez elle
dans une dans une ville très éloignée
par exemple du centre de Paris ce n'est
pas vrai qu'elle a le temps à 14h30
d'aller à la préfecture dans une
association prendre des cours de
français et la disposition que je vous
ai proposé c'est que pendant les heures
de travail pendant le contrat de travail
l'employeur qui a une responsabilité
sociale pas de taxe une responsabilité
sociale comme dans ma région dans le
nord de la France il y a eu le 1 %
logement je vous propose 1 % intégration
si je dire il une responsabilité sociale
les employeurs pendant que les
employeurs embauchent des personnes qui
n'auraient pas toutes les capacités
d'intégration et par exemple qui
parlerent pas français et notamment les
l'immense majorité de l'intégration dans
le travail ce sont les femmes c'est une
immigration féminine qui essaie de
travailler dans votre pays alors oui il
faut non seulement que le patron
autorise que pendant les heures de
travail on apprenne le français mais que
il y ait un examen pour savoir si oui ou
non on a réussi cet examen de français
si on l'a réussi on a le droit d'avoir
un titre de séjour long sur le
territoire national si on n pas réussi
on ne peut pas s'intégrer on doit
quitter le territoire national c'est ce
que nous proposons ici je rappelle que
c'est ce que propose la plupart des
grands pays qui nous entourent il est
inimaginable de travailler aux
États-Unis sans avoir un travail
régularisé sans parler anglais nous
proposons rien d'autre que de pouvoir
intégrer les personnes au moment où le
président de la République et tous
ensemble ici j'ai cru comprend dans les
débats récemment ont défendu la langue
française je ne comprendrai pas
évidemment le gouvernement comprendrait
pas que nous trouvions pas un accord sur
le fait qu'il faut savoir parler
français pour s'intégrer en France sinon
pas de titre de séjour fermeté donc mais
aussi
simplification et là monsieur le
président de la commission des lois je
dois appeler des coupables je plaide
coupable de
plagiat la simplification les
simplifications des procédures c'est le
rapport buffet rapport buffet qui n'est
pas que le rapport buffet qui est le
rapport de tout le Sénat puisque je
crois savoir Monsieur le Président que
tous les groupes politiques alors
représentés dans l'ancienne chambre
sénatoriale ont adopter votre rapport
qui lui-même s'inspirait d'un rapport du
Conseil d'État le drame de notre
politique migratoire le drame de la non
apppplication des eqtf nonobstant les
évocations que tout à l'heure nous
citions sur les réserves d'ordre public
c'est le fait que nous soyons longs
beaucoup trop long la loi Colom a permis
la rapidité de l'OFPRA l'agence qui au
ministère de l'Intérieur regarde les
demandes d'asile avant que monsieur
colon ne présente son texte c'était à
peu près un an désormais c'est 5 mois
nous avons gagné à peu près en moyenne
bien évidemment il y a des cas
particuliers deux fois plus de temps
pour répondre OUI ou NON à quelqu'un
mais la justice administrative elle
continue à être lente notamment la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile alors
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs un
exemple imaginons quelqu'un qui vient en
France ce matin et qui traversant les
mers demande
l'asile imaginons quelqu'un qui détourne
le droit d'asile arrive ce matin et se
dit tiens pour rester en France je vais
demander
l'asile ces deux personnes vont d'abord
déposer leur dossier à l'OF pr et en 5
mois à peu près nous allons lui répondre
oui ou non nous ne sommes pas
laxistes 70 % des cas l'OFPRA dit non
nous refusons 70 % des demandes d'asile
en France nous avons l'un des taux de
refus les plus importants
d'Europe on lui dit non qu'est-ce qu'il
fait il fait un recours il va devant la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile là c'est
entre 9 mois et un an ça fait déjà
quasiment un an et demi la Cour
nationale droit d'asile n'est pas la
existe non plus dans 70 % des cas
également elle dit
non que fait-il il attend que le préfet
lui mette un arrêtter de reconduite du
territoire un eqtf et là leqtf est
susceptible de recours et donc il fait
un recours pendant ce temp là le
ministre l'intérieur il peut pas
expulser cette personne donc on attend
vous savez bien que 40 à 50 % de
contentieux de vos tribunaux
administratif c'est le droit des
étrangers 60 % cours d'appel les cours
administratifs d'appel les tribunaux
administratif au territoire écoute de
moins en moins les doléances de vos élus
locaux sur l'urbanisme mais de plus en
plus te font que du contentieux des
étrangers et donc cet étranger qui est
déjà arrivé voilà depuis plus d'un an et
demi sur le territoire national il va
attendre encore 9 mois que le tribunal
administratif de lillele par exemple lui
dise non parce que dans 70 % des cas il
lui dit non et qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
après ben il saisit le Conseil d'État
encore suspensif voilà comment quelqu'un
à qui on va dire non quatre fois à qui
on a mis un arrêté de reconduite à la
frontière à qui on a sans doute négocié
un laissé passer consu
avec tel ou tel pays peut rester 2 ans à
3 ans sur le territoire national sans
que nous puissions l'expulser et pendant
ce temps-là cette personne peut-être
qu'il aura été embauché par un patron
voillou parce qu'il faut qu'il vive il
aura peut-être eu l'occasion d'avoir
effectivement accès au logement on en
reparlera il aura peut-être eu accès à
la santé on en reparlera aussi il aura
peut-être fait des enfants sur le
territoire national et s'il a fait des
enfants et s'il s'est marié alors le
minist d'intérieur ne peut pas
l'expulser puisqu'il rentrera dans les
réserves d'ENT publi qui m'empêche de
l'expulser ce que je vous demande c'est
qu'on puisse dire oui ou non à quelqu'un
mais vite pour la première fois le
gouvernement ne vient pas devant vous en
changeant les pays qui sont sûrs ou pas
sûr ou change les critères de l'asile il
vous dit que nous avons en moyenne des
bons critères des agents courageux à
l'OF pra des juges en général qui
écoutent la demande du ministère de
l'intérieur mais qui sont aussi
sensibles à la misère de telle ou telle
personne et que en moyenne nous disons
non à 70 % des gens qui se présentent
chez n simplement nous leur disons NON
au bout de 3 ans et quand on leur dit
oui à la fin au bout de 3 ans est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est une vie pour la
France de les fa viv de l'ADA de l'aide
sociale du Conseil d'État que que qu'on
nous octroie ici de quelques centaines
d'euros et de forcément est parfois pris
dans la spirale soit du travail illégal
soit pire de la difficulté et de la
délinquence ce qu'on vous demande et ce
qui est inspiré par le rapport buffet
c'est la rapidité nous avons 12 Procé
mesames et messieurs les sénateurs notre
droit 12 procédures pour pouvoir
contester des décisions conc les
étrangers il n'y a pas d'autres
contentieux plus complexe nous proposons
de passer de 12 à 3 de 12 à 4 en débat
avec la commission de diviser par 3 de
diviser par 3 le nombre de conteneux
possible pour que nous puissions vite
dire oui ou dire non simplification de
recours à la vidéo audience
simplification dans la réforme de
l'asile en territorialisant
l'ofpr pour que y compris pour la CNDA
il y ait des réponses de proximité pour
la justice administrative pour aller
plus vite simplification de travail des
policiers aujourd'hui les policiers ne
peuvent pas par coerition demander
l'empreinte des personnes c'est dans le
texte de loi simplification pour que
ceux qui sont nos frontières puissent
regarder ce qui se passe dans une
voiture aujourd'hui à la frontière entre
la France et la Belgique ou entre Menton
et l'Italie lorsqu'on voit qu'il y a des
Boué ou des moteurs de bateau dans une
voiture les policiers ne peuvent pas
arrêter cette voiture sans réquisition
du procureur de la République le texte
de loi évidemment simplifie et donne des
moyens à nos policiers simplification
bien évidemment pour tous ceux qui
abusent de notre droit au séjour et
notamment de la demande d'asile le
ministre de l'intérieur ne peut pas
retirer la carte de résident d'un
individu qui aurait imaginons le statut
de réfugi en France imaginons à Chechen
et qui repart allité en
Chechenie les Français doivent savoir
que ministre d'intérieur ne peut pas
tiraer la carte de résident d'un
chechenen qui a le grade si jeux dire de
réfugié politique et qu'il était
repartant en tchenie N donc pas pour
chasser dans le pays qui normalement
mérite qu'on le protège de cette
dictature évidente évidemment je vous
demande de lever tout toutes ces
imperfections et de permettre au
ministre d'intérieur de retirer ces
titre de séjour parce qu'on peut pas se
réfugier dans un politique pour lequel
on a demandé refuge dans un autre pays
ça paraît frapper du coin du bon sens ce
n'est pas le droit français aujourd'hui
simplification aussi dans les titre de
sé jour trop nombreux madame la
rapporteur vous le soulignez souvent
faisons un premier pas en passant la
suppression de 10 titres de séjour pour
le passeport à l'an simplification
simplification
simplification ce texte est donc ferme
mais il n'est cependant pas dépourvu
d'humanité pour la première fois le
gouvernement de la République va
proposer que des enfants de moins de 16
ans ne soient plus dans les centres de
rétention
administratifs le fait déjà depuis un an
et à l'exception de maot qui doit
connaître des dispositions particulières
pour le bien du service public et pour
la raison très particulière de nos
compatriotes Maoris le gouvernement
décide que la pratique soit dans la loi
et propose au au Parlement de
l'adopter ce texte est ferme mais il
respecte les outres maires pour la
première fois un texte régen va traduire
en direct les dispositions qui
concernent l'article 73 ne renverra pas
à une ordonnance si jeose dire les
autres maèes méritent mieux qu'une
habilitation et nous serons extrêmement
ouverts aux dispositions qui n'existent
pas encore dans le texte notamment pour
la Guyane ou pour Maillotte et pour tout
évidemment territoire ultramarin qui
voudra voir son droit particulier
s'appliquer du fait de sa proximité qui
peut penser qu'on peut gérer la Guyane
et Maillotte comme on peut gérer la
corise ou le nord de la France il est
évident que le gouvernement sera très
ouvert aux dispositions proposées par
les parlementaires ultramarins et les
autres ce texte enfin est ferme mais
n'est pas
fermé le gouvernement est à l'écoute de
la Haute Assemblée pour modifier ses
articles pour adopter les amendements d'
qu'ils viennent du moment qu'ils
répondent à l'efficacité à la fermeté et
à la simplicité et pour trouver le
meilleur compromis possible pour que les
Français voient que quel que soit nos
différenceces nous avons compris qu'il
nous demandait d'agir
ensemble ce texte prévoit d'autres
amendements du Gouvernement que j'ai
partagé avec Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs et monsieur le président de
la commission des lois
je proposerai notamment une modification
complète du travail du juge des libertés
et de la détention en lien avec monsieur
le garde des sauts pour que les juges et
liberté de la détention ne libèrent pas
les personnes dans les centres de
rétention administratif pour des raisons
de forme ou de nulité de la procédure
mais qui regarde la dangerosité des
personnes qu'on a voulu mettre en
rétention afin de les expulser
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont en centre de
rétention administratif mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et je vous
rappelle que vous avez voté une loi qui
prévoyait passage de 1300 à 3000 places
centre de rétention administratif sont
des gens qui sont soit affichés pour
radicalisation soit connus pour des
actes de délinquence nous avons changé
le public des personnes qui sont en
centre de rétention administrative et
nous nous concentrons dans l'expulsion
d'abord des personnes dangereuses pour
le bien public je pense que c'est de bon
sens le juge des libertés de détention
ne peut plus agir avec ce public comme
il agissait jadis avec quelqu'un que
l'on mettait dans un centre de rétention
et qui comméit aucun acte délictuel
comme le public est désormais dangereux
dans lescra je souhaite nous souhaitons
je j' espère que le juge et liberté de
détention prennent en compte la
dangerosité et ne n'annule pas le
travail que fait le ministère de
l'Intérieur pour des raison de tampon
qui manque ou pour une unité de
procédure
Bénin le gouvernement proposera
également une interdiction de retour du
territoire national de 5 à 10 ans quand
les gens sont expulsés aujourd'hui nous
prenons une interdiction de retour de 5
ans dans plusieurs cas que je ne peux
expliciter ici ce serait trop long mais
je pourrais détailler devant les
parlementaires nous pensons que 10 ans
qui correspond à la fois aux règles
européennes de voisins et à l'efficacité
pour la sécurité publique de nos
concitoyens est une meilleure règle que
celle de 5 ans le gouvernement va
proposer un amendement qui évitera les
abus de demande d'asile quand un
policier interpelle quelqu'un qui est
irrégulier et que ce personne dit moi je
suis en demande d'asile et qui n'a pas
fait sa demande d'asile précédemment
alors aujourd'hui il relâche cette
personne et il attend que la personne
fasse d'asile demande l'asile et on a
les 3 ans de procédure qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure la disposition que trèf
ferme et très forte que propose le
gouvernement c'est lorsqu'un policier
constatera que quelqu'un est irrégulier
et que cette personne n'a pas déjà
demandé l'asile et qu'il se sert de
l'asile pour rester plus longtemps sur
le territoire que cette demande d'asile
se fasse en rétention et de manière
accélérée le gouvernement va également
et je pense que c'est important vu le
drame de hy dont je rappelle que le
texte était antérieur bien évidemment va
proposer une disposition pour rendre
irrecevable les demandes d'asile de ceux
qui ont déjà l'asile dans un autre pays
qui le cas évidemment de celui qui a
attenté à la vie de ces bébés à h le
gouvernement donc proposera des
modifications encore à ce texte et enfin
je veux le dire le gouvernement n'épuise
pas les autres débats qui pourrai avoir
lieu dans ce texte des débats qui peut
être de nature bien sûr constitutionnel
proposition de loi est bientôt déposée
des débats qui peuvent être de nature
référendire le président de la
République s'est exprimé pour inviter
les partis à discuter de l'ouverture sur
l'article 11 du référendum y compris sur
l'immigration des débats qui peuvent
être européens ou conventionnels
personne n'a jamais dit que ce texte de
loi était la réponse absolument à tout
mais personne ne peut dire sérieusement
que ce texte de loi n'est pas ferme
n'est pas celui qui donnera à nos
policiers et à nos gendarmes des moyens
supplémentaires et personne ne peut dire
que le gouvernement n'est pas ouvert à
la discussion avec le Parlement je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre je vais donner la parole à
Madame Murielle Jourda rapporteur de la
commission des lois
vous avez la parole le rapporteur merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues je ne dispose pas comme
monsieur le ministre d'un temps bien
considérable aussi vais-je vous tracer à
grand trait le travail que nous avons pu
faire à la commission des lois pour
examiner le dernier avatar d'une litanie
de textes sur l'immigration dont le
nombre même nous laisse penser qu'ils
n'ont jamais atteint le le but qui leur
était
assigné ce texte pour l'aborder nous
avons euh d'abord dû prendre en compte
le fait qu'il ne s'agit que la loi
ordinaire et que les contraintes qui
nous sont imposées par la Constitution
par les engagements européens
internationaux de la France nous ne
pouvions euh nous en affranchir dans ce
texte nous avons aussi essayé d'écarter
les quelques ponfs qui peuvent circuler
dans la vie politique française et qui a
à mon sens nuise à la bonne efficacité
euh des décisions que nous pouvons
prendre
non l'immigration n'est pas
systématiquement synonyme de délinquence
et ça se réfère injure à nos concitoyens
qui sont d'origine étrangère que de le
dire en revanche il ne faudrait pas
tomber de l'excès dans l'aveuglement et
ne pas voir qu'un certain type de
délinquence et je pense notamment au
terrorisme islamiste qui sévit sur notre
territoire ne serait pas en lien avec
l'immigration car il est de la même
façon et dans un autre ordre d'idée voir
inversé je suis désolé monsieur le
ministre c'est vous qui prononcez le
plus souvent cette parole mais on ne
peut pas toujours dire que l'immigration
soit une chance pour la France
évidemment on peut penser et on peut
voir que les étrangers
peuvent peuvent sans doute utiliser leur
force à occuper un certain nombre de
métiers en France mais c'est plus me
semble-t-il une question d'organisation
du travail qui est propre à notre marché
du travail qu'autre chose on peut aussi
se dire que effectivement côtoyer une
culture étrangère est assez
enrichissante et cela est exa si ce
n'est que aujourd'hui et bien parfois
quand cette culture prend une place qui
permettre à nos concitoyens de ressentir
ce que Laurent Bouvet avait théorisé
sous le terme d'insécurité culturelle
c'est-à-dire la sensation que
effectivement l'insécurité culturelle
caractérisée par le fait que notre
propre culture est contrecarrée sur
notre propre territoire et bien ces
citoyens n'estiment pas que ce soit une
chance pour la France et puis je vais
vous le dire comme je le pense je pense
que même les immigrés estiment qu'ils ne
viennent pas en étant une chance pour la
France lorsqu'on quitte sa terre natale
lorsqu'on quitte ses proches lorsqu'on
quitte tout ce qui nous est familier
notre histoire notre tradition nos
cultures et bien il ne faut jamais
sous-estimer le déchirement qui est ce
départ l'immigration c'est quelque chose
mais l'immigration est toujours une
souffrance pour celui qui part et
lorsqu'en plus il donne les économies
familiales à ces nouveaux esclavagistes
que sont les passeurs pour risquer sa
vie en Méditerranée l'immigré ne vient
pas parce qu'il pense nous rendre
service il vient parce qu'il pense que
la chance c'est la France et que la
France est une chance pour lui alors
tous ces ponifs ne sont pas si simple
toute cette situation n'est pas si
simple et effectivement c'est en
l'écartant que nous
avons aborder ce texte en définissant
aussi c'était également un préalable ce
qu'une politique migratoire une
politique migratoire dans un pays des
frontières c'est une politique qui
consiste à dire qui a le droit d'entrer
qui a le droit de rester et à quelles
conditions dans un pays qui n'est pas le
sien et c'est ainsi que nous avons pu
constater que s'il existe 187 titres de
séjours différents en France et que
chacun sait comment y rentrer il existe
un manque terrible qui est de dire qui
et pourquoi les étrangers peuvent venir
en France et c'est pourquoi l'apport
principal de la commission des lois a
été d'introduire un titre un premier
titre qui vise a véritablement maîtrisé
l'entrée sur le territoire car lorsqu'on
travaille sur ces sujets ça été notre
cas avec Monsieur bon carère pendant 4
ans sur le budget ça a été le cas du
président buffet depuis de nombreuses
années ce que l'on peut constater c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le nombre d'entrées
sur le territoire qui nuit à la
véritable politique migratoire car nous
ne savons pas accueillir nous ne savons
plus intégrer et tout qu' fait nous
n'appliquons même plus les textes que
nous votons car lorsqu'on rentre en
France y compris lorsqu'on perd son
titre de de ses jours aprèsêre rentré
légalement et bien nous n'avons pas la
capacité aujourd'hui en France
d'éloigner les personnes qui sont en
situation clandestine c'est-à-dire
celles qui ne respecte pas la loi
française donc ce premier titre a
consisté à tout d'abord organiser un
débat au Parlement avec la fixation de
quota autant que faire ce peut nous
dirons qui va rentrer sur le territoire
et dans quelle quantité et nous avons
également ajouter dans ce premier titre
un certain nombre de conditions pour
resserrer le regroupement familial le
titre étranger le titre étudiant
également qui se doit d'être
effectivement contrôlé plus qu'il ne
l'est aujourd'hui voilà quel est
l'apport principal de la Commission et
sur les autres sujets nous en débattrons
pendant cette séance merci merci madame
le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Philippe boncarer rapporteur de
la commission des lois vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mes chers collègues après avoir
rappelé les propos du président Larcher
sur l'immigration la situation n'est
plus tenable vous avoir dit que le
travail technique entre les rapporteurs
s'était très bien déroulé que la
majorité sénatoriale est d'accord sur la
quasi totalité des sujets et vous avoir
dit qu'il existe et vous avoir dit qu'il
existe des solutions pour écrire
l'article 3 je voudrais organiser mon
propos introductif sur quatre points
premièrement nous avons une obligation
de résultat deuxièmement l'engagement de
fermeté respecté troisièmement nous vous
proposons un retour du Parlement dans la
définition de la politique migratoire et
qurièmement nous nous inscrivons dans le
cadre conventionnel et institutionnel le
tout au service de l'action publique
premièrement une obligation de résultat
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là et
bien le Sénat doit adopter un texte
personne ne comprendrait qu'il ne soit
pas en mesure de répondre à l'attente de
nos concitoyens et vous savez aussi que
le refus du temps dit programmé à
l'Assemblée nationale peut laisser
planer un doute sur la capacité de
celle-ci d'aller au bout des débats et
donc personne ne comprendrait que les
deux assemblées ne soient pas en mesure
d'élaborer un texte c'est une question
légitimité parlementaire et tout
particulièrement pour le Sénat vous le
savez tous nous estimons que le Sénat
est aujourd'hui le point d'équilibre
institutionnel il nous appartient d'être
cohérent avec nous-mêmes et de le mettre
en œuvre dans ce texte vous dire
également que deuxièmement ce texte
introduit des éléments indiscutable de
de fermeté vous en aurez de nombreux
témoignages c'était déjà l'objet du
texte présenté par Monsieur le Ministre
de l'Intérieur qui vientent de
s'enexliquer vous avez eu une première
étape avec la commission des lois du
mois de mars et à l'occasion de la
séance une deuxième étape nous permettra
d'adopter de nouveaux amendements c'est
bien un nouveau paysage de la politique
migratoire du pays qui se dessine et non
une addition de mesures vous dire aussi
troisièmement que il y a me semble-t-il
dans ce texte en tout cas dans
l'évolution que nous avons voulu lui
donner un retour du Parlement à quoi je
fais référence je fais référence au fait
que la politique migratoire n'est pas
simplement une politique diplomatique
pas plus qu'une politique mémorielle
elle est régalienne elle s'écrit au
présent et elle s'écrit au présent sous
le contrôle du Parlement dans le débat
annuel que nous vous proposons l'article
1a du texte à travers les nombreuses
données euh attendues bien nous
souhaitons vous donner ou nous donner
collectivement les moyens d'être
beaucoup plus précis sur les évaluations
de notre politique migratoire et surtout
d'en fixer les objectifs c'est bien ça
l'idée de l'article 1a c'est que le
Parlement puisse redonner un cap sur la
définition de de la politique migratoire
et 4ème et dernier élément vous dire que
nous avons essayé d'inscrire notre
action en tout cas l'analyse que V
rapporteurs ont fait des amendements
dans le respect de nos engagements
conventionnels et de notre Constitution
alors j'entends très bien le débat dans
la société entre liberté individuelle et
droits collectif mais je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas que l'État de droit entrave
l'action publique la CEDH admet une
marge d'appréciation nationale et si
l'on veut bien regarder avec précision
les décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
celui-ci n'a jamais interdit au pouvoir
exécutif ou à l'exécutif
ou au législatif de mettre en œuvre ses
politiques avec ces différents éléments
je voulais finalement peut-être
anticiper sur la suite du débat et vous
dire qu'il faudrait faire attention à ne
pas introduire des données
inconstitutionnel qui n'apporte rien à
la crédibilité du Parlement et surtout
qui se retend ensuite à une censure
laisseraiit entendre à nos concitoyens
qu'en fait l'action publique ne serait
pas possible et c'est par cela que je
terminerai en vous disant que je crois
très profondément que la politique
migratoire qui vous est proposée
peut-être efficace elle ne sera jamais
efficace à 100 % et je partage le
sentiment d'humilité qui vous a été
exprimé en préambule par le ministre de
l'intérieur mais c'est un discutablement
avec ce texte une politique qui sera
plus efficace et aussi avec les
amendements que vous apporterez merci à
tous et à toutes de votre
attention nous
allons maintenant passer à la discussion
d'une motion tendante à opposer
l'exception du recevabilité madame
Cécile cuerman les membres du groupe
communiste républicain citoyens et
cégist kanaki ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 1 tendant à
opposer l'exception
d'irrecevabilité au texte en discussion
je donne la parole maintenant à madame
la Présidente Cécile C
Caran pour la
motion vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues loin de nous l'idée en
déposant cette motion de laisser
sous-entendre qu'il n'y aurait pas lieu
de débattre de l'immigration dans notre
pays mais nous demeurons convaincu que
ce n'est pas avec ce texte que nous
répondrons à deux des nombreux défis de
demain l'explosion des migrations de par
le monde la lutte contre le terrorisme
et plus particulièrement actuellement le
terrorisme islamique radical nous nous
devons donc un discours de vérité sans
excès mais empli de sincérité et de
conviction sur ce sujet monsieur le
ministre c'est dans cet état d'esprit
que s'inscrit mon groupe à l'hône de
l'examen des articles de votre projet de
loi un discours de vérité car il ne
faudrait pas laisser à penser que
gestion des politiques migratoires et
lutte contre le terrorisme vont
forcément de paire il n'y a d'ailleurs
et malheureusement qu'à se retourner sur
la dernière décennie et les attentats
dont notre pays a été victime pour
constater de suite qu'immigration ne
riment pas avec terrorisme ne laissons
donc pas croire ici aux Français que ce
texte est un texte pour leur sécurité ne
laissons pas croire non plus que la
France pourrait stopper les migrations
de milliers de populations qui fuit le
dérèglement climatique les guerres la
famine le drame les drames récents et
notamment celui de l'ampedusa le
démontre oui massivement ces femmes et
ces hommes qui traverse le monde au
péril de leur vie le font car c'est pour
eux la seule chance de survie une partie
de notre planète subit actuellement
famine et ségeresse quasi permanente
cette réalité ce sont les pays les plus
riches de notre planète qui en sont
souvent les premiers responsables
déforestation massive
hyperurbanisation exploitation et
assèchement des cours d'eau exploitation
des océans et des fonds marins à ces
migrations se rajoutent les nombreux
conflits qui parfois bien loin des
plateaux de télévision font des milliers
de morts des milliers de prisonniers des
milliers de filles privées des école des
milliers d'enfants soldats des milliers
de femmes violées la réalité de la
guerre et des dictatures c'est celle-ci
et là encore c'est au péril de leur vie
à pied derrière des camions ou dans des
bateaux de fortune que chaque jour des
milliers de personnes tentent de fuir
vers un eldorado que notre pays parmi
d'autres incarne et pourtant à leur
arrivé l'Eldorado s'effondre ils ont
cherché à partir pour vivre ils restent
ici pour survivre notre devoir au pays
de Voltaire et d'Hugo et de les
accueillir avec humanité oui nous avons
un impératif les sortir des mains de
tous les passeurs trafiquants et
exploiteurs en tout genre or votre texte
n'y répond pas au contraire il tente à
stigmatiser un peu plus encore ces
femmes et ces hommes qui n'ont plus rien
en les rangeant dans le camp de ceux qui
nuirait à notre pays mais de quelle
nuisance parlons-nous pour cell et ceux
qui ne l'auraient vu je vous invite à
revoir ce magnifique documentaire
diffusé sur France Télévision nous les
ouvriers je vous invite à relire notre
histoire de France pour mesurer au
combien bien loin d'être dé nuuisances
ces femmes et ces hommes ont aidé la
France à se construire à se défendre à
se reconstruire pmel ils étaient
marocains tunisiens algérien sénégalais
ivoirien polonais italien espagnol
portugais et de tant d'autres pays en
ils ont tous connu à leur arrivée
l'hostilité plus ou moins mondaine
parfois d'ailleurs d'un racisme
ordinaire mais par le travail par
l'exigence de notre République à faire
du commun et non du communautarisme ils
se sont intégrés et ont su vivre
ensemble en France je ne fais preuve
d'aucun angélisme ici car oui le monde a
changé et oui notre République ses
valeurs ont faibli la République publ
dans la Constitution est définie comme
indivisible laïque démocratique et
social à nos yeux c'est en confortant
ces quatre principes que nous que nous
sortirons du débat nosé àond auquel nous
assistons depuis plusieurs années dans
notre pays un débat qui a fait renoncer
les gouvernements successifs convaincu
que la répression et la négation même de
la réalité réglerait le problème mais il
n'en est toujours rien au contraire à
nier cette réalité nous avons affaibli
notre République en renvoyant dans le
communautarisme ces personnes-là en les
excluant de nous-mêmes de notre commun
en les déshumanisant même parfois en
renforçant ainsi l'emprise des marchands
de sommeil des patrons voyou et autres
exploiteurs de la misère humaine et le
débat que nous aurons etci même sur
l'aide médicale d'État en est un exemple
frappant privé de soins préventifs des
femmes et des hommes au détriment de
toute politique de senti publique c'est
une catastrophe pour ces individus comme
pour notre société enfin ne soyons pas
hypocrite nous sommes nombreux dans nos
départements à avoir des parcours de
réussite et pas seulement dans les
métiers en tension nous sommes
d'ailleurs nombreux à solliciter les
préfets ici ou là pour de nombreuses
dérogations aux droits existants parfois
même monsieur ministre à vous
interpeller directement alors si le
monde a changé nous devons donc
renforcer nos politiques nous devons
renforcer le droit au travail pour ces
femmes et ces hommes qui d'ailleurs ne
demandent que ça nous devons renforcer
la prise en charge de l'apprentissage du
français pour décommunautariser ces
personnes et les rendre libres de leur
destinée enfin nous devons créer les
structures d'accueil dignes du pays des
droits de l'homme à l'inverse de se
satisfaire des dormeurs de rue ceci doit
se traduire dans la loi loi et non en
renforçant le pouvoir discrétionnaire
des préfets un autre sujet je l'évoqué
est celui de la lutte contre le
radicalisme sachez monsieur le ministre
que nous serons toujours de ce combatlà
nous le savons et à titre d'exemple
l'histoire algérienne des années 90 le
démontre le radicalisme islamiste n'aime
pas les progressistes car à la doctrine
de Dieu nous répondons par la doctrine
de la République à la doctrine de
l'immobilisme facilitatrice de
l'exploitation de l'homme par
nous répondons par la doctrine de
l'éducation et de la construction d'un
esprit critique seul facteur
d'émancipation pour les femmes et les
hommes nous ne voulons pas une
république uniformée mais une république
qui rassemble qui conjugue les talents
de chacun au service de tous Quelques
remarques de forme pour finir dans la
lignée des précédents texte ce projet de
loi participe de faites à l'inflation
normative une loi sur l'immigration tous
les 18 mois ce qui est sans équivalent
et au non respect des principes de
sécurité juridique et d'intelligibilité
de la loi alors que nous ne dispose pas
d'un appareil statistique complet ni de
bilan de la loi du 10 septembre 2018 qui
s'assignait les mêmes objectif selon
l'avis du Conseil d'État ce n'est pas
respectueux du travail de la
représentation nationale ce texte nous
le pensons en cour fortement la censure
du Conseil constitutionnel il porte plus
que jamais atteinte au droit de mener
une vie fam normale protégé par les
juristes européennes tiré de l'article 8
de la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme et constitutionnelle le
Conseil le liant au droit au respect de
la vie privée fondé sur l'article 2 de
la Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et
du Citoyen enfin il est examiné dans un
contexte particulier je l'évoquais de
stigmatisation des étrangers et d'un
concours l'épine des propositions les
plus dures pouvant aller jusqu'à une
remise en cause de l'état de droit qui
n'est pourtant pas toujours assumé y
compris lorsqu'il est question pour
certains acteurs politiques de bousculer
une constitution à l'égard de laquelle
ils sont d'ordinaire beaucoup plus
prudent c'est un texte rempli de
contradiction comment peut-on en même
temps poursuivre un objectif
d'intégration des des étrangers et s'ans
prendre au regroupement familial comment
peut-on en même temps vouloir accélérer
les procédures d'expulsion et augmenter
les délais de rétention comment peut-on
en même temps durcir les sanctions
contre les marchandes sommeil et ne pas
accompagner davantage les victimes
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous l'aurez compris nous ne partagons
ni le texte du Gouvernement ni celui
réécrit ici par la droite sénatoriale
cependant nous aurons jusqu'au bout le
débat avec vous car nous demeurons
convaincus que c'est dans le débat dans
la confrontation et dans la
contradiction que nous avancerons t le
sens de cette question préalable et
parce que et je le sais et sans surprise
elle se sera rejeté je veux vous dire
ici à chacune et chacun que nous ne
lâcherons en rien sur notre capacité à
article par article vous faire la
démonstration que d'autres solutions
sont possibles sans être néfastes à
notre République et en la faisant
grandir sur la route de l'humanité je
vous remercie merci madame la
[Applaudissements]
Présidente y a-t-il rateur contre la
d'exception
d'irrecevabilité il y en a pas quelle
est l'avis de la commission
oui monsieur le Président l'avis de la
commission et vous vous en doutez
défavorable pour quelques raisons que je
vaisquer rapidement la première en
disant madame la Présidente Kirman que
l'aspiration qui la sienne à ce que le
débat soit poursuivi et amplifié suppose
déjà que le texte puisse se poursuivre
deuxièmement lui dire que elle appelle à
un discours de
vérité c'est bien quand même le point de
départ avec un flux d'immigration
irrégulière important entre 600 et
900000 personnes présentes sur notre sol
un dispositif d'intégration qui est en
panne et une difficulté pour pas dire
une incapacité chronique à atteindre nos
objectifs quant au nombre de demandes
d'asile nous serons peut-être aux
environ de 150000 C ce qui est sera le
nombre le plus important même si la
France est loin d'être le pays le plus
attractif si vous me permettez cette
formule quant au nombre je terminerai
mon propos en reprenant deux éléments
vous avez fait référence madame la
Présidente au fait qu'il y avait des
conflits multiples vous avez bien sûr
raison ce qui est une manière de dire
que le texte comme quelque foois je
l'entends dire n'est pas une réponse à
une sorte d'air du temps à un air de
stimatisation mais correspond bien à une
situation Gé politique avec un fort
niveau de d'instabilité vous avez
également madame présidente parmi vos
les nombreux points que vous avez
abordés appeler à faire du commun
comment faire du commun dans la France
2023 c'est effectivement un objectif que
l'on peut volontiers partager tout en
émettant un avis défavorable sur la
motion que vous venez nous présenter
monsieur le ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement merci monsieur le président
bon évidemment un avis défavorable mais
euh peut-être dire à à madame la
Présidente d'abord que je partage avec
elle l'envie que ce débat se déroule on
se l'est déjà dit dans des conditions
évidemment respectueuses du débat
républicain parce que quand on parle
d'immigration il me semble l'avoir dit à
la tribune on parle effectivement de
femmes et d'hommes d'enfants mais on
parle aussi de femmes et d'hommes qui au
nom de la République agissent écoutent
ou parfois accompagnent c'est le cas des
association donc évidemment toujours un
débat respectueux puisquon ne parle pas
de matière on ne parle pas d'argent sans
doute les deux respectables mais enfin
ce qui est important effectivement c'est
c'est l'humain et la seule querelle qui
vaille c'est c'est l'homme si ce n'est
l'humain d'abord voilà donc je voulais
je voulais évidemment vous dire Madame
présidente que c'est dans cet esprit que
que travaille le le gouvernement
peut-être deux points très rapides
madame la Présidente cependant dans
votre intervention je voudrais
m'inscrire en faux le premier c'est de
dire je l'entends souvent cet argument
et partout euh c'est de dire ah il y a
eu 20 lois en 30 ans une tous les 18
mois bon d'abord c'est c'est tout à fait
faux depuis que le Président de la
République est en responsabilité il y a
eu une seule loi en 2018 donc c'est la
deuxème loi en 6 ans sur
l'immigration alors voilà Monsieur ro
dit il en faudrait d'autres bon très
bien donc il faudrait que vous mettiez
d'accord mais mais on peut pas dire que
le gouvernement fut pris à pic sur les
questions de loi migratoire ces
dernières années une tous les 6 ans ça
me paraît raisonnable deuxièmement vous
avez voté combien de textes budgétaires
cette année combien de textes sur
l'écologie combien de textes sur
économie et
devant trop pas assez voyez on voit bien
la majorité sénatoriale dans sa
diversité pourquoi les questions
migratoires qui répondent qui répondent
et vous l'avez dit vous-même madame la
Présidente à une actualité
internationale forcément évidemment que
ce qui se passe dans certains pays
lorsque les talibans prennent en
responsabilité l'Afghanistan lorsqual
Bangladesh qui subit qui subit qui subit
des désirs qui subit des désirs de
changement
climatique lorsqu'il y a des difficultés
extrêmement fortes lorsque l'armée
française se retire du sel lorsqu'il y a
des coups d'État bien sûr que ça a des
conséquences sur notre pays et c'est
quand même étonnant d'avoir ce genre
d'argument l'immigration sans doute la
matière qui évolue le plus non pas selon
nos propres désirs nationaux mais selon
ce qui se passe à l'extérieur de notre
pays et considérer qu'il faudit pas
qu'on s'adapte ça me paraît un drôle de
raisonnement au contraire ça me paraît
difficile de ne pas adapter nos règles
de droit au moment même au moment même
où on a des changements vous savez
j'entends beaucoup de comparaisons j'ai
entendu d'ailleurs des comparaisons pour
dire ah bah il y a 20 ans il y a 25 ans
oui c'est vrai c'est Monsieur Sarkozi
qui avait fait la double peine vous le
reprochez aujourd'hui ou alors à
l'époque lesqutf mais il y a 25 ans le
monde était totalement différent le
minintérieur qui était à ma place il
avait une discussion politique et
diplomatique avec la Libye avec
l'Afghanistan avec la Syrie avec le Mali
avec le Niger avec l'Irak quel ordre
mondial désormais comparer ce qui est
incomparable me paraît pas très honnête
intellectuellement donc il est normal
que d'utiliser la loi de la République
et peut-être d'autres instruments selon
les avancées des uns et des autres pour
modifier nos textes et notre texte
législatif et nos textes réglementaires
pour s'adapter au désordres du monde
l'immigration s s'adapter
malheureusement ou heureusement au
désordres du monde donc l'argument de y
a une loi tous les 18 mois d'abord elle
est fausse le président de la République
elle vaut pour d'autres gouvernements
elle vaut pour le gouvernement
socialiste va pour le gouvernement de
droite bah oui vous en avez fait
plusieurs des loisimigration donc c'est
pas très grave et tant mieux ces
personnes c'est pas moi qui vous le
reprocherait et cependant depuis 6 ans
nous avons eu nous un seul texte à vous
proposer le deuxème point c'est sur la
CEDH la vie privée et familiale est
garantie mais la vie privée et familiale
est pas absolue la vie privée familiale
n'est pas absolue madame la Présidente
le législateur depuis très longtemps y
compris sous un gouvernement de gauche
les fondamentaux de la nation contre le
terrorisme qui on été pris par le
ministre casenu par un gouvernement
totalement je crois de gauche il y avait
pas de doute possible soutenu d'ailleurs
je me semble-t-il par une gauche très
plurielle bah le gouvernement de
Monsieur Hollande a considéré que vie
privée familiale d'accord mais pas pour
les terroristes bah nous disons on dit
vie privée familiale d'accord mais pas
pour les criminels bah ça me paraît
assez normal j'ai eu le cas madame la
Présidente à connaître de quelqu'un qui
était connu pour pédophilie condamné
comme tel criminalité condamné comme tel
oui mais il y a pas criminalité dans le
texte aujourd'hui non mais de de CRIM
pédophile de CRIM pédophile pardon si je
me suisexprimé madame la ministre
condamné comme tel dont on m'a dit qu'on
ne pouvait pas demander l'expulsion au
nom de la vie privée et familiale parce
qu'il avait des enfants vous avez
l'absurdité l'absurdité dans laquelle
parfois le droit est plongé du fait que
la loi aujourd'hui est surannée dépassée
ne correspond plus aux difficultés
auxquelles nous faisons face et auquell
le peuple français demande que nous
légiférions donc la vie privée et
familiale oui mais pas n'importe quel
prix a un équilibre à avoir entre les
besoins de la nation les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation ça c'est le
terrorisme mais l'ordre public qu' soit
grave ou simple on verra sur les
articles 9 10 13 et moi je suis
favorable effectivement que nous n
censurions pas et que nous puissions
dire nous demandons l'expulsion des
personnes même s'ils ont une vie privée
et familiale en France à partir du
moment où ils ne respectent pas l'ordre
public à partir du moment ils respecte
pas les intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation nous avons le droit nous de nous
en séparer et la CEDH ne dit pas le
contraire je constate que dans laffire
yquissen alors même que le texte n'avait
pas changé et que le Conseil d'État
s'est inspiré du la loi séparatisme que
vous avez voté ici nous avons obtenu
l'expulsion de monsieurquissen contre la
vie du tribunal administratif de Paris
alors que son avocat demandait la vie
privée et familiale alors que ces quatre
enfants étaient nés en France et majeur
en France qu'il était lui-même
propriétaire en France depuis plus de 40
ans qui s'était marié en France et que
nous avions réussi à démontrer qu'il
lutter avec séparatisme contre la
République nous avons obtenu son
expulsion le juge et notamment le juge
européen NOTAM le juge che DH parce que
c'est possible pour c'est possible pour
le séparatisme et pas pour les crimes et
délits madame gonri on aura l'occasion
d'en parler si vous n'êes pas toujours
convaincu ce qui est possible pour les
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation et
séparatissteme possible pour les CRIM et
délit c'est toute la démonstration de ce
texte et je je crois qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler enfin
l'exception d' respabilité monsieur le
Président c'est je crois pour dire que
ce texte ne respecte pas les règles de
droit de notre Constitution le Conseil
d'État a donné un avis très favorable à
ce texte dans les dispositions
présentées par le gouvernement c'est une
très bonne chose et assez rare pour être
souligné les laissz le Conseil
constitutionnel faire son office je suis
sûr qu'il sera
saisi il y a-t-il des demande
d'explication de vote je rappelle qu'ils
sont limités à un par groupe sil en a
pas je vais consulter le Sénat sur
l'exception
d'irrecevabilité je rappelle que
l'adoption de cette motion entraînerait
le rejet du texte en discussion qui est
pour cette exception
d'irrecevabilité manifeste en levant la
main
avis
contraire n'est pas
adopté nous allons passer à la
discussion de la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable
elle a été déposé par Monsieur Thomas
deessur les membres du groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire je vous donne la parole pour
la motion mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame la ministre mes chers
collègues 4 ans après l'entrée en
vigueur de la dernière loi asile
imigration monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous vous présenter devant
nous avec un nouveau texte de nouveau
pour contrôler l'immigration et
améliorer l'intégration dites-vous
l'immigration et vous l'avez dit ce sont
avant tout des immigrés des hommes et
des femmes des enfants des ados avec
leur situation particulière leurs
parcours leurs aspirations leurs
difficultés et des difficultés il y en a
de loi en loi le parcours administratif
d'une personne étrangère en France est
devenu de plus en plus
indigne la conception disuisive des
politiques françaises d'immigration est
devenue un facteur de désordre permanent
la situation de nombreux étrangers en
France parfois de mineurs est marqué par
l'extrême précarité et une succession
perpétuelle d'obstacles de l'accès aux
préfectures et à l'OFI pour l'obtention
ou le simple renouvellement d'un titre
de séjour en passant par l'accès au
travail jusqu'à une prise en charge mé
ic effective tout est fait texte après
texte pour rendre le parcours chaotique
un rapport de l'Assemblée nationale sur
les moyens des préfectures pour
l'instruction des demandes de séjour de
2021 décrit une situation qui a encore
empirée depuis lors du jour au lendemain
faute de rendez-vous des personnes en
situation parfaitement régulière inséré
professionnellement et socialement
basculle en situation irrégulière entre
deux titres et perdent leurs droits
entre 2019 et 2022 les réclamations
relatives au droits des étrangers on
augmenté de 203 33 % et le droit des
étrangers est devenu le premier motif de
cisine du Défenseur des droits passant
de 10 % des réclamations reçues par
l'institution à 24 %. cet accroissement
concerne essentiellement l'obtention de
rendez-vous les difficultés en lien avec
la dématérialisation des guichets et les
délais d'instruction excessifs cette
mise en désordre de l'immigration et ce
renoncement à nos valeurs se manifeste
aussi et en premier lieu à nos
frontières le rétablissement des
frontières depuis 2015 sans cesse
renouvelé entre la France et l'Italie
est le symbole de l'absurdité de cette
politique une une frontière de plus en
plus militarisé avec des effectifs de
plus en plus nombreux mais qui n'ont
pour seul effet que de rendre plus
dangereuse la traversée des montagnes et
qui malgré la solidarité des montagnards
provoque régulièrement des drames il y a
2 semaines un mort un homme est mort
dans la Durance la rivière qui coule
près de brillan son alors qu'il tentaiit
d'échapper à un contrôle cela n'est pas
acceptable alors disons-le un contrôle
aux frontières entre la France et
l'Italie oui c'est l'idéal européen qui
meurt à petit feu à chaque fois qu'on
renouvelle le rétablissement de cette
frontière entre nos pays face à cela
monsieur le ministre vous nous proposez
donc de contrôler l'immigration et
améliorer l'intégration contrôler avec
un mot d'ordre clair que vous répétez à
l'envie dans les médias et encore ici
fermeté fermeté fermeté pourquoi les
motivations réelles de ce texte restent
flou le Conseil d'État comme le
Défenseur des droits on manifester
clairement leur regret face à l'absence
d'une d'une motivation sérieuse à ce
texte je cite l'exposé des motifs et
l'étude d'impact ne permett pas
d'apprécier la mesure des phénomènes que
le projet de loi devrait réguler ou
l'inefficacité des dispositions
législatives actuelles pour rendre les
objectifs visés nous dit ainsi le
Défenseur des droits du fait de la
faiblesse de cet exposé des motifs et de
l'étude d'impact le même Défenseur des
droits s'inquiétait déjà en février dans
son avis que le débat public risque
d'être soutendu par des représ enttion
erronée voire discriminatoire de
l'immigration on peut dire qu'elle ne
s'était pas trompé dans votre texte ces
représentations erronées se manifeste
clairement par le renforcement de
l'arbitraire administratif pour vous
comme pour vos prédécesseurs le sérieux
d'une politique migratoire réside
uniquement dans la notre capacité à
expulser donc vous présupposez qu'en
multiplication qu'en multipliant la
distribution des obligations de quitter
le territoire français en ajoutant
contraintte et arbitraire administratif
sur les personnes étrangères présente
sur notre territoire vous afficherez la
fermeté propre à votre ambition
politique mais la réalité on la connaît
vous n'allez qu'amplifier le désordre et
la précarité quand la machine
administrative broie arbitrairement par
son organisation ou plutôt son incurie
la vie des personnes étrangères elle
alimente aussi le désarroi des agents
des préfectures ou des travailleurs
sociaux pour utant est-ce que ce texte
va réduire le contentieux le Conseil
d'État dans son avis douche un peu vos
espoirs la réforme ne permettra pas par
elle-même de limit la part substantielle
et croissante du contentieux des
étrangers dans l'activité de la
juridiction administrative je cite ce
tour de vis législatif supplémentaire va
en revanche impacter la vie des
personnes pourtant installées depuis
longtemps sur notre territoire la loi
prévoit ASI des capacités élargies de
lever les protections particulières pour
appel cette protection vise à empêcher
de prononcer des otf à l'encontre des
étrangers qui sont soit père ou mère
d'un enfant français mineur résidant en
France marié à un ou ou une française
qui réside en France depuis plus de 10
ans ou qui justifi d'un domicile
régulier en France depuis la veille de
leur 13 ans pour toutes ces personnes
donc une OQTF pourra être prononcée non
pas comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui si
elles sont condamnées à plus de 50
prisons mais si elles ont été condamnées
par un délit passible de 50
d'emprisonnement au-delà de la
distorsion évidente de l'égalité face à
la loi de toutes et tous un étranger est
ainsi reconnis coupable au maximum de la
peine encourue c'est évidemment la
logique de la double peine qui fait son
retour complet ici durcissement toujours
au sein du texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui cette fois-ci cela concerne
la santé des personnes étrangères la
majorité sénatoriale au Sénat propose et
on ne sait plus trop si c'est avec votre
assentiment personnel monsieur le
ministre de remplacer l'aide médicale
d'État par une aide médicale d'urgence
un accord vaut visiblement bien la mise
en danger de la santé des Français comme
des étrangers les arguments de la
majorité sénatorial ici on les connaît
l'ame coûte cher et son maintien
constituerait un appel d'air à
l'immigration illégale peu importe si
chaque année plusieurs collègues
rappellent que ces deux arguments sont
faux le coût des soins couverts par
laame et du dispositif des soins urgents
et vitaux ne représente que 0,4 % des
dépenses de l'assurance maladie en
France et seulement 51 % des personnes
qui en sont éligibles demandent à
recourir à laame pour des raisons
comptables mais surtout idéologiques on
fragilise la santé des personnes mais
aussi ça paraît évident de toute la
population enfin les débats qui ont
entouré ce t ont évidemment c'est
presque devenu une coutume ici toucher
les associations et les bénévoles cette
fois évidemment celles et ceux qui font
viv no valeur républicaine de fraternité
enant en accompagnant les personnes
migrantes dans leur parcours vous-même
monsieur le ministre vous en êtes pris
directement à la simade récemment mais
ce sont toutes les associations d'aide
aux personnes migrantes qui sont
entravées dans leur action et harcelé
par nos forces de police je l'ai même
moi-même constaté lors d'une maraude
avec les équipes de Médecins du Monde
mais ce constat est largement documenté
au-delà de ma personne ces associations
visent simplement au respect du droit à
la protection des plus fragiles ce sont
les vigis permanentes qui nous alertent
sur l'indignité de nos politiques
migratoires et PAsie au manque
d'investissement de l'État une fois
détaillé le catalogue des mesures de
contrôle de fermeté et de répression il
est temps de parler d'intégration la
carotte après le bâton mais la carotte
est bien maigre et c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire penchons-nous d'abord sur
l'intégration par la langue française
nous pourrions imaginer cette
intégration se manifeste par un
renforcement de l'accès aux formations
et au cour mais la finalité est tout
autre le niveau de langue devient un
outil d'exclusion un motif de refus de
titre une inversion même des des
objectifs fixés la mesure a pour
objectif d'inciter les étrangers
d'inciter les étrangers qui souhaitent
demeurer durablement sur le territoire
français à se mobiliser davantage pour
leur apprentissage de français de
manière à favoriser leur intégration en
France nous dit l'exposé des motif de
votre texte l'incitation par le refus de
carte de séjour drôle de carotte cette
mesure d'incitation a tellement plu à la
droite qu'elle l'a rendu plus expluante
encore sans même se préoccuper de
renforcer cours et formations alors
certes nous pouvions nous pouvons y
venir nous aurions voulu voter l'article
3 de ce texte nous avons toujours
défendu la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier lorsqu'on
travaille ici que souvent on cotise ici
il est logique de bénéficier des mêmes
droits que les travailleurs d'ici il est
vrai qu'au début du texte Olivier dusob
vous accompagnait il brille par son
absence aujourd'hui il a dit disparu
depuis quelques semaines tout comme a
disparu la valeur travail du logiciel de
la droite sénatoriale qui en fait le
casus Bell indépassable ù il faut s'y
faire désormais la droite dite
républicaine pr préfère donc le travail
au noir et l'exploitation des
clandestins mais même vous le monsieur
le ministre vous exigez tout de même une
bonne période de clandestinité dans
l'article 3 en amant de la demande de
Votre titre de séjour métier en tension
il faudra que la personne étrangère sans
droit ni tite vive dans l'ombre esquive
les contrôles pendant 3 ans et et
travail sans droit réel pendant 8 mois
pour obtenir son titre lui permettant de
travailler
légalement l'égalité des droits ajusté à
la part la loi du marché et les hasards
de la vie soit si cela permet d'avoir
d'autres portes de régularisation que la
circulaire dit Vals nous pourrions nous
laisser convaincre dans les jours qui
viennent mes chers collègues vous alle
vous allez jouer l'avenir de milliers de
travailleuses et de travailleurs dans un
calcul des plus cyniques une a une autre
voie et pourtant possible pas moins
ferme pas moins républicaine la crise
ukrainienne et les moyens exceptionnels
déployés dans un temps record en matière
d'hébergement nous l'ONS montré mais
cela demande une approche radicalement
différente cela démangeche qu'on accepte
un changement de rapport dans les liens
entre l'État les collectivités et les
les acteurs de la solidarité pourtant
nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui avec
une loi dans la liignée des dizaines
d'autres qui l'ont précédé qui ne répond
pas aux enjeux actuels en teres de
migration et
d'intégration une fois de plus ce projet
de loi passe à côté de la réalité vécue
par les personnes étrangères un texte
qui va dégrader la situation au lieu de
l'améliorer l'insertion économique et
soci l'accès au droit la formation
l'accès au soins la protection des
mineurs bref la garantie des conditions
d'un accueil digne demande de sortir de
cette approche chentré sur les questions
sécuritaires elle demande une approche
sur les parcours d'hommes et de femmes
comme celles et ceux en tribune
aujourd'hui sur leurs aspirations et
notre
humanité prend une direction
radicalement inverse c'est pourquoi je
vous demande de voter cette motion de
rejet merci quel est l'avis de la
commission
le suspens sera relativement limité il
sera bien entendu défavorable peut-être
dire à notre collègue que nous avons
tous écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention que il nous a indiqué tout
ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire et vous
avez détaillé tout ce que vous reprochez
dans ce texte ou dans le travail
d'amendement réalisé vous nous avez dit
à aucun moment ce qu'il fallait faire et
comment traiter ces sujets sinon en
quelques secondes par la référence à la
solution ukrainienne ce qui était quand
même un peu une forme de pirouette
intellectuelle vous nous avez également
indiquer que il
manquait une étude d'impact que la
mesure des phénomènes n'avait pas été
défin je pense quand même que l'ensemble
des éléments qui se situent qui se
déroulent dans notre société et les
chiffres que j'ai rappelé quant au
nombre de personnes irrégulièr sur notre
territoire quant au nombre de demandes
d'asile et cetera
représentait bien une objectivation du
sujet par ailleurs vous avez ce qui est
tout à fait normal évoquer le détail des
éléments et nous aurons l'occasion si
votre motion est est rejetée de pouvoir
en débattre peut-être un dernier élément
sur ce que vous avez appelé le la
disparition de l'idéal européen c'est un
sujet auquel je suis sensible et pour ma
génération qui a été construite
intellectuellement avec cet idal
européen c'est effectivement un sujet et
vous l'avez entendu dans l'intervention
du ministres tout à l'heure
la la manière de mobiliser aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des P dans les pays de
l'Union Européen sur ces questions est
un sujet douloureux tout le monde
préféraait que les solutions soient
d'ors et déjà soi d'ors et déjà présent
peut-être aussi vous dire que le débat
que vous nous présentez un peu comme
franco-français n'est pas si
franco-français que cela puisque en
réalité il se déroule sur l'ensemble du
continent européen et que quelque part
les discussions que nous avons enin fin
d'après-midi vous les avez également en
Allemagne ne parlons pas de de l'Italie
mais je je partage en tout cas avec vous
l'idée que nous devons reconstituer un
narratif ou voire même un idéal européen
vous comprendrez que la vie soit négatif
merci l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
défavorable y y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote je n'en vois point
je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
question préalable l'adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion qui est pour l'adoption de
cette question
préalable avis
contraire n pas
adopté nous allons passer à la
discussion demandant le renvoi en
commission et
elle a été déposée par notre collègue
Mariepierre de la Gonterie les membres
du groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain je vais lui donner la
[Applaudissements]
parole vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames madame la ministre
monsieur le le président de la
commission Madame et Monsieur le le
rapporteur chers collègues je reprendrai
pour débuter mon propos
le propos de notre collègue Philippe
boncarer le retour du
Parlement nous savons depuis quelques
semaines depuis quelques mois que le
Parlement ne fonctionne pas de manière
comment dire idéale nous le voyons à
l'Assemblée nous en sommes 13e
engagement de responsabilité du
gouvernement motion de censure mais dans
ce paysage parlementaire il y a un îlo
de sérieux
de
robustesse parlementaire et législative
et de travaux accomp ce qui n'empêche
pas d'ailleurs les affrontements c'est
le
Sénat et donc cette motion de renvoi je
vais tenter de vous convaincre de la
voter parce que je pense qu'il ne faut
pas malmener notre démocratie
parlementaire et que c'est pour cela
qu'il faut la voter et que ce serait
l'honneur du Sénat pour trois raisons la
première monsieur le ministre vous
n'êtes pas
après ce texte a connu un parcours pour
le moins chaotique il a été adopté il y
a un an au Conseil des ministres il est
venu une première fois devant la
commission des lois le 15 mars dernier
inscrit à l'ordre du jour puis
désinscrit
8 mois plus tard le voilà en séance
entre-temps vous avez produit un nombre
d'annonces successives non toujours
suivi des faits d'ailleurs
vous vouliez expulser tous ceux qui
manifestent une adhésion à une idéologie
djihadiste radicale un autre jour
expulser tous les fichiers s un troisème
jour augmenté à 18 mois la rétention qui
était aujourd'hui de 90
jours vous êtes aujourd'hui bien seul il
faut bien le dire même si je note qu'une
de vos collègues a estimé devoir venir
au banc du gouvernement monsieur dusop a
disparu
et alors qu'il est signataire du projet
de loi le garde des saut est
momentanément empêché mais nous aurons
l'occasion de demander sa présence
puisque nous avons compris qu'il pouvait
faire plusieurs chos à la fois et
notamment siéger ici sur le banc du
gouvernement lorsque les articles qui le
concne viendront en séance vous avez
depuis lors déposé 28 amendements sans
avis du Conseil d'État évidemment sans
étude d'impact et donc aujourd'hui à
l'évidence la succession de vos annonces
montre que ce texte n'est pas abouti
ensuite je le dirai au président
buffet la commission n'est pas prête
tout d'abord la commission a adopté un
texte singulièrement modifié composé
d'un tiers de membres de cette
commission qui ne sont plus parmi nous
donc lorsque nos collègues Jourda et
boncarrère s'expriment je ne sais pas au
nom de quel collègue il s'exprime
puisqueun tiers d'entre eux n'est plus
des nôtres
ensuite nous avons noté lors de l'examen
par cette commission c'est un fait assez
atypique me semble-t-il que sur deux
articles majeurs les articles 3 et les
articles 4 la commission n'avait pas
d'avis les rapporteurs n'étaient pas
d'accord j'indiquerai d'ailleurs au
ministre quelque chose qui m'a paru
extrêmement étrange au point qu'il a
fallu que je vérifie avec mes collègues
si je m'était pas trompé dans votre
discours de présentation du texte pas un
mot sur ces articles difficiles
et j'ai trouvé très étrange que rien n'a
été dessiné de l'accord possible qui
était semble-t-il envisagé je dis cela
parce que je lis le journal et non parce
que cela se passe en commission nous
avons vu ensuite arriver 28 amendement
du
Gouvernement puis 32 amendements du
rapporteur aujourd'hui des rapporteurs
aujourd'hui même et c'est pour vous dire
que je ne suis pas la seule je pense à
trouver que la Commission n'est pas
totalement n'a pas totalement fait
aboutir ses travaux c'est que le
ministre de l'Intérieur a estimé devoir
initier une réunion délocalisée de la
Commission dans la salle à manger de
beauovau ce qui prouve bien et ce à
cette occasion le président reetaillot
et moi ce n'est pas coutumier nous étons
d'accord avec le fait que les travaux
parlementaires se tenaient au Parlement
et non dans cette salle à manger même si
on m'a dit que le déjeuner était
excellent le troisème point qui fait que
cette motion de renvoi était je n'étais
pas là Monsieur le Ministre donc vous
étiez sans doute en très bonne compagnie
le trisème point qui mène à ce
que cette motion de droit voie doit être
votée c'est que le Sénat n'est pas
prêt nous avons noté que le groupe LR a
déposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui de mon point de
vue fait système avec le texte dont nous
débattons
aujourd'hui pour ma part j'aurais trouvé
logique que le projet de loi
d'aujourd'hui soit débattu après la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle qui
porte en grande partie sur les sujets
d'immigration et donc il me semble que
si le groupe LR qui est très important
ici voulait un travail cohérent il
demanderait l'inscription de ce projet
de loi après l'examen de la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle
ensuite on note une certaine instabilité
au Sénat on a l'habitude des choses bien
faites on arrive en séance la majorité
sénatoriale certes composée de deux
groupes essentiels je ne veux vexer
personnes travaille ensemble
l'opposition s'oppose manière la plus
efficace possible mais je dois dire que
le résultat de notre opposition est
souvent assez
relatif mais dans le cas présent les
articles 3 et 4 et la me font l'objet
sembleil de grandes difficultés entre
vous au point qu'àheure où nous parlons
nous ne savons absolument rien de ce que
vous
entendez ce sur quoi vous entendez
délibérer au point que l'on me dit ça
restera entre nous mais oui r carucci il
y a débat que vous pourriez demander la
réserve des articles 3 et 4 afin de
pouvoir en débattre vendredi je trouve
que c'est une excellente idée pour nos
collègues moi personnellement j'ai prévu
d'être là toute la semaine mais je
l'indique à certains réservez votre
vendredi car c'est ce jour-là que le
débat peut-être aura lieu donc nous le
voyons tout cela n'est pas très sérieux
et très instable alors en con usion je
me suis demandé pourquoi le gouvernement
s'obstinait et pourquoi le ministre de
l'Intérieur s'obstinait à vouloir
présenter ce projet de loi est arrivé le
drame
d'aras et à partir du drame d'aras nous
avons entendu le ministre de l'Intérieur
s'appuyer sur ce fait
terrible pour expliquer que ce projet de
loi était indispensable et de manière un
petit peu
excessive estimer que si ce projet de
loi avait été en vigueur
le drame d'arace aurait pu peut-être
être
évité je regrette ces propos
pourquoi je pense que d'une part le
ministre aurait dû noter et soutenir ses
services car dans le drame d'arace les
services de police ont fonctionné il se
trouve
que il se trouve que la sécurité total
n'existe pas et que lorsque vous
indiquez que si ce projet de loi avait
été voté aras ne se serait pas produit
ce n'est pas exact et donc vous utilisez
et instrumentalisez quasiment cette ce
terrible ce terrible
meurtre pour expliquer qu'il faut voter
ce projet comme une sorte
d'assurance que vous voulez construire
pour éviter d'être mise en cause
ultérieurement peut-être lorsque un
drame analogue pourrait se reproduire
donc au bénéfice de l'ensemble de ces
constats d'impréparation
de manquement et de difficultés à
déterminer une position stable sur un
sujet sérieux nous souhaitons que la
Commission puisse retravailler afin que
dans les jours qui viennent nous
puissions proposer un texte qui soit à
la hauteur de ses
ambitions quel est l'avis
de la commission monsieur
rapporteur l'avis monsieur le Président
sera également défavorable merci bien
sûr à Madame de laonterie d'avoir
débuter son propos par un éloge du
sérieux du travail sénatorial mais vous
savez tous que quand un propos commence
par des félicitations la suite n'est pas
de même nature et cela bien sûr été le
le cas quant au fait de savoir si
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur est
prês ça ou pas ça c'est à lui qu'il
appartiendra de répondre sur le nombre
d'amendements du gouvernement 28 je ne
pourrais pas lui en faire le reproche
puisqu'il y en a 32 de la part des
rapporteurs sur la le fait qu'un des des
collègues euh est été qu'il y a eu une
modification pardon avec le
renouvellement sénateural dans la
composition de notre assemblée vous avez
bien sûr raison tout en attirant votre
attention sur qu'il est fait qu'il
existe une continuité de l'État mais
qu'il existe également une continuité du
par du Parlement ou plus exactement je
crois que le terme institutionnel est
dire que l'assemblée euh est permanente
vous dire enfin sur la référence au
drame d'aras que je ne crois pas que les
dispositions que nous examinons soit des
dispositions qui s'inscrivent dans ce
que j'ai appelé tout à l'heure l'air du
temps je récuse en tout cas dans le
travail des rapporteurs dans le travail
que nous avons pu mener monsieur le
Président buffet dans le cadre de la
commission des lois je récuse que nous
soyons sur un texte d'émotion nous
essayons de trouver des solutions de
moyen et de long terme d'où la demande
de rejet de la motion
présentée merci l' viis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président
permettez-moi madame de La Gonterie
d'abord de de vous dire je TR je trouve
le manque total de délicatesse d'attaque
de Monsieur Dupont moréti qui ne peut se
défendre dans cet hémicycle et je pense
queon devrait plus se poser n'hésitez
pas n'hésitez pas la prochaine fois à
être courageuse devant lui et pas quand
il n'est pas là je pense que ce serait
une première chose
voilà je je je vous ai écouté j'ai même
souffert à vous écouter souffrez un peu
que je vous réponde j'ai l'impression
que
Madame oui oui je sais je sais je sais
mais ce n'est pas fini ça durera jusqu'à
vendredi au moins et j'ai tout mon temps
personnellement madame la sénatrice je
suis à disposition du du Parlement j'ai
l'impression que vous vous êtes en en
fait en train de nous exprimer allez je
vais le dire une forme de de regret
voilà peut-être même d'ailleurs vous
cherchez à vous rattraper vous dites
qu'on est trop dur mais madame de La
Gonterie vous apportenz une majorité qui
a souhaité la déchéance de
nationalité non non non mais je non non
mais bah moi j'étais parlementaire à
l'époque nous étions dans un hémicycle à
Versailles j'ai entendu président
Hollande qui d'ailleurs président
Hollande qui début novembre je vousour
je vous encourage à écouter le président
Hollande qui début novembre dans
l'émission quotidien d'ailleurs je
passerai la bande disait que la loi que
le gouvernement proposait était une loi
qu'il fallait discuter et peut-être même
adopter bon donc non mais je constate
que le président Hollande n'est pas sur
ses bombes et que désormais après
rejeter un certain nombre de personnes
vous rejetez y compris même le président
Hollande ce qui vous sans doute vous
pousse non seulement à ne pas voir que
vous étiez donc favorable chez les
socialistes à déchéance de nationalité
maintenant vous dites que le
gouvernement est trop dur bah écoutez
c'est un président socialiste qui l'a
proposé alors peut-être que Monsieur
Holland était pas un président
socialiste bien bien donc écoutez vous
ferez le procès du président Hollande
plus tard mais quand même je vrais
essayer vous le dire voilà ça fait même
rire l'M ici à droite regardez on arrive
en 3h on arrive à trouver déjà des
motifs des motifs de de d'humour avec
vous Madame de La Gonterie deuxièmement
vous semblez regretter vous dites il y a
trop de lois vous vous avez voté trois
madame de La Gonterie en 5 ans la loi de
décembre 2012
La la la loi de décembre 2012 la loi de
juillet 2015 la loi de mars 2016 ou
d'ailleurs je vousis signé que dans la
loi de mars 2016 du du ministre cas9 qui
autre candidat putatif de la sociale
démocratie que vous soutenez prévoyez et
je pense que c'est un point important là
aussi des mesures extrêmement fortes
contre les étrangers qui étaient qui
faisaent des qui étai en responsabilité
d'actes terroristes suite notamment aux
attentats horribles qu'a connu la France
là vous n'avez pas fait le procès de
suite à un attentat que le gouvernement
a légiféré c'est bien normal que le
gouvernement et que le Parlement
réfléchisse et voit ce qui a pu
disfonctionner trème regret madame de La
Gonterie moi mes services je les
soutiens madame de La
Gonterie les policiers je les S tien ce
qui est sûr c'est que les services
étrangers quand vous étiez en
responsabilité avaient fait leur travail
avec cette famille tchenne radicalisée
c'est pardon de vous le dire votre
gouvernement et la pression de vos amis
et notamment y compris les associations
qui vous soutiennent qu'on fait libérer
cette famille vous avez fait pression
sur les services du ministère de
l'Intérieur vous n'avez pas respecté le
travail du préfet de Bretagne vous
n'avez pas respecté le travail de la
police aux frontières et sur Inquisition
politique vous avez demandé au droit
Fran de reculer vous avez fait libérer
vous et vos amis cette famille si vous
deviez faire le réquisitoire de
quelqu'un c'était réquisitoire de la
pression politique que la gauche a jadis
appuyé en effet quand monsieur Vals été
minist à l'intérieur puisquen effet les
services ministeintérieur avaient très
bien travaillé et s'il y avait en effit
un drame dans la race madame de La
Gonterie c'est d'avoir soutenu cette
proposition de libération de ces
personnes y y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote je n'en vois point
je vais consulter le Sénat sur la motion
de renvoi à la commission si la motion
était adoptée le renvoi du texte à la
commission serait ordonné qui est
favorable à son
adoption avis
contraire il n'est pas
adopté nous allons passer à la suite de
la discussion générale et nous allons
donner la parole à Monsieur Stéphane
Ravier pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs de figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe et Monsieur
ravier dispose de 3
minutes vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le minist
mes chers collègues plus de 2 millions
d'étrangers sont entrés sur le
territoire français sous la macronie
soit l'équivalent de la ville de Paris
selon l'Observatoire de l'immigration et
de la démographie entre 700000 et 900000
clandestins vivent sur notre sol c'est
l'équivalent de la population de
Marseille et 95 % des qtf ne sont pas
exécutés
423000 clandestins bénéficient de l'aide
médicale d'État c'est près de 2000
bénéficiaires supplémentaires en
seulement 6 mois cela nous coûte
1illard200 million d'euros par an selon
la blé des départements de France il y
aurait plus de 40000 prétendus mineurs
non accompagnés pour un coût annuel
moyen de 50000 € par mineur un coût de 2
milliards d'euros par an à la charge du
contribuable français par ailleurs selon
l'INC sur les 2600000 Algériens vivant
sur notre sol 42 % sont chômeurs ou
inactifs tout en bénéficiant de la
panoplie des aides sociales dont ils ne
sont pas contributeurs alors que la
France n'est plus un eldorado mais un
Rado l'immigration coûte selon l'OCDE 35
milliards d'euros finances publiques
françaises chaque année soit
l'équivalent du double des économies de
la réforme des retraites réalisées
jusqu'en 2027 cette immigration
également un coût sécuritaire effarant
les étrangers représentent 10 % de la
population totale de la France mais 25 %
de la population carcérale et sont
responsables de 50 % de la délinquence
et de la criminalité la réalité est
encore plus scandaleuse car ces chiffres
ne prennent pas en compte les
binationaux qui comme Mohamed Mera a
assassiné des enfants juifs parce que
juifs et des soldats français parce que
français parmi le flot des faux réfugiés
et vrai clandestin on compte les
terroristes du Bataclan l'assassin de
Laurin et moral à Marseille de Samuel
pati de Nadine Vincent et Simone dans la
basilique de Nice de Lola de Dominique
Bernard de Fabienne très récemment à
Lille la natalité française s'effondre
pendant que la natalité exogène explose
chez nous plus près d'un tiers des
enfants nés en 2021 ont au moins un
parent né à l'étranger cette réalité de
la submersion migratoire et de la
balance démographique a un nom le grand
remplacement un grand remplacement
cultuel et civilisationnel nous sommes
passés de 100 mosquées en 1970 à 3000
aujourd'hui si bien que la vie de
certains quartiers de certaines villes
de France est rythmé aux heures de la
prière et des us et coutumes islamique
et que les manifestations de soutien au
Hamas se multiplient à travers le pays
au cris de Allah Akbar motivé par la
haine des Juifs et la détestation de la
France le voilà votre bilan suicidaire
de votre politique d'immigration mes
chers collègues car vous êtes tous
responsable de cette folie de ce
désastre à gauche pour être passé du
parti de l'étranger au parti des
étrangers bien sûr on s'en félicite à
droite après 30 ans de naïveté de dénis
mais aussi de soutien et de petit
calculs électoraux on s'en inquiète
enfin alors plutôt que de vouloir sauver
les apparences je vous conjure de sauver
la France ce sont les Français eux-mêmes
qui vous le demandent alors mes chers
collègues j'en appelle à votre courage
et à l'Union ensemble faisons de cette
30e loi sur l'immigration la première et
unique loi sur la non immigration pour
que vive vive la France française dans
une Europe
européenne
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Danny wbl pour le groupe les pendant
République et
territoire
parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président commission des lois
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues il y a plus de 30
ans François mitteran estimé que les CAP
maximales d'accueil des immigrés en
France avait été atteinte dès
1970 ne pas réussir à gérer la question
migratoire depuis des décenes apparaît
aux yeux de concitoyens comme la
démonstration de la puissance de l'État
en 2022 les franchissement illégaux de
la frontière extérieur ont bondit de 64
% par rapport à 2021 ils sont encore en
augmentation
2023 les états y compris au sein de
Frontex ne déoi pas suffisamment des
moyens pour faire face à cet influx
l'immigration légale connaît elle aussi
une forte progression au sein de pays
des pays de l'OCDE 300000 immigrés
permanents en France pour la seule année
2022 ce chiffre bat les records des 15
dernières années malgré cela certains
continuent à appeler à ouvrir grand nos
portes prétendant ainsi défendre les
droits de l'homme et la voix du peuple
cela est illusoire et cela est même
dangereux ilillusoir d'abord car nous
n'ont pas les moyens d'accueillir tout
le monde dans des conditions décentes
dignes dangereux ensuite parce que plus
de 71 % de nos concitoyens considèrent
qu'il y a trop d'immigration et
d'immigré en France le comppatriote ne
souhaite pas l'immigration massive
conscient de cela nous avons aussi gardé
en mémoire les conséquences politiqu des
vagues m migratoires depuis 2015 en
Europe la Grèce aurait procédé à à des
refoulements illégaux la Pologne a géré
avec fermeté la crise provoquée par la
Biélorussie la Hongrie a construit un
mur de barbelé le Royaume-Uni et le
Danemark ont même renvoyé envisagé
d'envoyer des migrants au Rwanda la
France n'a jamais recouru à de tels
procédés les crises géopolitiques
s'enchaînent au Moyen-Orient au Sahel en
Afrique subsaharienne et demain dans le
Golfe de
Guinée il a à craindre que les flux
migratoires vers l'Europe continent de
s'accroître bien encadré l'immigration
peut-être une chance une chance pour
nous tous lorsqu'elle aboutit à de
l'intégration en revanche prétendre
qu'une immigration insuffisamment
maîtrisé n'est pas encore source de
difficulté et malhonnête notre nation
fait face à un déficit de cohésion
l'accueil d'étranger désir nous
rejoindre ne peut pas se faire au prix
de l'AFF de nos valeurs nous voulons
absolument reprendre le contrôle le
projet que nous voyons aujourd'hui que
nous examinons il contribue il aggrave
en premier lieu les sanctions contre les
passeurs tous ceux qui facilitent
l'immigration illégale sur territoire
les sanctions prévues sont lourdes et
disatives elles devront être appliquées
le texte renforce aussi les poss
d'expulsion des étrangers
dangereux aucun de nos compatriotes ne
peut plus comprendre ni accepter que de
tels individus se maintiennent sur notre
territoire ceux qui représente une
menace grave pour notre public ceux qui
ont été condamnés pour des faits
illégaux infraction à la loi pénale ceux
n'ont pas leur place en France ces
mesures protègeront davantage no
citoyens et permettront une meilleure
intégration des étrangers respectueux de
no loi dans le même esprit nous nous
félicitons que l'engagement républicain
soit remis au centre de notre politique
migratoire l'égalité femm homme la
laïcité le respect de la liberté des
valeurs et des symboles de la République
ne sont pas des éléments négociables ils
appartient à ceux qui veulent venir dans
notre pays d'en embrasser la culture et
les
valeurs le projet lo renforce également
les exigences la maîtrise de la langue
française c'est l'une des clés
d'intégration dans notre société l'autre
clé bien sûr est le travail
l'article 3 est sans doute le plus
polémique du texte nous attendons des
débats à venir qui nous permettent de
trouver un point d'équilibre entre d'une
part des situations d'ors et déjà
existantes dans notre pays et la Cé de
pas créer non plus un appel d' d'autre
part l'histoire de notre pays et sa
démographie nous conduisent àer une
politique d'accueil maîtrisé nous devons
absolument veiller à l'éion des lois que
nous votons et à celle des décions
rendues par la justice et par notre
tribunau nous appelons de nos vux une
politique d'immigration choisie nous les
immigrés adis notre pays travaille et
qu'il soit accueill en fonction des
besoins de notre économie et de le
volonté de s'intégrer c'estàd de notre
société c'est cela qui intégration parmi
les besoins se trouve bien sûr les
métiers en tension les métiers
médicsocial le projet de loi prévoit
plusieurs mesures à même deanger le
manque de personnel il y a aussi les
patrons que l'on a peut-être appelé
patron voyou mais il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui veulent régulariser leur
personnel qui sont là présents depuis
plusieurs années et qui ne savaient même
pas qu'il étaient en irrégulière la
question migratoire concerne tant la
France que ses partenaires européens
seul les grands ensembles peuvent
répondre efficacement au grands défis de
notre temps dans le cadre de la difffion
de sa politique migratoire l'Union
européenne doit travailler à soulager
les États membres qui sont en première
ligne la France en fait partie avec nos
partenaires nous devons ensuite négocier
avec plus de fermeté des accords de
réadmission et enfin de renforcer nos
capacités de reconduire hors des
frontières de pays d'origine vers le
pays d'origine si nous parvenons pas à
garder efficacement nos frontières si
nous échouons à faire correspondre
l'immigration aux besoins de nos
sociétés les Européens sont condamnés à
laind division et donc à
l'impuissance ce texte nécessaire et
attendu cons une première réponse aux
attentes de nos concitoyens nous devons
lorsexamen prochain du budget veilleer à
élever nos moyens à la hauteur de nos
ambitions le groupe Les Indépendants
soutient l'adoption de ce projet de loi
je vous
remercie
merci je vais mainten donner la parole à
notre collègue Isabelle Floren pour le
groupe de l'Union
centriste
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames madames et monsieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues ça y
est nous allons enfin examiner ce projet
de loi immigration dont 98 % du texte a
été approuvé en mars et cette attente
nous aura permis de mesurer à quel point
notre droit ne nous permet pas de de
faire face efficacement à l'un des
principaux défis politiques qui est
devant nous en effet pas un mois
malheureusement sans qu'une actualité ne
fasse état de délits commis par une
personne qui n'aurait pas dû être sur
notre sol ou que l'on soit confronté à
ces images de camp de migrants sur
l'espace public malgré les très nombreux
textes législatifs qui se sont succédés
depuis plus de 30 ans la politique
migratoire laisse apparaître une forme
d'impuissance de fatalité que l'État ne
parviendrait pas à gérer pourtant on ne
peut pas faire le reproche à votre
gouvernement de ne rien faire en la
matière monsieur le ministre mais la
réalité quotidienne notamment en matière
d'immigration illégale est souvent
décourageante si l'on en croit l'exposé
des motifs votre projet de loi n'est pas
je cite une couche supplémentaire de
sédimentation législative nous
l'espérons tous effectivement que ce
n'est pas le cas une chose est sûre sans
refaire l'inventaire de l'ensemble des
mesures votre texte vise bel et bien
l'ensemble des aspects de notre
politique migratoire en passant de
l'immigration économique à l'asile et à
la simplification de son contentieux aux
mesures en faveur de l'intégration et de
la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale malgré tout cela a été rappelé
par nos rapporteurs votre texte manquait
d'ambition sur certaines thématique
notre commission des lois dont je salue
la qualité du travail a largement étaufé
votre re projet aussi bien s'agissant du
renforcement de la politique
d'intégration que de la lutte contre
l'immigration
illégale je reviendrai dans quelques
instants sur plusieurs aspects de ce
texte mais une remarque plus générale
tout d'abord le défi migratoire ne
concerne pas que notre pays vous l'avez
dit il concerne l'ensemble de nos pays
voisins et de nos voisins européens et
nous ne sommes pas les plus mal lottis
dans cette dans cette situation en tout
cas l'Italie ITIE et la Grèce pour n'en
citer que deux sont quotidiennement bien
plus exposés que nous par facilité
certains sont tenter de dire ah oui mais
vous comprenez c'est surtout un problème
européen et il est vain de modifier sans
fin notre législation nationale bien sûr
que le problème est européen mais ce
n'est certainement pas une raison pour
attendre que la solution Vienne
exclusivement de l'Union européenne nous
devons à la fois porter des évolutions
efficaces dans notre droit interne et
convaincre nos voisins d'adopter des
solutions à l'échelle européenne mais
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre nous avons
besoin de règles européennes
ensuite sommes-nous parvenus avec les
mesures que nous examinons aujourd'hui à
un plafond de verre de ce que nous
pouvons faire en droit constitutionnel
constant sur plusieurs aspects il me
semble que c'est le cas je ne doute pas
que la discussion des amendements
amènera nos rapporteurs à rappeler ce
cadre et à signaler que plusieurs
propositions pouvant paraître
intéressantes sont contraires à la
Constitution nous sommes conscients de
ces limites constitutionnel c'est la
raison pour laquelle depuis les travaux
de la commission en mars dernier notre
groupe a proposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à aménager la
norme suprême en matière d'asile le
texte que nous avons déposé prévoit que
les demandes d'asile soient présenté non
plus à l'arrivée sur le territoire
national mais auprès de nos ambassades
et consulats
nous pensons qu'il faut donc
radicalement faire évoluer notre système
pour pouvoir continuer à protéger vite
ceux qui sont réellement en danger sur
ce sujet il en va de l'honneur de la
France c'est pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
opposés par principe à faire évoluer
notre Constitution sur ces questions
mais dans le respect des exigences
conventionnelles en effet peut-on
accepter demain de déroger à la
hiérarchie des normes principes cardinal
de notre État de droit faut-il envisager
des cas dans lesquels l'autorité des
traités serait remise en cause par
rapport à celle de la loi interne nous y
sommes défavorables si certains aspects
d'un traité nous semblent inadaptés
négocions leur modifications si des
dispositions communautaires sont
devenues inopportunes travaillons avec
nos voisins pour les changer puisque nos
collègues
nous y invite nous aurons ce débat dans
l'hémicycle au mois de décembre pour
lors je reviens en projet de loi notre
commission des lois a apporté de
nombreuses améliorations au texte et je
me concentrerai sur certaines d'entre
elles l'article premier vous l'avez dit
monsieur le rapporteur introduit une
innovation majeure elle prévoit la tenue
d'un débat annuel au Parlement sur les
orientation pluriannuelle en matière
migratoire mais surtout à l'issue du
débat le Parlement déterminera le nombre
des étrangers admis à s'installer
durablement en France pour chacune des
catégories de séjour à l'exception de
l'asile à travers cette disposition la
représentation nationale vaoir va
pouvoir chaque année orienter la
politique migratoire de notre pays une
excellente mesure permettant d'associer
députés sénateurs et gouvernement dans
un débat public pour une fois nous ne
subirons pas l'actualité nous la ferons
la Commission s'est également attachée
en renforcer la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale deux articles du
texte sont malheureusement de sorti de
l'anonymat malheureusement après
l'assassinat ignob du professeur
Dominique Bernard enseignant au groupe
scolaire Guerno Gambetta à haras les
articles 9 et 10 nos rapporteurs avaient
déjà profondément modifié ces articles
relactif aux protections permettant
d'empêcher des mesures d'expulsion ou le
prononcer d'interdiction sur du
territoire français nous avons tous été
heurtés par le profil de l'agresseur du
professeur et de celui d'une partie de
sa famille totalement radicalisé il nous
faut aller plus loin encore et faciliter
la levée des protections absolues et
relatives pour des individus qui sont
une telle menace pour la sécurité
publique mais sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres ne cédons pas à la tentation
d'adopter des dispositifs dont nous
savons qu'ils seront censurés par le
Conseil constitutionnel nous n'avons
rien à y gagner impossible évidemment de
faire l'impasse sur l'article le plus
célèbre de ce texte le fameux article 3
nous tenons au préalable à rappeler que
nous ne comprenons pas du tout
l'effervescence suscité par cette
disposition sur les métiers en tension
elle ne mérite sûrement pas les
réactions très excessives qu'elle
suscite y a-t-il aujourd'hui des
personnes en situation irrégulière qui
travaillent légalement dans notre pays
oui bien sûr sont-ils parfois
régularisés au bout d'un certain temps
de présence et de travail sur le
territoire national oui bien sûr
autrement dit le sujet de cet article
n'est pas nouveau et il ne serait pas
juste de prétendre le contraire
l'innovation majeure de l'article 3
réside dans la création d'un titre de
séjour de plein droit pour qu'une
personne travaillant dans notre pays
depuis plus de 8 mois au cours des pour
une personne qui travaillerait depuis
plus de 8 mois au cours des deux
dernières années notre groupe a
longuement débattu de cette disposition
élément central a toujours fait
consensus niz la situation de ces
travailleurs sans papier qui travaillent
parfois depuis des années sur notre sol
souvent dans des métiers pénibles ne
résoudra pas le problème soyons clair
ces personnes sont le plus souvent non
expulsable ils sont sur le territoire
depuis trop longtemps ils sont intégrés
ont souvent une famille inutile donc de
venir les voir grossir la catégorie de
ce qu'on appelle les niniis ni
expulsable ni régularisable mais faut-il
pour autant créer un nouveau type de
titre de séjour nous avons finalement
considérer que ce n'était pas la bonne
option le plus efficace est de conserver
comme aujourd'hui le pouvoir
d'appréciation des des préfets dans une
gestion des dossiers au cas par cas
c'est ce que prévoit l'amendement que
nous vous présenterons il prévoit aussi
et surtout de modifier le régime
applicable en matière d'autorisation de
travail cela a été rappelé un salarié
sans papier qui souhaite régulariser sa
situation doit recueillir l'accord de
son employeur pour pouvoir présenter sa
demande de titre de séjour en préfecture
il ne nous paraît pas pertinent de
maintenir ainsi un salari étranger dans
la dépendance de son employeur c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre amendement
prévoit aussi la suppression de cet
accord préalable une telle rédaction de
l'article 3 nous semble pragmatique et
responsable ni ni d'appel d'air ni des
nid de réalité nous espérons que
celle-ci sera finalement partagée par
tous nous sommes également favorable à
un dispositif qui permette d'assouplir
l'accès plus rapide au marché du travail
pour les demandeurs d'asile qui sont
susceptibles d'obtenir la protection de
la France il ne s'agit pas de remettre
en cause la règle applicable à tous les
demandeurs d'asile dont on sait
pertinemment qu'une part majoritaire
n'obtiendra pas le statut de réfugié en
revanche laisser travailler un idu
originaire d'un pays pour lequel les
ressortissants obtiennent l'asile dans
90 % des cas c'est pragmatique cela
favorisera son intégration et nous y
sommes favorables je conclurai enfin en
prenant une analyse de notre collègue
mon cher Jean-Louis bourlange ce dernier
considère qu'il règne en France
actuellement un climat de peur et
d'insécurité d en grande partie à une
perte de confiance dans nos institutions
ce texte à l'ône de nouvelles procédure
administrative essaie de remédier à ce
constat il vient compléter d'autres
mesures déjà prises en y mettant encore
plus d'exigences il correspond à une
attente de nos concitoyens une attente
de fermeté et d'efficacité puisque le
sondage paru hier montre que les 3/4 de
l'opinion publique soutiennent le
présent projet de loi enfin à celles et
ceux qui veulent fermer les frontières
de notre pays je souhaite juste rappeler
que la France s'est construite de tout
temps grâce à l'arrivée d'étrangers
venant de multiples pays et à qui elle
doit une grande partie de sa richesse et
de son rayonnement je vous
remercie merci Madame madame Floren la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Guy
bénaroche pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et
territoire
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madamees messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues avant
d'entrer dans le détails important de ce
projet de loi pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
il est bon de rappeler qu'il est le 30e
texte effectivement monsieur le ministre
sur la question de l'immigration depuis
les années 80 à la lecture on peut être
heurté par son déséquilibre provoqué
tant par la partie sécuritaire du texte
gouvernemental initial que par la
version de la commission des Lois du
Sénat qui reste sans voix sur les
articles 3 et 4 au cœur de l'intégration
prévue tout en renforçant ces aspects
punitifs je sais que nous ne définissons
pas l'immigration ni ne la caractérisons
pas tous de la même façon
l'immigration est un phénomène normal
historique récurrent point commun de
l'histoire des civilisations qui a
participé et qui participera à
l'évolution de notre culture et à la
construction de notre pays c'est un
phénomène démographique complexe
tributaire de contingence géopolitique
comme les guerre les famines et même
conséc mett du changement climatique
mais d'autres fables voient de plus en
plus le jour dans la réalité aucun mur
physique ou administratif n'a pu
empêcher durablement l'être humain
d'aller voir ailleurs quand cela est lié
à sa survie tant d'épisodes tragiques
nous le rappelle en Méditerranée en
Manche et ailleurs un phénomène qui
conduira encore plus de mouvements dans
les années à venir au sein et entre les
pays et les continents l'appréhension du
phénomène migratoire ne peut pas se
passenser qu'à l' d'une vision
sécuritaire sauf à assimiler l'étranger
à une menace ce que nous refusons le
ministère de l'Intérieur ne doit pas
être l'unique maître d'œuvre de la
politique migratoire de notre pays il
est urgent de nous pencher sur la
création d'un ministère dédié à la
politique d'immigration d'accueil et
d'intégration comme notre groupe
notamment au travers de mon collègue
Thomas DASU a déjà pu
l'exprimer l'équilibre cherché par cette
loi est loin de la promesse président
identiel de 2019 je crois au vrai en
même temps sur la politique migratoire
aussi alors quelle est l'histoire
présentée aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement et réécrite par la
commission des Lois du Sénat ne soyons
pas dupes et analysons l'intérêt
politicien devenu le fondement de ce
texte don le parcours jusqu'à ce jour
est plus qu'ératique certes vous
déclarez monsieur le ministre il y a
quelques jours dans un journal du
dimanche l'enjeu est trop important pour
la nation pour faire de la politique
politicienne pourtant tout dans la
gestion de ce texte n'est que le reflet
d'un calcul politicien sinon comment
expliquer son retrait de la séance
publique en mars dernier car il
n'existeit pas de majorité pour voter à
tel texte comment expliquer les annonces
présidentielles parlant en mars du fait
qu'il y aura bien une loi immigration il
y en aura même sans doute plusieurs de
textes qui arriveront dans les
prochaines semaines comment accorder
cela avec la déclaration de la première
ministre en avril ce n'est pas le moment
de lancer un débat sur un sujet qui
pourrait diviser le pays avec comme seul
Boussant l'efficacité aujourd'hui vous
pensez réellement que le climat est plus
apaisé qu'en
avril la politisation tranière de la
question migratoire est un piège qui ne
doit profiter à personne et qui va
malheureusement profiter à certains
comment expliquer sinon que l'on soit
passé d'un texte je cite gentil avec les
gentils méchants avec les méchants
c'était la morale de la fable au texte
je cite le plus ferme avec les mesures
les plus dures depuis ces 30 dernières
années la France ne peut pas accueillir
tout le monde si elle veut accueillir
bien disait le président de
mieux accueillir est-ce procéder dans le
budget une baisse des crédits octroyé
pour laallocation des demandeurs d'asile
de plus d'un tiers 36 % comme l'an
dernier quel décalage entre la réalité
et le récit notre pays ne peut pas
mettre les gens dans des situations
irrégulières vis-à-vis de la loi du fait
de la complexité croissante de
l'inflation législative nationale ou
européenne comment ne pas voir que ce
texte n'apporte rien au phénomène
inexcusable de précarisation des
étrangers venons-en à l'intégration par
le travail c'était l'un des deux piliers
mis en avant par les ministres d'armanin
et du S l'accès au travail est la clé de
l'intégration des adultes arrivant sur
notre sol je sais que c'est une
conviction partagé au vu du traitement
des Ukrainiens lors de leur arrivée la
crise ukrainienne a montré que l'Europe
et que notre pays pouvait accueillir
bien accueillir et rapidement accueillir
lorsque la volonté politique y est le
dérogatoire ukrainien qui a fait ses
preuves ne devrait-il pas tendre à
devenir la règle la question de la
régularisation la jambe gauche bien
mégrichante du texte celle contenue en
partie dans l'article 3 est essentiel
permettez-moi de rappeler l'objectif
annoncé régulariser les travailleurs
sans papier pour faciliter leur
intégration pour leur éviter d'être à la
mercie des raisons mafieux et pour
permettre à de nombreuses branches de
notre économie de fonctionner
normalement comme beaucoup d'employeurs
le demandent aujourd'hui que nous
dites-vous monsieur le ministre sans le
ministre du Travail qu'en fait vous
allez passer un accord avec la droite
pour faire en sorte que cet article 3 ne
permett de régulariser que le moins de
Me possible sans satisfaire aucun des
objectifs que vous aviez vous-même
annoncés comment ne pas vouloir
permettre à des personnes qui
travaillent qui veulent s'intégrer de
s'extirper de la peur permanente du
contrôle de l'éloignement et d'un nouvel
exempe personne ne peut être
complètement intégré même après des
années avec cette crinte permanente
intégré par le travail c'est aussi
régularisé par le travail au cutf accru
multiplication descin et en même temps
plus de contraite pour renouveler les
demandes pour les étudiants par exemple
pour les prises de rendez-vous en
préfecture pour l'obtention des titres
on sait déjà à quel point la situation
et les délis d'obtention ser ins
supportable nous étions prêts à
féliciter le gouvernement pour enfin
agir sur la rétention des mineurs dans
l'écran mais la limitation des mineurs à
l'âge de 16 ans est une farce qui nous
paraît peu drôle vous mettez en place
les défaillances du système de la CNDA
manque de moyens de personnel et en même
temps vous appuyez sur ces délis r du
tropent pour justifier une réflexion au
sujet des modifications des règles de
droit pour limiter les recours et j'ai
généraliser le juge unique les
assesseurs de la formation collégiale ne
sont pas forcément des magistrats ne
plus faire appel à la collégialité
notamment au membres désigné par le
Haut- commomissaire des Nations Unies
pour les réfugiés n'accélérera pas les
procédures oui il y a une embouisation
d' système ma calibré mais la seule
réponse est un calibrage adapté avec un
nombre de locaux et de personnel
adéquate nous groupe écologistes et
solidarité sommes clairement en faveur
d'une meilleure célérité des procédures
mais jamais au dépend des fondamentaux
de la justice des droits des personnes
des conditions de travail des agents de
l' service public je pense aujourd'hui
aussi à l'enterrement définitif de la
promesse d'Orléan de 2017 qui avait vu
le président déclarer qu'aucun demandeur
d'asile ne dormirait dehors rien de ce
qui nous a été présenté ne s'attelle à
ce sujet pourtant essentiel et comment
ne pas dire comme l'ont souligné des
milliers de médecins acteurs de la santé
et du social que la FA de laame est une
aberration quelle est cette légende de
soi-disant appel d'air que tous les
chiffres et tous les témoignages
dément monsieur le ministre messieurs
les rapporteurs nous devons veiller à
une inconditionnalité de la dignité dans
l'accueil à juste titre c'est vraiment
notre honneur je regrette que cet
honneur soit variable entre l'Aquarius
et l'océan de Viking l'acceptabilité des
refus doit s'ancrer dans le respect des
procédures et des personnes et une prise
en charge digne de l'accueil jusqu'au
traitement des demandes chers collègues
n'y voyez ni naïveté ni idéalisme
utopique mais au contraire entendez le
besoin d'accueillir humainement de mieux
respecter la digité de chacun ce projet
de loi ne le permet pas à nous la
responsabilité de le changer dans les
jours qui viennent merci merci Monsieur
Baroche la parole est désormais à
Monsieur Yan brossa pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
kaki monsieur le Président Monsieur le
le ministre ce ce projet de loi tel
qu'il ressort en tout cas de sa
réécriture par la commission des Lois du
Sénat par au fond d'un principe l'idée
que l'étranger serait d'abord une menace
dont il faudrait se prémunir un péril
dont il faudrait se protéger un danger
qu'il nous reviendrait d'écartter je
veux le dire d'emblé pour résumer l'état
d'esprit de notre groupe nous ne
partageons pas cette vision des choses
et toutes les mesur qui en découleent
qu'un pays bien sûr définisse des règles
en matière d'immigration c'est
parfaitement naturel et parfaitement
légitime qu'il veille à leur respect
c'est légitime également en revanche que
la politique d'immigration se consacre
quasi exclusivement à faire des
étrangers qui vivent sur notre sol des
suspects s'en est une autre et nous n'y
adhérerons jamais il suffit d'ailleurs
pour démentir cette vision des choses de
regarder la société en face de regarder
en face la grande masse des étrangers
qui vivent sur notre sol qu'ils aient
des papiers ou pas ceux dont on ne parle
finalement jamais ceux qui travaillent
en silence ceux qui bien souvent
prennent le premier métro pour que les
cadres de la défense puissent travailler
dans des bureaux propres de tout cela
personne ne parle jamais ils sont
pourtant là sous nos yeux dans les
cuisines des restaurants alentour dans
les chantiers où se préparent les Jeux
Olympiques dans les épades où
travaillent les auxiliaires de vie dans
les hôpitaux où travaillent tant de
médecins étrangers dans nos champs où
travaillent tant d'ouvriers agricoles
dans nos universités où travaillent tant
de chercheurs étrangers ne pas voir
cette réalité ne pas voir la réalité de
la grande masse des étrangers qui vivent
sur notre sol c'est faire le choix du
déni c'est refuser de voir que ces
femmes que ces hommes travaillent ici
produisent des richesses ici participent
du rayonnement de notre pays respecte
les lois les principes et les valeurs de
la
République ces hommes ces femmes-là ceux
dont je parle à l'instant ceux qui
représentent la grande masse des
étrangers qui vivent sur notre
territoire sont assurément beaucoup plus
patriotes et beaucoup plus loyaux à la
France que tous ces immigrés fiscaux qui
continuent à bénéficier d'un laxisme
coupable vous l'avez compris notre
vision des choses est à 1000 lieu de
celle que défend la majorité sénatoriale
et le gouvernement nous sommes à la fois
en désaccord avec votre constat de
départ et en D acccord par conséquent
avec toutes les mesures qui en découlent
en effet toutes les mesures qui ont été
voté en commission des lois visent en
réalité à aggraver le projet initial
présenté par le gouvernement c'est la
limitation du droit du sol c'est la
limitation du regroupement familial ce
qui est d'ailleurs totalement
contradictoire avec l'objectif
d'intégration car il va bien falloir
m'expliquer comment un étranger qui
vient en France peut s'intégrer dès lors
qu'il n'a pas la possibilité de vivre
vivre en famille et c'est par ailleurs
la remise en cause de l'aide médicale
d'État au fond partant de l'idée que
l'immigré est une menace vous déployez
une stratégie une stratégie qui consiste
à penser que vous réduirez les flux
migratoire en dégradant les conditions
d'accueil de ceux qui viennent chercher
refuse chez nous c'est totalement faux
d'abord parce que depuis des années
maintenant les conditions d'accueil de
ceux qui viennent chez nous ont déjà été
considérablement dégradé et ça n'a en
aucun cas conduit à ce que les flux se
tarissent ensuite parce que le faible
taux de recours de toute une série
d'aides dont pourrai bénéficier les
immigrés qui viennent sur notre
territoire prouve bien que les gens ne
viennent pas pour des aides comment
expliquer autrement que sur l'aide
médicale d'État on est un taux de
recours d'à peine 50 % autrement dit que
50 % de ceux qui auraient droit à l'aide
médicale d'État n'y ont pas recours
comment explique expqu que sur le RSA 70
% des étrangers en situation régulière
évidemment sinon il n'y aurait pas droit
hors Union Européenne qui pourrait y
avoir droit n'y ont pas recours c'est
bien la preuve que ceux qui viennent
chez nous ne viennent pas pour
bénéficier d'aide et c'est par ailleurs
se tromper fondamentalement parce que ce
qui provoque la migration ça n'est pas
la situation de la personne dans son
pays d'accueil ça n'est pas
l'attractivité du pays d'accueil c'est
la situation du pays de départ et donc
agir sur les flux c'est agir sur la
situation du pays de départ et non pas
dégrader les conditions d'accueil sur
notre sol à partir de là au fond deux
possibilités se présentent à nous soit
nous restons dans le déni nous
continuons à vendre le mirage d'une
immigration zéro ou d'une immigration
quasi réduite à néant et à ce moment-là
nous laisserons le chaos s'organiser
soit nous regardons la réalité des
migrations en face et nous nous
organisons à des dessin nous organisons
l'accueil digne et nous organisons
l'intégration l'intégration par l'école
l'intégration par la langue
l'intégration par le travail et c'est
d'ailleurs précisément parce que cette
organisation fait défaut que nous en
sommes là aujourd'hui et c'est
précisément cela qui nourrit le discours
sur le chaos migratoire c'est l'absence
de voie légale d'immigration qui crée un
marché pour les passeurs c'est l'absence
d'hébergement digne qui crée un marché
pour les marchands de sommeil et
d'ailleurs nous proposons un amendement
qui vise à permettre aux victimes des
marchands de sommeil qui porte plainte
de bénéficier d'un titre de séjour
provisoire ce qui permettrait
précisément de les protéger c'est
l'absence de régularisation massive par
le travail qui crée les conditions pour
que des patrons voyou puissent profiter
de la misère autrement dit le drame ce
n'est pas l'immigration c'est
l'exploitation qui en est fait par un
certain nombre de gens qui profitent de
la misère humaine et quand même cela a
été dit tout à l'heure mais le fait que
en commission des lois l'article 8 qui
permet de pénaliser les employeurs qui
embauchent des sanspiers c'est quand
même une question qui devrait tous nous
interpeller parce que dans une relation
d'exploitation qui est coupable c'est
l'exploiteur ou c'est celui qui est
exploité et donc je le dis ici la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papi est- ce qui nous permettrait de
sortir de l'hypocrisie dans laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui vous l'aurez
compris la vision que nous défendons est
aux antipodes de celle du texte qui est
ressorti de la commission des lois et je
voudrais que nous soyons attentifs au
fait que lorsque nous parlons deux
lorsque nous parlons de ces étrangers
qui vivent sur notre sol lorsque nous
mettons en place des politiques qui les
concernent nous parlons d'abord de nous
et de ce que nous voulons faire de notre
pays et des valeurs que nous voulons
défendre dans notre
pays merci merci merci Monsieur brossa
la parole est maintenant à Marie scarer
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen madame
la Présidente
carer monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
ces dernières décennies notre hémicycle
a eu plutôt l'habitude légitime de se
plaindre du miliefeuille administratif à
travers la prolifération des
d'administration locale le menu de cette
semaine ne s'en éloigne finalement pas
tellement puisque nous allons nous
pencher sur un autre millefeuille mais
celui-ci change de saveur il est
législatif depuis le début des années 80
notre Parlement a déjà voté presque 33
lois sur l'immigration soit environ une
tous les 17 mois une fois que nous avons
ces chiffres à l'esprit on s'interroge
forcément sur la nécessité d'un nouveau
texte alors même que nous n'avons pas
encore tiré tous les bilans de la loi
colon qui nourrissait pourtant des
ambitions assez similaires à celles du
projet que nous examinons mais il est
vrai que le monde change et qu'il faut
s'adapter mais essayons d'en tirer les
de tirer les leçons des expériences
précédentes toutefois en découvrant le
texte dans sa version initiale nous
avons d'abord été plutôt surpris il
comprenait des mesures pour lesquelles
nous étions favorables et celles qui
nous contrariait le plus restait malgré
tout mesuré côté positif il avait
évidemment les articles 3 et 4 nous
sommes absolument favorables à ce que
les trilleurs immigrés sortent
d'une situation de précarité difficile
marqué par des emplois instables une
faible rémunération et l'absence de tout
dispositif de protection sociale il n'y
a pas de doute que l'intégration par le
travail soit efficace et valorisante et
qui n'a pas au sein de cet hémicycle
reçu sur son département l'appel d'un
chef d'entreprise devant se séparer de
son employé pour pour non régularisation
de papierers côté négatif je pense bien
sûr avec un exemple de l'exemple de la
réforme du contentieux des étrangers
certes nos administrations et
juridictions font face à de réelles
difficultés de l'engorgement de la
complexité juridique pour autant ces
difficultés juridiques et le manque de
moyens humains ne saurait être compensé
par des renoncement à nos principes
fondamentaux notamment la collégialité
des juridictions et la publicité des
débats il s'agit ici de principes que
nous défendons systématiquement à chaque
réforme contentieuse et institutionnelle
il aurait peut-être été plus Judici de
réformer le fond du droit en le
simplifiant et en le clarifiant les
résultats d'une telle démarche sur la
célérité et l'efficacité de la justice
serait peut-être plus probant nous y
reviendrons lors de l'examen des
articles et des amendements toujours
est-il que dans sa première mouture le
texte aurait pu convenir à notre groupe
sous réserve de quelques aménagements
mais sans le modifier sans en profondeur
puis est venu l'examen par notre
commission des lois et là ce projet de
loi sur l'immigration a pris une
tournure radicale pour ne pas dire même
parfois brutal je m'attarderai seulement
sur quelques exemples car nous aurons le
temps de détailler nos nos position
durant cette semaine d'examen d'abord
l'article 1er I qui propose de
substituer à l'aide médicale d'État une
aide médicale d'urgence cette mesure est
symptomatique d'un état d'esprit cet
état d'esprit qui a donné au projet de
loi une tournure et éloignant tout
espoir de consensus car avec cet article
ajouté par notre commission nous
retrouvons un partie pris sur
l'immigration car factuellement
économiquement et sanitairement rien ne
le
justifie certains décrivent ce
dispositif comme engendrant des effets
d'appel d'air et pourtant d'une part
toutes les personnes éligibles à laame
n'en bénéficient pas réellement et cela
même lorsqu'elle déclare souffrir de
maladies nécessitant des soins d'autre
part moins de 10 % des étrangers en
situation irrégulière évoquent la santé
comme un motif de venu en France j'ai du
mal à y voir un usage abusif
économiquement et sanitairement ensuite
nous sortons d'une pandémie qui a
rappelé les impératifs les plus
fondamentaux en matière de santé
publique que se passera-t-il lorsque
notre pays nous ne soignerons dans notre
pays nous ne soignerons plus une partie
de la population pour défaut de titre de
séjour quelle réaction auront les
médecins nous le savons tous très bien
cette suppression idéologique pourrait
avoir de graves conséquences pour le
système de santé français et constitue
un nonsens économique puisque les
pathologies hospitalières prises en
charge tardivement sont particulièrement
coûteuses autre dispositif préoccupant
ajouté par le Sénat les articles de bis
et de terr qui viennent marquer un recul
très net du droit du sol mais surtout
qui place des mineurs donc des enfants
et des adolescents desquels nous
exigerons une manifestation de volonté
et pour le dire simplement un casier
judiciaire vierge alors que notre
assemblée s'attache le plus souvent à
défendre le droit des enfants et de la
jeunesse j'ai du mal à comprendre que ce
sujet soit encore débattu s'agissant de
la manifestation de volonté je veux bien
y voir un intérêt symbolique mais en
pratique ce ne sera qu'une démarche
administrative de plus sans efficacité
concrète ensuite concernant les mineurs
condamnés à une peine de 6 mois ces
jeunes n'auront donc plus de droit à
l'erreur à l'erreur alors même que notre
Parlement peine par exemple à adopter ce
type de mesure pour les élus et je ne
suis pas sûr d'être à l'aise avec cette
exigence asymétrique de moralisation il
reste toujours en suspend les articles 3
et 4 comme une sorte de dernier espoir
pour que le texte puisse encore être
défendu puisque nos rapporteurs n'ont
pas su n'ont pas trouvé un accord
j'espère que notre hémicycle sera
favorable euh à ces deux articles qui
nous semblent fondamentaux pour que
notre pays parvienne à plus d'apaisement
et de sérénité face à la question de
l'immigration dernier point sur lesquels
nous ne pouvons pas faire l'impasse la
question des
qtf question difficile car souvent prise
de populisme nous sommes forcément
saisis par les carart qui existe entre
d'un côté le nombre d'qtf prononcé et de
l'autre celles qui sont finalement
exécuté il y a d'autant plus un problème
que chacun a déjà rencontré dans son
département le cas d'une personne
parfaitement intégrée et pourtant
menacée d'expulsion il est rare que ces
personnes soient concernées par les
dispositions des articles 9 et 10 du
projet de
loi autrement dit il faut trouver
l'équilibre pour cesser de prononcer des
qtf à l'encontre des personnes intégrées
et appliquer ferm celle qui vise des
personnes risquant d'atteindre à la
sûreté de notre nation cela étant nous
admettons que cette équation est
difficile à résoudre notre seule
certitude sur le sujet est qu'il ne
passe il ne sera pas réglé si chacun
campe sur ses posture impossible donc
pour en conclusion je dirais qu'il est
impossible aujourd'hui en l'état de dire
la position du RDSE à l'issue de du vote
de l'examen de ce texte il faudront il
faudra donc attendre l'examen des
amendements pour nous positionné
toutefois si le texte n'était pas
modifié lors de la séance publique peut
voir aucun d'entre nous ne le
soutiendront je vous
remercie merci Madame carer la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Olivier bis
pour le groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et
indépendants monsieur le Président
Madame et monsieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madamees et monsieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues chacune et chacun le
sait bien les flux migratoires se sont
accélérés ces dernières années à
l'échelle mondiale instabilité politique
évolution démographique inégalité de
toutes sortes et changement climatiqu
viennent provoquer une mobilité
croissante des populations ainsi selon
l'OCDE l'immigration dans les pays
riches a atteint des niveaux records en
2022 cette progression rapide trouve
bien bien évidemment sa traduction en
Europe et dans notre pays en 2022 320000
autorisations de séjour ont été délivrés
par la France alors que dans le même
temps 131 demandes d'asile y ont été
enregistrées bien évidemment bien
évidemment les entrées clandestines
viennent s'ajouter à à ces chiffres déjà
considérables à l'évidence cette
trajectoire n'est pas soutenable dans la
durée pour notre cohésion nationale elle
ne correspond pas à la capacité
d'accueil de notre pays encore moin à sa
capacité d'intégration l'échelle
européenne est bien sûr pertinente pour
régler les pour réguler les phénomènes
migratoires et nous nous réjouissons de
l'élon donné l'année dernière par la
présidence française pour aboutir à
l'adoption prochaine du pacte européen
sur la migration et l'asile la dimension
européenne du sujet ne nous empêche
cependant pas de muscler notre droit
interne car il y a nécessité de mieux
soutier juridiquement pour faire face à
cette évolution de la situation l'état
de notre droit de nous permet pas
aujourd'hui d'agir assez assez
efficacement pour réduire les flux
migratoires mieux protéger nos
concitoyens des délinquants étrangers et
affirmer avec force notre attachement au
principes et valeurs de la République la
loi du 10 septembre 2018 avait déjà fixé
le cap il s'agit maintenant d'accélérer
accélérer à la fois sur les moyens
juridiques donnés à l'état pour mener
une politique plus ferme mais aussi
parallèlement sur les moyens financiers
qui lui sont confiés pour atteindre cet
objectif à cet égard la entre la volonté
politique du gouvernement et les moyens
qu'il a demandé et obtenu avec
l'adoption de l'opmie doit être souligné
un seul exemple pour améliorer
l'exécution des décisions l'éloignement
l'objectif de 3000 places de rétention
administrative d'ici 2027 est d'ors et
déjà programmé et financé la nécessité
d'une évolution plus rigoureuse de notre
droit est une conviction largement
partagée sur la méthode je me réjouis de
constater à quel point ce projet de loi
a été enrichi par les travaux de la
commission des loi et la reprise par le
gouvernement de la quasi-ttalité des
propositions faites il s'agit d'un bel
exemple d'un processus de coconstruction
qui devrait nous permettre d'avancer et
je tiens ici à saluer tout
particulièrement la volonté de dialogue
et d'échange du ministre
d'intérieur ne pas adopter ce projet
reviendrait Infiné à se satisfaire de
l'état du droit actuel ce serait prendre
une lourde responsabilité car notre pays
a besoin de renforcer les exigences
concernant l'intégration en demand au
demandeur d'une carte de séjour
pluréannuelle la connaissance d'un
niveau minimum de français mais aussi un
engagement à respecter les principes de
la République pour protéger nos
concitoyens la menace grave pour l'ordre
public doit devenir un motif de non
renouvellement ou de retrait de la carte
de résidents dans le même sens le projet
de loi vient faciliter l'éloignement des
étrangers qui représente une menace
grave pour l'ordre public il s'agit
aussi de mettre à l'honneur la valeur
travail en faisant de l'activité
économique un facteur d'intégr mieux
reconnu au moment même où nombre de nos
entreprises souffrent de ne pas trouver
la main d'œuvre qui leur est nécessaire
on a pu un temp entendre un peu tout et
n'importe quoi sur ce désormais célèbre
article 3 alors même qu'il ne s'agit que
d'un dispositif expérimental limité dans
le temps permettant de ne délivrer qu'un
titre temporaire d'un an renouvelable
sous conditions à des personnes se
trouvant déjà sur le territoire depuis
au moins 3 ans et dont le pays a besoin
de l'activité cela mérite à l'évidence
pas tous les excès entendus par ailleurs
représentant l'Orne territoire rural qui
comme beaucoup d'autres territoires
ruraux représentent un désert médical je
me réjouis des mesures facilitant la
situation au regard de leur droit au
séjour des médecins diplômés à
l'étranger enfin la simplification du
contentieux des étrangers est très
attendu en ayant comme objectif
d'accélérer les procédures tout en
conservant l'effectivité du droit au
recours vous l'aurez compris sans
surprise le groupe R despays soutiendra
la volonté du gouvernement de muscler
notre droit en faisant preuve de
pragmatisme et d'humanité je vous
remercie merci merci Monsieur wi à la
demande de Monsieur le Ministre nous
interrompons pendant 5 minutes la
séance
là nous allons donc reprendre la séance
avec Madame Corine Narassiguin pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain à vous madame pour 9
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues
contrairement à ce ce que certains
disent nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui
confrontés à une vague d'immigration les
composants de ce mouvement migratoires
sont multiples elles sont en premier
lieu le résultat du regroupement
familial cette pratique demeure
marginale et doit être préservée ces
mouvements migratoires comptent aussi
des étudiants des demandeurs d'asile
dont le nombre a cert un peu augmenter
mais dans des proportions qui n'ont rien
de comparable à ce que l'on constate
chez nos voisins le sujet de
l'immigration ne devrait donc pas
inquiéter la population française et
pourtant pourquoi fait-il débat parce
qu'il est source à la fois de confusion
de malentendu d'une forme d'inquiétude
ou comme le diraient certains auteurs
d'insécurité culturelle mais les racines
d'un tel sentiment réside dans la
question de l'intégration pas dans le
fait migratoire nous ne devons pas
mentir à nos citoyen l'immigration n'est
pas quelque chose dont nous pourrions
nous départir de surcroix l'immigration
se révèle une chance d'un point de vue
économique culturel social mais à
condition de savoir la prendre en charge
quand on sait les intégrer les former
les femmes et les hommes renouvellent
notre société puis donneent une
impulsion nouvelle des élans
d'éventivité d'innovation les
démocraties qui réussissent intégration
bénéficient d'une croissance supérieure
à la NRE autre mais la question de
l'intégration reste un problème en
France nous ne parvenons plus à nous
départir d'une défiance à l'égard des
migrants monsieur le ministre ces
premiers mots de mon propos sont ceux
d'Emmanuel Macron alors candidat à
l'élection présidentielle en février
2017 mais alors que s'est-il passé
depuis que s'est-il passé monsieur le
ministre pour que vous nous présentiez
le 29e projet de loi sur l'immigration
depuis les années 80 en faisant croire à
nos concitoyens qu'il résoudra enfin
tous leurs problèmes que s'est-il passé
pour que vous assumiez d'être condamné
par la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme aussi régulièrement que s'est-il
passé pour que vous nous présentiez le
texte le plus dur et le plus ferme sur
l'immigration depuis les 30 dernières
années comme vous le
proclamez que s'est-il passé pour que le
Président de la République renie ses
positions intérieures sur la question
migratoire la france d' aujourd'hui est
l'héritière d'une histoire complexe
qu'elle doit apprendre assumer elle est
de fait un pays d'immigration et une
terre d'accueil l'immigration est une
réalité structurelle que nous devons
embrasser nous socialistes considérons
qu'une immigration réussie passe par
l'intégration et cette intégration a
trois composantes essentielles le
travail l'apprentissage de la langue
ainsi que l'amxité à l'école et dans le
logement alors quand je lis le titre de
votre projet de loi et que je vois
améliorer l'intégration je dis pourquoi
pas l'apprentissage de la langue tout
d'abord monsieur le ministre vous vous
ventez partout que ce projet de loi
facilitera l'apprentissage de la langue
du français on y regarde de plus près
c'est faux la vérité est que vous
utilisez la maîtrise de la langue
française comme un obstacle à l'entrée
et à l'installation durable au lieu de
vous inquiéter des moyens de son
apprentissage autre volet essentiel pour
s'intégrer le travail quoi de mieux pour
le que le travail pour s'intégrer un
travail digne
etanticipateur et porteur de sens
il y a un an quand vous souhaitiez être
gentil avec les gentils au côté de
Monsieur du sopt qui a d'ailleurs
disparu des radars depuis c'était la
mesure phare de votre texte le travail
vous le savez nous soutenons cet article
3 qui vise à régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension c'est une mesure très
insuffisante mais c'est un premier pas
dans la bonne direction les Français ne
sont pas dupes et voi bien que les
secteurs de la restauration l'hôtellerie
le BTP l'aide aux personnes la propreté
ou encore le numérique fonctionne grâce
à de nombreux travailleurs sans papiers
ils sont les travailleurs de l'ombre qui
font tourner notre pays ils étaient
celles et ceux qui sortaient chaque jour
en risquant leur vie pendant la covid-19
ils sont ceux ne vous en déplais chers
collègues qui épluche vos légumes et
font la plonge au restaurant du
Sénat mais au-delà de cette vision très
utilitaristes de l'article 3 nous sommes
pour la régularisation de l'ensemble des
travailleurs sans papier sur le
territoire français il s'agit d'arrêter
avec une forme d'hypocrisie et de leur
permettre de vivre légalement sur les
territoires sans être peur au ventre et
le risque d'être contrôlé à tout moment
pour être renvoyé dans leur pays ils
contribuent à la vie économique sociale
et culturelle de notre pays ils doivent
pouvoir y vivre en toute lgalité nous
proposerons donc que l'ensemble des
travailleurs puisse être régularisé
après 6 mois de CDI CDD ou intérim nous
souhaitons également que cette mesure
s'applique au travail d'illeurs des
plateformes qui sont des milliers à
participer à notre économie nous
soutiendrons également la possibilité de
travailler dès le dépôt de la demande
d'asile nous soutenons votre mesure mais
sans illusion car nous avons bien
compris que vous êtes en négociation
privilégiée avec la droite extrême
représenté dans cet hémicycle par
Monsieur reetaillot qui veut supprimer
cet article 3 Le seul élément relatif à
l'intégration dans votre texte
concernant le deuxème volet mieux
contrôler l'immigration il s'agit en
réalité de la partie la plus importante
de votre texte et je le dis sans détour
nous socialistes nous pensons qu'une
organisation des politiques migratoires
est nécessaire une organisation fidèle
aux valeurs de la République pour mieux
accueillir et mieux intégré votre projet
de loi c'est au contraire ajouter du
désordre désordre suite au dramatique
attentat d'aras vous instrumentalisez la
crainte du terrorisme islamiste pour
multiplier les amagalmes faire le lien
entre immigration insécurité et
terrorisme et justifier le durcissement
de votre texte mais cela sans véritable
vision d'immigration et sans même aucune
notion d'efficacité la sûreté de l'État
et la sécurité de nos concitoyennes et
nos concitoyens méritent mieux que la
démagogie elles exigent un discours de
vérité parce que nous sommes lucides sur
la réalité des menaces sécuritaires nous
sommes prêts à aller au bout du débat et
de votre bilan en matière de contrôle de
l'immigration à chaque fois que vous
essayerez d'embbrer d'embrouiller les
Françaises et les Français nous serons
là pour rappeler les faits les régimes
de l'expulsion et de l'éloignement que
vous confondez au mépris des mises en
garde du Conseil d'État n'ont pas besoin
d'être modifié l'enjeu c'est la bonne
application du droit existant plutôt que
de multiplier les qtf mettez des moyens
au préfecture et à l'administration pour
le suivi des individus véritablement
dangereux cessez vos effets de mange et
agissez
efficacement nous nous opposerons
également à la fin de la collégialité au
sein de la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile où l'uralité et l'intime
conviction tiennent une place décisive
une décision de la CNDA peut parfois
renvoyer des personnes à la mort il est
essentiel que cette décision ne soit pas
individuelle pour être la plus juste
possible enfin nous combattrons les
mesures noséabondes de la droite dans
cet hémicycle qui n'a plus de
républicaine que le nom ces mesures que
vous faites vôre comme vous le dites si
bien monsieur le ministre suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État restriction du
regroupement familial remise en cause du
droit du sol sur ce dernier point nous
sommes choqué du silence du gouvernement
le droit du sol est une composante
fondamentale du droit de la nationalité
et de l'intégration républicaine
réveillezvous supprimer les articles de
bis et de
terre monsieur le ministre vous vouliez
une loi immigration qui porte votre nom
finalement
cétrapopri ce projet de loi est une
opération de communication qui au mieux
ne servira à rien ou à pas grand-chose
au pire sera néfaste avec ce texte vous
voulez faire passer l'agitation pour de
l'action l'effet d'annonce pour de l'E
acité la fanf ronade pour
l'autorité vous ne vous souciez plus des
droits fondamentaux de notre
constitution de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme face à C dérive
illibérale nous serons les garants de
notre État de droit nous serons celles
et ceux qui ne mentent pas au français
pour remettre de l'ordre dans notre
République il faut une immigration
organisée un accueil organisé une
intégration organiser et penser une
politique claire applicable et appliquée
votre projet de loi c'est une nuance des
politiques d'exclusion nous serons de
celles et ceux qui considèrent que
l'immigration est une chance pour notre
pays nous serons de celles et ceux qui
pensent l'intégration plutôt que
l'exclusion nous serons de celles et
ceux qui rappelleront que ces personnes
sont avant tout des êtres humains des
hommes des femmes et des
enfants merci madame la sénatrice la
parole est à monsieur le président Bruno
retaillot pour le groupe les
républicains
pour 10
minutes monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues les désordres migratoires
actuels sont sans doute que les
prémisses de désordres plus violents de
secous thélurique beaucoup beaucoup plus
violentes qui sont à venir avec le
dérèglement climatique je l'ai entendu
tout à l'heure avec les dérèglements
géopolitiques et et avec aussi les
déséquilibres démographiques et
d'ailleurs dans le monde occidental
beaucoup beaucoup de gouvernement et de
droite et de gauche durcissent
considérablement leur législation
nationale le dernier en date ça a été
souligné c'est l'Allemagne c'est
Monsieur Scholz qui a présenté un projet
de loi il a d'ailleurs eu une
déclaration fracassante que je cite au
motamot en indiquant que il fallait
expulser à grande échelle les gens qui
n'ont pas le droit de rester en
Allemagne et Joe Biden vient de
poursuivre l'œuvre si j'ose dire de
Monsieur Trump puisque il a décidé la
continuation du mur sur la frontière
mexicaine je rappelle simplement que
Monsieur Biden est démocrate et que
Monsieur Olaf Scholz est socialdémocrate
dans tous ces pays et dans tous les pays
d'Occident en réalité la demande de
fermeté elle vient des classes
populaires elle ne vient pas des classes
aisées qui ont les moyens de se protéger
des conséquence du désordre migratoire
en mettant leurs enfants dans les bonnes
écoles et en habitant les beaux
quartiers la réalité elle est là
monsieur le ministre il y a quelques
semaines vous aviez déclaré dans un
journal du dimanche que sur
l'immigration vous n'aviez aucun tableau
je ne demande qu'à vous croire sur
parole mais j'ai quelques doutes
pourquoi autant d'atterermoimement
pourquoi un accouchement aussi difficile
avec un texte tant de fois promis et un
texte tant de fois remis je pense au
contraire que pour votre majorité pour
votre majorité l'immigration reste un
tabou un tabou
d'abord sur le plan politique c'est le
en même temps qui débouche sur un double
jeu un tabou surtout sur le plan
numérique la question du nombre qui est
fondamentale et un tabou sur le plan du
droit la question du droit qui est aussi
absolument essentiel d'abord le premier
tabou c'est la question du du nombre
tout nous y ramène tout nous y ramène
absolument parce que l'échec de
l'intégration vient du fait que on peut
intégrer des petit nombre des individus
mais comment intégrer des populations
qui souvent sont peu désireuses
d'adhérer à nos principes républicains
et à nos modes de vie qui peut ici dire
de façon sérieuse qu'il n'y a pas de
lien entre tous ces échecs entre tous
ces échecs et l'insécurité qu'il n'y a
pas de lien entre tous ces échecs sur
l'intégration et la multiplication des
territoires perdus de la République
qu'elle soit légale ou illégal le
problème de l'immigration but sur la loi
des grand nombres c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous ne souhaitons pas cet
article 3 qui est devenu certes un peu
totéique mais je je voudrais y revenir
quelques instants d'abord parce que on
ne peut pas à la fois prétendre dans un
texte lutter contre l'immigration
illégale et ouvrir une brèche à
l'immigration illégale la fraude ne peut
pas être une voie de régularisation
parce que alors là on ouvre encore une
fois une une facilité qui va créer un
appel d'air la deuxème la deuxème raison
la deuxième raison c'est que c'est une
formidable capitulation que d'aller
chercher une main d'œuvre bon marché
quand en France il nous faut encore
mobiliser une réserve extraordinaire de
travail qu'on ne mobilise pas au moment
je vous parle il y a plus de 560000
étrangers qui eux sont en situation
régulière et qui sont au chômage au
moment où je vous parle il y a plus d'un
million de jeunes qui sont ni en emploi
ni à l'école 1900000 franc qui sont au
RSA et 3 millions qui sont au chômage
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait et j'ajoute et je termine
rapidement sur cet article 3 Le travail
l'activité professionnelle n'est
absolument pas une condition qui permet
d'éviter une radicalisation je voudrais
citer l'attentat symboliquement de celui
qui avait été perpétré à rambouiller
Jamel gorchen il était en situation de
travail il était chauffeur livreur ce
que nous voulons nous c'est que que le
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet
contrôle bien sûr l'activité réelle
professionnelle mais que on contrôle
dans ce
pouvoir discrétionnaire aussi la
capacité des individus à intégrer nos
propres valeurs c'est ce qui est
fondamental et c'est ce qui nous
distingue de ce fameux article 3 il y a
aussi le tabou je le disais du droit
parce que nous avons depuis des années
et des années abandonné les instruments
juridiques qui nous permettent de
réguler l'immigration et tout ça
desbouur impuissance extraordinaire une
impuissance coupable que les Français
constatent à chaque fait divhiver qui
n'en sont plus des faits divers bien
évidemment cette impuissance elle était
organisée d'abord par le législateur qui
a multiplié les protections les
exceptions à la règle et les exceptions
ont tué la règle et la règle peut tuer
des Français on l'a vu à Ar ras bien sûr
si cet individus caucasien avait été
expulsé le professeur Dominique Bernard
serait toujours en vie bien évidemment
et qu'importe s'il s'il est arrivé en
France avant son âge avant l'âge de de
13 ans nous ce que nous voulons ça n'est
pas multiplier les exceptions aux
exceptions ce que vous nous proposez ce
que nous voulons nous c'est anéantir les
exceptions pour que il y ait la règle
vis-à-vis des expulsions et vis-à-vis
des eqtf et que enfin on puisse aussi
rétablir ce que Hollande avait défait
c'est-à-dire le délu pour sé jours
irréguli pour bien marqué que un pays
une nation une communauté nationale un
corps politique c'est un dedans et un
dehors tout simplement pour ce qui
concerne cette impuissance je voudrais
revenir un instant sur un certain nombre
de jurisprudenceces qui sont choquantes
surtout lorsqu'elles font
systématiquement en tout cas parfois
prévaloir les droits individuels la
protection des droits individuels sur
l'intérêt général sur un cadre collectif
sur la le besoin d'un peuple de se
protéger je pourrais prendre plein
d'exemples je vais prendre des exemples
que vous vous connaissez bien la
condamnation par la CEDH de la France à
la suite de l'expulsion de deux
tetchenîn radicalisé comme vous le savez
et
dangereux et là nous sommes condamnés
parce que l'expulsion de ces individus
encore une fois dangereux ne permettait
pas d'avoir une garantie suffisante
qu'ils éent dans leur propre pays
d'origine un procès équitable mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire protéger
les Français ou protéger ces individus
dangereux vous avez répondu d'ailleurs
vous avez dit moi je préfère payer
l'amende et vous avez bien fait monsieur
le ministre vous voyez ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que il faut trouver
monsieur le rapporteur un juste
équilibre entre l'État de droit qui
respecte les textes qui n'interprète pas
dans des interprétations très créatives
les traités et la démocratie la
souveraineté populaire retourner les
droits individuels systématiquement
contre la souveraineté populaire ça
n'est pas l'état de droit ça n'est plus
l'état de droit évidemment c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous voulons ce
référendum une révision de la
Constitution pour rendre aux Français
cette capacité à décider par eux-même la
politique migratoire Françis française
président de la République a fait un pas
il y a loin de la coupe aux lèvres on
n'est pas des perdre de l'année le
président du Sénat n'est plus là en tout
cas moi je ne suis plus un perd de
l'année et et nous attendrons de voir ce
qu'il advient de cette révision
constitutionnelle le le tabout politique
un un mot simplement sur le le en même
temps je disais que c'était un double
jeu parce que il y a un non dit dans
dans ce texte c'est le contexte de son
élaboration il il a fallu que vous soyez
écartelé entre une aile droite et une
aile gauche le problème c'est que en
même temps en matière migratoire ça ne
marche pas parce que les signaux que
vous allez envoyer au monde entier et
que vont très bien percevoir les
filières ce doit être un signal de
grande fermeté tout l'axisme sera
interprété comme un appel d'air et vous
savez que en France nous avons des
appels d'air on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir en matière en matière de
regroupement familial et cetera euh un
ouvrage un ouvrage un ouvrage a été
rédigé par quelqu'un qui connaît très
bien ces choses-là et qui s'appelle
Didier Lesk et qui ne vient pas
d'ailleurs de d'une sucursale de la
droite pour terminer pour conclure
monsieur le ministre pour terminer pour
terminer et conclure je crois que je
pense que l'URE est grave parce que on
voit bien que jamais les risque les
menaces euh de partition que les menaces
euh de fragmentation communautaire
non'ont autant fragilisé l'unité
française et nous en sommes parfaitement
conscients c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous abandonnerons ni aux postures
de ceux qui pourraient se contenter du
yakafucon ou alors d'expédient de slogan
mais on se contentera pas non plus de
l'imposture de ceux qui qui appellent
l'ambigué qui appelle les demi-mesures
qui appelle finalement le en même temps
nous voulons un texte efficace et nous
nous voulons un texte utile on verra on
commence l'examen de ce texte ou bien ce
texte donne les conditions et nous
feront des propositions des nombreuses
propositions d'amendement ou bien ces
propositions sont reprises ou bien on
durcit le texte ou bien on a la
conviction intime d'aller dans le sens
supérieur de la nation parce que les
français demandent cette fermeté et les
Français d'abord encore une fois d'en
bas pas les Français d'en haut bien et
alors nous pourrons voter le texte si en
revanche si en revanche nous sommes
persuadés qu'il y a une ambiguïé qui
subsiste nous ne tricherons pas nous ne
jouerons pas les faux semblants et euh
nous nous opposerons à ce texte voilà
notre position elle est claire elle est
très très simple elle consiste à dire la
vérité au français et je pense que cet
enjeu il est énorme il est finalement si
je devais réduire en quelques mots de
faire en sorte que demain la République
euh soit partout chez elle en France
merci de votre
attention merci monsieur le
président
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
George patient pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
[Applaudissements]
indépendants monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monie le rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'immigration dans les UTR
aussi est une problématique de
première la réalité des outres mers en
matière d'immigration c'est d'être
humble face à l'immensité géographique
c'est pour la Guyane une frontière
fluviale sur 500 km dans la forêt
amazonienne avec le Surinam dans le pb
par habitant est 10 fois inférieur à
celui de la
France avec le Brésil dont la frontière
est de 700
km la réalité des outromè c'est pour les
Antilles d'avoir pour toute frontière la
mer des Caraïbes où le tourisme de Max
jte la grande délinquance et la misère
d'État insulaire en déliquessence c'est
également une étendue maritime de 102
km dans l'océan Indien qui ancre Mayotte
à son destin français les ordres de
grandeur donc dans les outrers sont loin
d'être les mêmes que dans
l'Hexagone il faut le savoir les deux
territoires français les plus impactés
par l'immigration sont Mayot et la
Guyane où plus de la moitié de la
population pour l'un et plus du tiers
pour l'autre est
étrangère aussi comme pour beaucoup de
mes collègues il me semble indispensable
d'avoir un débat au Parlement sur toutes
les adaptations qui devraient être
apporté en matière de gestion de
l'immigration dans les
outrers c'est le sens d'un des
amendements que j'ai déposé et qui a
également été déposé sur d'autres bancs
et qui vis à supprimer l'habilitation à
légiférer par ordonnance pour le
gouvernement d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre j'ai le sentiment que le
gouvernement n'est pas complètement
opposé à la démarche puisque certains
amendements spécifiques aux outrè
déposés par mes collègues de maotte ou
moi-même avec ma collègue de guyan ont
été travaillés avec votre cabinet je
pense notamment à l'amendement qui
permettra de répondre au défis que
représente la filière d'immigration qui
utilise les visas humanitaires accordés
par le Brésil pour rentrer en Guyane
avec l'Hexagone pour destination finale
en attendant son adoption Cayenne et sa
mère doivent faire face à un afflux de
migrants qui en raison d'un manque de
place d'hébergement occupe l'espace
public et cristallise les
mécontentements pour autant le texte que
le gouvernement a déposé au Sénat début
février était relativement équilibré
apportant des réponses pragmatiques et
courageuses notamment pour tout ce qui
touche au travail des étrangers ainsi
les articles 3 et 4 sont essentiels car
ils améliorent l'accès au travail des
migrants ou des réfugiés or le travail
est le premier facteur
d'intégration de plus il faut cesser de
faire croire aux Français que nous
pourrions nous passer des immigrés la
DARES révélait dans une étude de juillet
2021 que 22 % des emplois en
Île-de-France étaient
occupés par des
immigrés les métiers dans lesquels ils
sont surreésentés sont où les conditions
de travail sont les plus pénibles et les
difficultés de recrutement sont les plus
fortes ainsi jusqu'à présent tout un pan
de notre économie tourne grâce à une
foule de travailleurs sans papier qui
viennent palier le déficit de main
d'œuvre ce projet de loi va permettre
ENF à ces personnes et à leurs
employeurs de rentrer dans la légalité
et toute la société bénéficiera de
retomber
positive ce projet de loi comporte
également notamment d'autres mesures qui
auront un impact positif important dans
les autres mèes comme à l'article 7 avec
la création d'une nouvelle carte de
séjour pour les médecins venant de pays
hors Union Européenne cette nouvelle
carte de séjour devrait permettre
d'améliorer le recrutement des padus qui
sont indispensables à nos établissements
de santé malheureusement la commission
des lois a supprimé une partie de la
mesure j'espère que les débats
permettront de revenir à la version
d'origine dans le même ordid j'ai déposé
en j'ai déposé un amendement pour
autoriser le recrutement d'infirmière en
Guyane hors Union européenne comme cela
se fait déjà à Saint-Pierre et Miclot
vous l'auriez compris qu'il y a des
évolutions positives et même
indispensable de dans ce texte cependant
l'actualité récente a tendu les esprits
et durcit les positions mais j'espère
que nous arriverons à avoir un débat
serein sur ces questions et que le bon
sens l'emportera la nécessité d'adapter
en permanence la loi aux évolutions de
l'immigration justifie ce projet de loi
la posture et l'affichage de fermeté de
certains ne doivent pas nous empêcher
d'apporter une réponse plus humède et
plus efficace je vous
remercie merci Monsieur patient la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
michaelll valet pour le groupe
socialiste écologist républicain pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Madame et
monsieurs les rapporteurs Madame et
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues il
me revient de compléter la position du
groupe soci e sur les aspects de
politique linguistique ainsi que sur les
éléments relatifs à la politique de
délivrance des visas du texte issu de la
commission s'agissant des dispositions
relatives à l'exigence d'un niveau de
français tout en louant l'objectif
théorique nous ne pouvons que regretter
les conclusions qu'en a tiré notamment
la commission je m'explique d'autres
pays dans le monde ont ce type
d'exigence bien légitime citons le
Québec son gouvernement actuel a
récemment relevé le niveau de français
exigé en même temps qu'il a augmenté le
nombre d'immigrés à accueillir qui qui
peut les emblammer car dans leur cas il
n'existe qu'une alternative malheureuse
au nouvel arrivant qui ne parlent pas
déjà français devenir anglophone ce qui
est très malheureux et mettre à mal la
cohésion
nationale en France et espérons-le pour
encore longtemps il n'y a qu'une langue
commune et aucune autre capable de
s'imposer à elle la question du niveau
de français des immigrés pose donc moins
celle de la vivacité de notre langue
face à celle de chacun d'eux que celle
de leur propre capacité à travailler
vivre avoir des les interactions
sociales et suivre la scolarité de leurs
enfants c'est en plus de l'intégration à
la québécoise en français l'idée de
l'intégration par le français ce n'est
donc pas la langue qui est menacée mais
la facilité pour les immigrés à
l'utiliser à des fins d'intégration
indispensable or ce qui nous est
présenté dans ce texte c'est-à-dire
exiger demain pour un titre de séjour
annuel ce que nous exigeons aujourd'hui
pour un titre de séjour pluriannuel ne
semble pas poursuivre cet objectif
confondant le but par les Français et
l'outil le français considéré alors
comme un critère de tri préalable entre
étrangers car cet outil qui est la
langue à la manière d'un outil primaire
se forge se poit et voit affuter le
tranchant de Sal lame avec le temps il
faut donc donner le temps et les moyens
d'y parvenir que voulons-nous pour les
nouveaux immigrés et notamment les
travailleuses vous en avez parlé
monsieur le ministre un examen de
bachotage au bout d'un an ou une vraie
maîtrise de la langue sur le temps long
relever le niveau de langue exigé sans
s'en donner les moyens très concrets ne
mène nulle part et c'est ce que nous
défendrons dans nos différents
amendements mon deuxième point porte sur
la disposition introduite en commission
consistant à offrir un nouveau motif
légal de refus de visa de long séjour
notamment au ressortissant d'un État
délivrant un nombre particulièrement
faible de laisser passer
consulaire nous le disons clairement il
n'est pas tenable que des états sabotent
la mise en œuvre de décisions de justice
française en organisant de manière
systémique leur incapacité supposé à
reconnaître leurs nationaux mais nous
socialistes considérant considérons que
l'introduction dans la loi de cette
politique de rétorsion ne permettra pas
d'atteindre l'objectif annoncé encore
une fois que nous partageons en grande
partie je le redis il arrive que la
diplomatie réclame un peu de finesse et
que cette finesse échappe à la pensée la
plus complexe de nos plus hauts
dirigeants déjà en froid avec nos
voisins méditerranéens et avec les
opinions africaines nous enverrions un
signal public bien dommageable
si les États n'ont pas seulement des
valeurs mais aussi des intérêts à
commencer par Le Nôtre le travail des
chancelleries vaut parfois mieux pour
les faire respecter qu'une démonstration
de virilité législative
contre-productive le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs expérimenté cette méthode à
compter du printemps 2021 avec les pays
du Maghreb pour constater l'échec et y
renoncer dès 2022 et oui la diplomatie
comme la préfectorale d'ailleurs c'est
un métier enfin traitant des aspects
internationaux de ce projet de loi je me
dois d'évoquer notre maire commune la
Méditerranée et ce cimetière qu'elle est
devenu la Méditerranée berceau de
civilisation au pluriel est matrice de
tant de cultures dont la nôtre française
on y meurt par centaine dans une
indifférence dramatique formulons le
souhait que notre pays sache malgré les
vant mauvais qui nous agite et agite
l'opinion continuer à distinguer d'une
part les nécessaires débats sur les
politiques migratoires que nous allons
avoir présentement et d'autre part la
nécessité absolue de sauver des vies
quel que soit le contexte et sans aucune
condition préalable à ce propos
justement sur la Méditerranée depuis le
début des débats monsieur le ministre
vous avez cité le président Hollande la
majorité sénatoriale nous l'avons
entendu tout à l'heure a eu l'occasion
de citer le président mitéran mais il
est grand le mystère de la droite il n'y
a personne pour évoquer les déclarations
réchantes du chef d'État vaticané
peut-être aurons-nous l'occasion de le
faire pendant les débats en tout cas
c'est désormais chose faite dans les
discours d' introduction décidément les
socialistes doivent tout faire ici je
vous
remercie merci merci beaucoup monsieur
valet maintenant la parole est au
Président Monsieur François Noël buffet
pour le groupe les républicains pour 7
minutes monsieur le ministre madame et
monsieurs le les rapporteurs par pardon
monsieur le Président chers collègues
quelques mots tout d'abord un point de
constat et ensuite peut-être une
explication sur la stratégie que nous
souhaitons développer après la crise du
covid-19 notre pays a renoué d'abord
avec des flux migratoires irrégulier
très important selon d'ailleurs les
chiffres de Frontex
230350 personnes ont franchi
irrégulièrement les frontières de
l'Union européenne sur les 8 premiers
mois de l'année 2023 soit le niveau le
plus haut haut depuis 2016 plus de 80
près de 90000 personnes ont fait l'objet
d'un refus d'entrée à nos frontières en
2022 là aussi un record sur notre sol le
nombre de personnes en situation
irrégulière ne cesse de grandir le
nombre de bénéficiaire d'ailleurs de
l'Ame qui est un critère parmi d'autres
mais qui ne suffit pas naturellement
nous annonce 400000 personnes en 2022
soit 100000 de plus qu'il y a 10 ans
pourrait naturellement continuer pendant
longtemps d'égrainer ce type de chiffre
c'est incapacité à maîtriser nos
frontières est d'autant plus inquiétante
que évidemment elle pose le problème de
la reconduite dans les pays d'origine
dont nous savons que malgré les 120000
octf qui ont été prononcés ces dernières
années à peu près 10000 ont été exécuté
ce qui reste mais l'indicateur est
imparfait parce qu'il faut tenir compte
effectivement de la difficulté à obtenir
des laissés passer consulaires même
d'ailleurs notre politique d'immigration
régulière cette fois-ci nous n'avons
jamais délivré autant de titre de ses
jours 316000 premiers titres en 2022 et
pour autant nous intégrons de moins en
moins bien je dis bien de moins en moins
bien je rappelle que d'ailleurs la
plupart des étrangers qui arrivent sur
le territoire parlent ou écrivent mal le
français à l'essue de leur première
année de séjour et je ne parle pas non
plus des crises des rendez-vous que dans
les préfectures tout cela finalement
montre les difficultés la situation
n'est pas si différente s'agissant de la
politique de l'asile l'OFPRA comme la
CNDA sont au bord de l'embolie nous le
savons en 2023 il y aura pratiquement
140000 demandes et les prévisions du
gouvernement sont de l'ordre de 160000
pour
2024 évidemment la dét la détérioration
des délis va venir complexifier les
choses alors face à cette situation le
texte arrive très bien quel est le
critère de départ que nous devons
semble-t-il déterminer quelle politique
migratoire de quelle politique
migratoire la France veut-elle se doter
et une fois qu'elle aura fait le choix
encore faut-il que les mesures qui
soient prises soient très clair et
compréhensible par tout le monde il me
semble que nous avons besoin d'abord de
définir ceci et cette clarté me paraît
se traduire à travers trois points très
simples le premier c'est que
l'immigration régulière doit être une
immigration choisie que cette
immigration choisie doit correspondre à
naturellement une baisse de
l'immigration régulière à actuellement
et choisi sur la base plutôt d'une d'une
immigration économique qualifiée
j'entendais tout à l'heure que on nous
disait que potentiellement l'immigration
était une chance sans doute à quellees
condition il suffit de relire le rapport
de l'OCDE de 2021 qui dit très
clairement que en France notre
difficulté c'est que notre immigration
sur le plan économique n'est pas
qualifiée et que c'est notre handicap
c'est pas nous qui le disons c'est
l'OCDE qui le dit et donc nous avons
besoin de nous recentrer sur une
immigration économique qualifiée en
nombre moins important qu'aujourd'hui
par même beaucoup moins important de
façon à faciliter évidemment
l'intégration le deuxième point quel
est-il ben c'est l'intransigence dans la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
nous ne pouvons pas continuer comme cela
par le nombre de procédures possibles
pour détourner les objectifs qui sont
fixés par différents différentes
procédures qui veulent éloigner les
étrangers c'est la première chose des
procéures très complexes il y a
pratiquement 13 ou 14 moyens de saisir
les tribunaux administratifs le rapport
que nous avons rendu au Sénat il y a
quelques années enfin il y a un peu plus
d'un an démontre à l'évidence que les
juridictions administratives sont
absolument en situation de saturation le
nier serait tout de même inacceptable il
faut donc simplifier c'est l'objectif du
texte l'objectif du rapport qui a été en
partie repris dans le texte et c'est
important que de le dire mais c'est
aussi la capacité de pouvoir répondre
rapidement aux demandes des uns et des
autres a et aux situations des uns et
des autres et puis c'est la capacité
d'établir disons-le ici le rapport de
force avec les pays d'origine parce
qu'il faudra bien de toute façon
continuer d'obtenir des laisser passer
consulair et que cela ne peut ne peut se
faire monsieur le ministre je crois que
vous le savez j'imagine que tout le
monde le sait que si notre position sur
notre stratégie est parfaitement claire
pour qu'elle soit parfaitement comprise
et que l'on se donne les moyens de ce
rapport de force fusil difficile il faut
néanmoins le porter sinon il n'y a pas
de choix et puis enfin il a la les
problématiques des procédures d'asile
nous savons tous ici que la procédure
d'asile telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
voir depuis plusieurs années qu'elle
sert de détournement à l'objectif qui
est le sien la majorité des demandes son
la très grande majorité des demandes
sont faites uniquement pour permettre de
rester sur le territoire national en
espérant rester le plus longtemps
possible et bénéficier éventuellement
d'autres moyens de protection qu'est-ce
qui se passe et bien celui qui mérite
d'être protégé d'avoir le statut de
réfugié attend des années et des années
et les autres attendent tranquillement
la décision en se disant que plus elle
sera tardive mieux ce sera et qu's en
tiront un profit nous sommes victimes
deux fois ceux qui méritent la
protection rapide de la France et on a
raison de la donner ils étaient à peu
près 35000 se font de ma part ces
dernières années et il faudrait aller
vite mais ceux qui ne la méritent pas
doivent le savoir également rapidement
pour qu'il puisse être reconduit dans
leur pays d'origine bien sûr c'est donc
à la faveur de ces trois constats et à
mon avis de ces trois stratégies qu'on
pourra potentiellement avancer
sérieusement doter notre pays de
politique migratoire faut-il pour autant
dire que nous sommes très durs oui nous
sommes fermes bien sûr nous sommes
fermes nous voulons être fermes car le
message que nous enverrons est tout
aussi important que ce qu'il y aura dans
le texte mais nous devons aussi être
responsable c'est-à-dire se doter de
moyens suffisants pour pouvoir intégrer
ce que l'on accepte sur notre territoire
et nous avons fixé des un certain nombre
de règles d'ailleurs à la commission des
lois les rapporteurs l'ont dit très
clairement alors puisque mon temps est
compte si je puis dire il reste 30
secondes je voudrais simplement insister
sur le fait que ce texte en tous les cas
pour nous dans notre groupe et je crois
pour la majorité consiste à mettre de la
clarté pour obtenir de l'efficacité à la
fois pour ceux que l'on accueille et les
accueillir de façon qualitative et enfin
de la fermeté de l'efficacité à l'égard
de ceux qu'on ne veut pas voir sur le
territoire qui doivent repartir la
question étant que tout cela se passe
dans des procédures certes respectueuses
mais extrêmement rapides c'est tout l'OB
de ce que nous avons fait à la
commission des lois et que probablement
les débats qui sont les nôtres
permettront d'aborder dans les jours qui
viennent pour ne pas dire dans les
heures qui viennent voilà je remerci de
votre
attention merci président buffet la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Roger
caroci pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
le
Rapporteur certes un énième texte sur
l'immigration quelle
importance notre premier texte en la
matière sur la nationalité les étrangers
l'immigration date de
1889 et depuis tous les gouvernements de
gauche et de droite du Centre ou
d'ailleurs ont tous fait des textes
pendant le Front populaire avant la
guerre de 14 avant dans les années 50 et
encore aujourd'hui tous avec les mêmes
fondements
l'immigration est une politique
régalienne
elle doit être déterminée par un
gouvernement et par un état sur ce que
représente sa capacité à intégrer ce que
représente sa capacité à maintenir
l'unité de sa nation sa capacité à
laisser la société dans l'état dans
lequel elle
est aujourd'hui c'est vrai monsieur le
ministre un nouveau texte bon après
celui de 2018 mais la situation a bien
changé sur les 15 20 dernières années je
représente j'ai cette chance et cet
honneur le Sénat à l'office français
d'immigration et
d'intégration et à plusieurs reprises je
me suis exprimé à la Commission des
finances comme dans cet hémicycle pour
réussir
l'intégration je le dis de manière très
calme mais très
sûre nous n'y parvenons plus nous n'y
parvenons plus parce qu'un pays qui a
plus de 3000 milliards d'euros de dett
parce qu'un pays qui a les déficites
budgétaires qui sont les siens
aujourd'hui parce qu'un pays qui a les
fractures sociales et sociétales qui
sont les nôtres aujourd'hui et dans la
difficulté à la fois matérielle
financière pour intégrer mais il est
aussi dans la difficulté de la
transmission les pays qui peuvent et qui
ont fait par exemple lorsque Angela
Merkel a accepté un nombre de migrants
important sur une seule année c'était
une époque où l'Allemagne était dans une
situation forte financièrement
économiquement humainement si
aujourd'huia
change de politique c'est parce que
l'Allemagne n'est plus dans cette
situation si aujourd'hui la France doit
remettre en cause les mouvements
migratoires tels qu'ils sont c'est parce
que le pays n'est plus dans la situation
d'il y a 30 ans d' y a 40 ans oui bien
sûr la France son honneur avant la
guerre de 14 elle a intégré très bien
les Italiens les Polonais qui venaient
dans l'entre de guerre des Italiens des
Espagnols après la deème guerre mondiale
des Portugais et des Algériens qui
arrivé et l'intégration s'est bien passé
il faut le dire très clairement jusque
dans les années 60 70 l'intégration a
été une force de la France elle ne l'est
plus aujourd'hui parce que la société
française a changé parce que
malheureusement c'est la vie l'économie
française n'est plus ce qu'elle été
parce que nous n'avons plus la capacité
d'intégrer des grands nombres je ne sais
plus qu' l' a dit tout à l'heure oui
l'intégration est facile si vous avez un
petit nombre parce qu'alors les
structures de l'État les structures des
collectivités locales que je reconnais
prennent en main réussissent cette
intégration lorsque le nombre est trop
important et bien cela ne fonctionne
plus j'ai été de ceux qui ici dans cette
hémicycle on demandait à ce qu'à l'issue
des cours de français il y ait un examen
parce que membre de l'OFI j'allais
régulièrement dans les salles je n'en
parle pas comme ça dans les salles pour
voir que bien des gens venaient parfois
malheureusement les hommes imposés aux
femmes qui étaient là de se voiler de ne
pas prendre la parole pendant les cours
et à la fin on disait bah ils ont été
présents 80h ils ont été présents 20h il
y a donc pas à vérifier qu'ils sachent
le moindre mot de français ça n'est pas
acceptable nous sommes en République
nous défendons la République la
République elle est là pour tous mais
elle est là aussi pour faire en sorte
que la société française ne soit pas
davantage fr tuis elle est suffisamment
comme ça nous avons en tant qu'élu tous
ici une responsabilité première faire en
sorte que la France reste la nation
unique elle a toujours été par le passé
par rapport à ses opposants par rapport
à la compétition internationale si nous
ne sommes pas capables d'assurer cela
comment voulez-vous que nous soyons
capables d'intégrer d'autres de faire en
sorte que les valeurs françaises
républicaine et nationale soit transmis
à d'autres alors que nous ne sommes même
pas capables aujourd'hui
de faire en sorte qu'elle soit
totalement assimilée par la société
française nous avons donc une
introspection tous à faire à gauche à
droite au centre tout le monde est
responsable de la situation actuelle
nous n'avons pas vu la société française
se fracturer de plus en plus nous
n'avons pas vu notre quasi impossibilité
d'intégrer d'où aujourd'hui ces
territoires perdus ces quartiers
difficiles parce que en réalité à un
moment donné l'inversion ne s'est pas
faite dans nos politique et nous avons
cru peut-être sûrement avec trop
d'angélisme que nous y parviendrions
puisque nos ancêtres y étaient parvenu
dans les années 1900 dans les années
1950 nous ne sommes plus ni la France ni
l'Europe ni le monde des années 50 nous
n'y parvenons plus et nous avons
absolument besoin maintenant d'avoir une
immigration choisie d'avoir une maîtrise
des flux de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
beaucoup moins d'entrée sur le
territoire national pour pouvoir
intégrer ceux qui veulent réellement
devenir Français participer à l'économie
française participer à la société
française être fier d'être français au
terme de leur intégration nous ne
pouvons plus faire en sorte que nous
ayons des apports tellement massif qu'
ne sont pas intégrés pas assimilés et
qu'en réalité nous fabriquons nous-mêmes
des antifrance de l'avenir la
responsabilité de la France la
responsabilité des élus c'est de dire
voilà les moyens dont nous disposons
voilà ce que nous pouvons acceptter
voilà ce que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter n'allons pas au-delà parce que
si nous allons au-delà et bien en
réalité nous ne faisons pas de la bonne
politique migratoire nous ne faisons pas
de la bonne politique d'asile on l'a dit
tout à l'heure aujourd'hui 140000
demandes d'asile c'est un détournement
manifeste il y a 10 ans 15 ans il y en
avait 35000 donc clairement on demande
l'asile pour faire un détournement de
l'immigration économique nous avons des
structures qu'il faut reprendre en main
parce que si nous V voul avoir des
immigrés qui demain soient fier d'être
français il faut qu'ils soi parfaitement
intégrés et pour être parfaitement
intégrés ils doivent être moins nombreux
ceux qui rentrent sur le territoire de
manière illégale doivent être reconduits
à la frontière et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que notre système explose en
vol merci merci Monsieur
carucci maintenant la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Géral
armanin merci Monsieur le le Président
je évidemment remercier tous les
orateurs qui se sont exprimés en
commencer par remercier ceux qui
apportent un soutien d'ors et déjà au
texte du Gouvernement bien sûr le groupe
RDPI le groupe centriste groupe des
indépendants j'ai compris qu'il y avait
des on va voir on va voir du groupe du
RDSE on va voir du groupe les
républicains et puis j'ai compris qu'il
y avait par nature des gens qui
souhaitient s'opposer au gouvernement
même s'il ne refuse pas la
discussion par définition ou par
introduction sans sans faire le débat
sans faire le débat d'avance mais ouvert
à à certain nombre de propositions c'est
le grade du du cas du groupe communiste
pour faire vide du groupe socialiste et
du groupe écologiste je pas répondre à
tous les orateurs mais peut-être à
quelquesuns d'entre vous soit parce que
les propos me semble apporter si il le
permettent un complément de la part du
du gouvernement soit répondre à un
certain nombre de questions soit pour
préciser un certain nombre de de termes
puisqu'on va passer quelques jours et
peut-être quelques nuits à travailler
sur ce texte important euh bien
évidemment Monsieur
benarche Je je je pense qu'il faut que
dès le début on essae tous ensemble me
semble-t-il de nous poser les les
questions qui correspondent non pas à
des pressupposés ou des postures mais
bien des réalités vous dites par exemple
vous voulez l'intégration et puis vous
baissez les crédits de laada mais c'est
en fait assez cohérent avec le texte du
gouvernement puisque si j'avais inscrit
dans le budget de l'année prochaine une
augmentation des crédits de Lada qui est
donc le versement de l'aide sociale que
nous donnons au demandeurs d'asile ça
veut dire que j'anticipe le fait que le
texte sera pas efficace puisque le
principe de ce texte c'est de pouvoir
simplifier les procédures pour très vite
comme l'a dit le président de la
commission des lois et comme j'ai essayé
de vous le démontrer dire oui ou dire
non à quelqu'un et l'inscription à Lada
elle est automatique ça arrivera à tous
les ministres de l'Intérieur qui me
succèderont il ne discuteent pas du
montant de Lada dans le budget avec les
parlementaires le Conseil d'État
considère qu'effectivement c'est le
nombre de demandeurs d'asile qui aura
sur le territoire national le temps
qu'ils sont en demande d'asile si
j'avais présenté au Parlement une
augmentation de la DVE vous m'ariez dit
sans doute au côté droit de l'hémicycle
cher amis c'est bien sympathique vous
prévoyez déjà que votre texte de loi le
20e le 25e le 30e n'est pas efficace
j'essaie d'être d'être cohérent monsieur
monsieur benarche ce qui ne veut pas
dire vous neavez pas dit complètement
qu'on n pas augmenté tous les autres
crédits d'intégration dans le budget que
je vous ai présenté pour l'année
prochaine puisque tous les autres
crédits d'intégration y compris ceux qui
concerne l'intégration par la langue
augmente donc oui la D baisse la D
baisse parce que nous réussirons j'en
suis certain à aller plus vite dans les
procédures de demande d'asile grâce à
cette loi et grâce au travail essentiel
que font les agents de lofpra mais non
les crédits d'intégration ne baissent
pas ils augmentent notamment par la
langue je vrais d'ailleurs dire ici à
Monsieur caouci et peut-être à Monsieur
rotillot que Monsieur SCHS en effet
prend des mesures de restriction
désormais de l'immigration mais un peu
tard je vous rappelle que si nous nous
sommes entre 130000 et 140000 demandes
d'asile au moment où je vous parle qui à
peu près le chiffre de l'année dernière
en légère augmentation c'est vrai
l'Allemagne est à 230000 au moment où
nous parlons quand je suis devenu
ministre de l'Intérieur nous étions à
120000 demandes d'asile quand
l'Allemagne était à 160000 3 ans après
nous sommes à 130000 140000 on verra la
fin de l'année l'Allemagne est à 225000
il referme après avoir beaucoup ouvert
et et je pense qu'il faut aussi le dire
ainsi sinon on ne comprend pas la
position qu' a désormais monsieur Scholz
en effet qui n'est pas dans dans la même
position que les socialistes français
manifestement monsieur benarage vous
avez évoqué également la protection
temporaire que nous offrons aux
ukrainien ça a été également évoqué par
Monsieur Dosu vous dites finalement et
ça je l'entends assez facilement
pourquoi on ne fait pas comme avec les
Ukrainiens mais j'allais vous dire
chiche mais je suis pas sûr que c'est ce
que vous voulez défendre au fond c'est
quoi la protection temporaire que nous
avons décidé tous les ministres de
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne
ensemble pour les Ukrainiens c'est que
justement on le donnait pas l'asile et
qu'on leur disait Mesdames et Messieurs
les Ukrainiens vous avez 3 ans dans 3
ans vous n'avez plus la protection la
différence fondamentale avec un Afghan
première demande d'asile française c'est
que nous donnons l'asile à vitam à
etternam on ne conditionne pas la fin de
l'asile au retour de vie démocratique
dans leur pays nous nous pensons que
nous allons gagner la guerre contre la
Russie en aidant les Ukrainiens pendant
un certain temps bah oui nous les
accueillons sur le territoire européen
tous les Européens ensemble en échange
de quoi bien sûr ils peuvent travailler
dès le premier jour jour mais je vous
signale monsieur benarche queils n'ont
pas l'asile et certains se sont élevés à
l'époque des associations pour dire
pourquoi vous donnez pas l'asile aux
Ukrainiens mais parce que nous pensons
que nous vons pouvoir retourner très
rapidement dans leur pays si la solution
que vous proposez au groupe écologiste
c'est de dire on arrête la demande
d'asile telle qu'elle existe depuis la
Révolution française ou la Convention de
Genève et on la remplace par la
protection temporaire qu'on offre aux
Ukrainiens c'est pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui trouvera à redire sauf à
considérer que vous êtes beaucoup trop
dur avec les demandeurs d'asile
peut-être pe-être pour revenir aussi à
la question de Monsieur brossa dont j'ai
goûté et j'ai été sensible à
quelques-uns de ces arguments sans être
d'accord évidemment sur le sur le fond
de son intervention en général je peux
comprendre
votre distinction pays d'accueil pays
d'arrivée pour savoir qu'est-ce qui
motive le départ finalement de ces
personnes je pense que il y a des
raisons extrêmement diverses si on est
tout à fait entre nous il y a des pays
il y a des grands pays d'Afrique qui
offrent une couverture sociale
extrêmement forte à leur personnes à
leurs citoyens leur off logement gratuit
le gaz quasi gratuit l'essence quasi
gratuit les produits de première
nécessité quasi gratuit le chômage et il
est si on compare les choses assez vrai
qu'il ne trouve pas en
France la même protection en tout cas
une protection beaucoup plus différente
que ce qu'ils ont et ce départ et
parfois le départ de cette jeunesse mais
aussi de catégories social
professionnelle plus élevé c'est aussi
un mode de vie qui vient chercher en
France donc c'est vrai qu'il ne viennent
pas chercher que des questions de
protection sociale ça peut être le cas
c'est pas tout à fait vrai mais ça peut
être le cas ils peuvent chercher un mode
de vie et ils peuvent chercher une
protection protection dans l'
orientation sexuelle protection
religieuse protection politique bien
évidemment je pense qu'il y a diverses
interprétation je crois que ce serait
faux de dire que les personnes qui
viennent en France ou en Europe ne ne
cherchent que le modèle social français
même s'il est effectivement généreux et
qui n'est pas aussi vrai vous l'avez dit
vous-même pour le RSA en faisant une
distinction exprès j'imagine à la
tribune que ce qu'on dit c'est vrai que
les personnes irrégulières ne touchent
pas le RS en France on l'entend beaucoup
mais ce n'est pas vrai bon alors
cependant il y a quand même une mesure
d'attractivité que ne peut pas nier
monsieur brossa et l'honnêteté
intellectuelle nous pousse à à l' voir
quand 40 % des demandeurs d'asile dans
les 100 % de demandeur d'asile que la
France a Vienne d'autres pays européens
c'est qu'il y a quand même une
comparaison
d'attractivité sinon on quitterait son
pays en guerre son pays dans lequel on a
un certain nombre de persécutions
religieuses politique quand on arrive en
Italie quand on arrive même en Suisse
qui est dans l'espace Schengen quand on
arrive en Belgique quand on arrive en
Espagne on devrait pas avoir envie
d'aller dans un autre pays de l'espace
européen puisque on y trouve là une
démocratie un accompagnement politique
évidemment euh puisque nous avons signé
à peu près les mêmes traités qui
garantissent les droits de l'homme la
vérité de sa propre existence
personnelle quand 40 % des demandeurs
d'asile que nous avons à l'OFPRA ou en
fait déposer l'asile dans un autre pays
européen c'est bien quelque chose qui ne
va pas soit tous les demandeurs d'asile
sont devenus des personnes qui
multiplient demand d'asile partout en
Europe et vous savez bien que dans les
conditions dans lesquelles il livveent
ce n'est pas vrai soit il trouvent en
France soit un intérêt linguistique il
viennent rejoindre une communauté qu'il
connaissent c'est possible soit il
reviennent d'une famille ce qui explique
qu'une partie d'entre eux vont en
Grande-Bretagne parce qu'ils trouvent
beaucoup de gens il y a plus d'un
million d'irréguliers en Grande-Bretagne
qui qui évidemment les pousse à
rejoindre leur père leurs mère leurs
fiancé ou leurs enfants soit ils y
trouvent des moyens de travailler sans
le dire en tout cas pas officiellement
et c'est pour ça que le texte vise à
lutter contre cet écosystème qui est en
effet irrégulier soit ils y trouvent une
attractivité sociale et c'est pas un
mauvais mot je serai à leur place je
ferai exactement la même chose et dans
ce cas-là je pense que notre position
c'est d'avoir la même position que
l'ensemble des pays européens le jour où
nous avons une politique européenne de
d'attractivité sociale mais Ben très
bien il y aura plus de comparaison de
pays à pays donc je crois que ce que
vous dites est à la fois juste mais
permettez-moi de dire qu'il y a quand
même une partie de ces personnes qui
viennent en France pour des mesures sans
doute qui consistent à y trouver des
avantages qui n'ont pas d'entre pays
encore une fois il y a aucun jugement
moral c'est un constat après est-ce
qu'on l'assume ou est-ce qu'on l'assume
pas c'est une une évidemment une
décision politique qui appartient à des
débats politiques ce que je dis moi en
revanche et je pense que c'est un débat
très important parce qu'il faut qu'on
essaie d'être honnête dans nos
convictions je ne suis pas tout à fait
certain que les gens viennent en France
par notre modèle social mais jeis à peu
près certain qu'ils y restent par notre
modèle social ce qui est assez différent
c'estàd que je pense qu'arriver en
France après un long voyage un long
voyage difficile je ne suis pas certain
qu'en effet il peut y avoir en effet des
filières de passeurs qui promeuvent le
modèle français je je je n'en
disconviens pas et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement corriger ça mais il est
certain en tout cas moi de ce que je
vois depuis 3 ans et demi que je suis
ministre de l'intérieur c'est que des
gens restent parce que nous avons pas un
système assez désincitatif aux personnes
de repartir parce que quand vous êtes
quelqu'un qui est en arrê en en TF
confirmé par la justice c'est quelqu'un
qui a passé un certain temps sur le
territoire national il peut donc
travailler il peut créer sa boîte
d'auto-entreprise sans qu'on il demande
des papiers à Beris pour servir les
repas ou pour conduire des personnes
dans des voiture je vous rappelle que
cette disposition existe dans le texte
de loi jusqu'à présent vous pouvez créer
votre auto-entreprise sans qu'on vous
demande vos papiers voilà une voilà une
une machine à créer de lairrégularité
c'est quand même ce que fait la loi
française aujourd'hui voilà pourquoi
cette loi est nécessaire donc vous
pouvez venir irrégulier sur le
territoire national on vous a refusé
tout votre demande de titre de séjour
Votre demande d'asile vous pouvez quand
même créer votre vre entreprise ou
d'ailleurs vous payez des impôts des
charges sociales sans bénéficier des
charges sociales enfin de la protection
sociale vous pouvez on l'a vu accéder à
un logement et notamment un logement
social vous pouvez accéder à la santé et
notamment dans le cadre de laame vous
avez même 100 % de la couverture après 9
mois pour des raisons qu'on pourrait
d'ailleurs évoquer dans le débat et qui
sont pas a priori moi je la me je suis
niitthémique pour la supprimer ni
tothémique pour la garder je pense qu'il
faut qu'on regarde les choses calmement
sereinement et et qu'on essaie d'en
discuter et qu'il faut évidemment
soigner toutes les personnes qui se
présente devant le système français
enfin c'est un fait que vous êtes plus
couvert après 9 mois d'irrégularité
qu'avant 9 mois d'irrégularité et vous
pouvez dans des conditions que nous
avons évoqué vivre sans partager les
valeurs de la République en aucune
manière et sans surtout parler français
ça incite pas les gens à partir
directement de notre pays sont puisque
vous savez bien que l'essentiel destf
sont des départs volontaires l'essentiel
les eqtf que nous mettons c'est je
remets un arrêté de reconduite à la
frontière à quelqu'un qui doit
l'exécuter lui-même c'est c'est très
petit le nombre de qtf qui sont des
départs forcés avec des policiers qui
les amènent à l'aéroport donc il je
pense qu'il faut qu'on qu'on tire des
des des conclusion du fait qu'on a dit
non et définitivement non à une personne
on peut pas l'accompagner évidemment
socialement sinon il y a une sorte de
contradiction dans notre politique
publique et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
que nous voyons les demandeurs d'asile
et notamment l'accompagnement social
quel qu'il soit autour de ça je pense
que c'est très juste que de dire c'est
ce que font tous les pays autour de nous
euh je je voudrais dire euh peut-être à
Madame Nara couin j'espère que je
prononce bien votre nom Narin pardon
madame la la sénatrice vous avez utilisé
plusieurs fois le terme de de migrant ce
que d'autres interlocuteurs n'ont pas
forcément fait moi peut-être que nous
pourrions tous nommer les choses
correctement le terme de migrants
général est difficile moi je je je ne
l'utilise pas parce que soit vous avez
des demandeurs d'asile et dans C CASL il
faut étudier leur demande d'asile et la
question savoir si on répond vite et on
dit OUI ou on dit non soit vous avez des
gens qui viennent pas regroupement
familial ou réunification familiale ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
bon soit vous avez des travailleurs qui
viennent pour le pour le des immigrés
qui viennent pour les questions
économiques soit vous avez des
clandestins mais derrière le terme
migrant il y a toute ces vérité euh
effectivement quand on dit migrant on a
l'impression que c'est des personnes qui
quoi qu'il arrive sont persécuté euh
pour ce qu'ils font et on leur doit euh
l'accueil moi je pense que ce n'est pas
le cas quand vous avez des euh
sénégalais des Ivoiriens des Maroc ain
qui viennent demander l'asile comme
migrant à Lampedusa je me dis que non ce
n'est pas possible première demande de
migrat prière demande d'asile
l'Afghanistan ça peut tout à fait se
comprendre très gros taux de protection
deuxième demande d'asile en France
Bangladesh déjà un peu plus compliqué à
comprendre mais on peut comprendre les
réfugiés climatiques qui existent au
bangladèch j' essayie de m'intéresser à
cette question 3è demande demande
d'asile c'est pas du tout un pays en
guerre c'est pas du tout un pays sur
lequel nous n'ons pas de relation
diplomatique c'est pas du tout on fait
pas de développement et quand je vois
des Sénégalais des Gabonais des
Ivoiriens des Marocains des Tunisiens
qui demandent l'asile en France hormis
des cas qui peuvent se comprendre
exceptionnels il y a quand même pas 80 %
de personnes qui sont persécuté dans ces
pays-là vous le savez bien c'est des
immigrés économiques et appelons-les
comme tels des immigrés économiques et
donc il faut pas qu'ils passe par
l'asile parce que ils bolise la demande
d'asile de ceux qui méritent l'asile et
la protection la plus rapide du
territoire de la République et elles
font la défiance
elles font la défiance pour les Français
mais appelonsles parlant non ce sont
soit des clandestins soit des
travailleurs économiques soit des
personnes qui sont des demandeurs
d'asile mais migrants me paraît un terme
qui consiste à cacher des vérités qui
sont très différentes selon les
étrangers pour Monsieur monsieur rotagot
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
choses j'eviendrai pas on aura sans
doute de longs débats mais peut-être la
question du nombre que vous évoquez et
quand tout à l'heure les rapporteurs
notamment évoquent la monsieur carci
capacité d'intégration c'est la même
chose finalement c'était éminemment
politique quelles sont nos capacités
d'intégration voilà je pense que c'est
un débat très important et d'ailleurs on
a une vraie différence me semble-t-il
avec notamment l'opposition de gauche
puisque ils évoquent non pas une crise
migratoire mais une crise finalement de
l'accueil c'est ce que j'entends souvent
moi je pense pas qu'il y a une crise de
l'accueil je ne sais pas s'il y a une
crise migratoire il y en a eu on aura
peut-être demain en tout cas il y a
manifestement une incapacité comme l'a
dit Monsieur carucci à intégrer
correctement les gens qui jadis ont été
intégrés par la République c'est c'est
un fait c'est un fait bon donc la
question c'est est-ce qu'on met beaucoup
plus de moyens pour l'intégration donc
c'est des questions de moyens mais c'est
pas que des questions de moyens c'est
aussi des questions de capacité pour
notre peuple à accueillir partout sur le
territoire national des personnes je
rappelle que 40 % des immigrés sont en
île-de- France donc extrêmement mal
réparti par ailleurs sur le territoire
national ce qui pose d'autres
difficultés puisquévidemment dès qu'il
s'agit de répartition ça pose évidemment
d'autres sujets de capacité
d'intégration sur le sur l'article 3 on
aura sans doute selon débat je voudrais
juste dire
je vis juste jeis juste vous dire que
nous avons toujours évoqué le fait que
pour nous l'article 3 correspondait à
6000 à 8000 régularisations par an bon
alors là où j'ai une petite différence
avec les orateurs précédents c'est qu'on
doit pas toujours parler du même article
3 je remercie madame Floren d'avoir
souligné euh ce qui était l'article 3
l'article 3 on peut voter pour on peut
voter contre bien évidemment on peut le
modifier on peut le remodifier il est
pas c'est c'est pas dans la pyramide de
Kelsen au-dessus euh la Constitution moi
je suis là pour discuter de de tout bien
évidemment et c'est une proposition du
gouvernement il peêtre pas être si
mauvais puisqu'il a pas été supprimé par
la commission des Lois du Sénat la
première fois donc on peut toujours en
discuter discutons-en discutons-en mais
je voudrais je voudrais lire parce que
j'ai lu des choses dans dans la dans la
presse qui qui correspond pas toujours à
ce que le gouvernement a proposé alors
je suis à un moment donné peut-être que
mon cabinet ou la direction générale des
étrangers en France donc je remercie le
travail Monsieur le Directeur on se
peut-être nuitamment changé l'article
j'avais souhaité écrire ave du S mais
non ils ont été extrêmement loyaux comme
ils le sont toujours Monsieur le
Directeur général je remercie vos
équipes c'est bien le même article 3
l'étranger qui a exercé une activité
professionnelle salariée figurant dans
la liste des métiers et zones
géographiques caractérisé par des
difficultés de recrutement donc d'abord
les métiers en tenstion c'est les
métiers qui sont évoqués là c'est pas
nous qui les définissons c'est même pas
moi c'est un arrêté du minist du travail
je voulais dire d'A à madame la
sénatrice tout que tout à l'heure la
restauration n'est pas aujourd'hui
jourd'hui dans les métiers en tension ce
qui pose des questions ce qui pose des
questions ce qui ceux qui pose des
questions mais donc les exemples sur la
restauration ils sont tous très
intéressants mais ils sont pas dedans
hein donc on peut toujours parler de
c'est quoi cette liste mais voilà dans
les zones géographiques c'est-à-dire que
l'article 3 n'évoque pas que dans toute
la France on va pouvoir régulariser des
personnes dans les zones géographique
tendu c'estd là où en général le chômage
est très bas où justement il n'y a pas
un taux de chômage élevé où on pourrait
dire et vous avez parfaitement raison
que les personnes régulières qui sont en
grande partie enfin il y a plus de 40 %
en effet de ces personnes qui sont au
chômage où les Français pourraient
travailler personne n dis convient le
gouvernement apporté une grande réforme
d'assurance chômage peut-être qu'il faut
faire d'autres choses encore mais c'est
pas partout tout le temps qui ont
travaillé grosso modo dans les 24
derniers mois au moins 8 mois dans les
emplois relevants de ces métiers et de
ces zones on insiste deux fois et qui
ont passé au moins 3 années en France se
voient des livret de plein droit une
carte de de séjour temporaire portant
l'amortion travail dans des
métiersentention d'un an n'ouvrant pas
au regoupement familial et on termine je
vais très vite chacun j'imagine la lu
que la disposition est appliquable
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 donc je veux
dire aux orateurs de la gauche qui ont
dit tout à l'heure que on crée quelque
chose 3 ans et qu'on les forcé pendant 3
ans et dans régularité pour éviter
d'avoir la possibilité d'avoir des
contrôles et de viv dans la peur qu'ils
ont pas bien lu le bon article c'est
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on a écrit
qu'est-ce qu'on dit on dit on dit que
des gens qui sont rentrés grosso modo
quand vous étiez en responsabilité allez
on l'a fait très très vite qu'on ne peut
évidemment pas expulser parce parce que
ces personnes parce que ces
personnes parce que ces personnes
évidemment désormais ne sont pour en
partie d'entre eux plus expulsables en
effet parce qu'ils ont fait leur vie
privée et familiale en France mais aussi
parce qu'on en a besoin parce qu'ils
sont dans une de métiers ention je ne
vais pas faire ici la litanie des
métiers dont vous êtes parfois les
pores-paroles pour me dire ici dans
l'agriculture là dans le BTP qu'il faut
absolument régulariser tou telle
personne c'est un fait que ces personnes
qui sont au moins depuis 3 ans et c'est
un une mise de départ pour discussion
avec évidemment le Parlement on pourrait
dans certaines circonstances les
régulariser et on arrête en 2026
c'estàdire que la disposition
d'aujourd'hui ne permet pas de
régulariser quelqu'un en 2026 quelqu'un
qui arriverait en France maintenant qui
travaillerait imaginons dans une zone
tendue dans un métier dans un métier en
tension bah il pourrait pas être
régularisé en 2027 puisque en 2026 c'est
clôturé je comprends je comprends je
comprends les questions que pose une
originalité qu cet article et je ne suis
pas fermé comme je l'ai dit à la
discussion j'attire simplement le fait
que nous avons des personnes qui en
effet doivent être régularisés et dont
notamment l'employeur ne veut pas le
régulariser quand l'employeur veut le
régulariser c'est pas un problème il va
voir son préfet et au nom de la
circulaire Vals 7000 parents 7000
parents d'ailleurs j'attire l'attention
qu' en a 23000 Vals en familial et que
ce que vous pouvez pas régulariser en
travail en général le préfet il essaie
de récupérer des critères familiau pour
régulariser des personnes qui
travaillent donc quand la dame n'est pas
régularisée quand la dame n'est pas
régularisée parce que son employeur
parce que son employeur euh s'y oppose
et ben il essaie de trouver des critères
et vous savez quoi notamment monsieur le
Président rotaillot si elle a des
enfants on peut la régulariser si elle a
pas d'enfant peut pas la régulariser
c'est ça la circulire Vals donc à
bloquer notre dispositif on encourage
les gens en fait à faire des enfants les
étrangers à faire des enfants en France
ce qui est assez incompatible avec la
loi du nombre donc il y a de la
bizarrerie dans notre dans notre dans
notre disposition mais je veux vous dire
que nous avons besoin d'une disposition
législative pour régulariser des
personnes qui mériterait d'être
régularisé quand l'employeur ne veut pas
les régulariser il faut quand même
avouer que c'est un drôle d'employeur et
c'est même quelqu'un de franchement pas
très acceptable dans dans le concer des
valeurs républicaines que d'embaucher
des sans papiers et refuser leur
régularisation quand cette personne veut
être régularisée parce que je fais
remarquer que 50 % de ces employeurs
sont des étrangers eux-mêmes
et que nous avons un défaut
évidemment et nous avons et nous avons
et nous avons et nous avons en effet de
grav de graves problèmes pour connaître
en effet les circuits professionnels
parallèles on le sait dans le bâtiment
et travaux publics on le enfin vous avez
tous géré des mairies ou des
collectivités locales on le sait dans
les bâtiments et travaux publics on le
sait évidemment dans la sous-traitance
de certains métiers et on le sait dans
le monde agricole donc l'article 3 il
est pas ce qu'on en dit il est tout à
fait prêt à être évidemment modifié dans
un compromis que notamment madame Floren
a évoqué mais je crois que il mériterait
en effet peut-être d'être complété vous
l'avez dit Monsieur rotaillot il n'y a
pas de disposition sur ce point sur les
valeurs de la République je suis tout à
fait d'accord comme c'est le fil rouge
du texte que nous portons il n'y a aucun
problème il s'agit pas pour nous de
régulariser sous prétexte qui travaille
dans un métier ention quelqu'un qui
aurait un casier judiciaire ou quelqu'un
qui serait adhérant à une idéologie
radicale je suis évidemment tout tout à
fait prêt sur l'article 10 vous avez
évoqué monsieur le Président rotaillot
le fait qu'en effet la disposition
prévue par le gouvernement était cert in
intessant dans sa philosophie mais
grosso modo prévoyit encore trop dans le
filament des exceptions pas assez de
clarté vous avez parfaitement raison je
vous signale et je vous feris savoir
mais vous avez lu l'avis du Conseil
d'État que c'est le l'avis sur lequel
nous étions partis j'avais proposer un
article 10 initialement ce que j'ai
transmis au Conseil d'État de faire
sauter toutes les protections et de dire
B voilà on va directement à
l'éloignement ou à l'expulsion et puis
ensuite le juge juge s'il doit juger
entre vie privée familiale et et ordre
public et après il y a éventuellement
une question constitutionnelle
conventionnelle sur la CEDH mais en tout
cas en texte de loi ordinaire bon le
Conseil d'État a répondu à un avis pas
extrêmement si je peux me permettre ici
de le dire pas extrêmement clair mais
qui nous a fait douter et c'est ce que
disait tout à l'heure madame Floren dans
son
intervention parce qu' il semblait dire
que nous rapprochions trop le régime de
l'expulsion du régime de l'éloignement 9
et 10 en disant que ce régime de
l'expulsion et de l'éloignement était
trop rapproché depuis tant d'années et
que ce que nous faisons c'est c'est que
nous rapprochions l'expulsion de
l'éloignement et qui ne sont donne pas
les mêmes garanties vous le savez bien
pour l'étranger ni même les mêmes forces
pour l'État et en fait nous préférions
expulser puisque c'est plus rapide et
plus efficace pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur nous ce que nous souhaitons
c'est faire sauter ces protections il y
en a qu'une qui doit rester parce
qu'elle est judiciaire et la Convention
Européenne des droit de l'enfant je
voudrais ici redire que les mineurs qui
ont fait des des des des crimes au délit
pendant qu'ils étaient mineurs ne sont
pas concernés par la levée des
protections mais toutes les autres
toutes les autres il y en a huit autres
nous souhaitons les les faire sauter une
fois qu'on a dit ça on a donc proposé un
texte qui nous paraissait comprendre ce
qu'a dit le Conseil d'État avec
peut-être un peu moins de clarté que le
texte initial nous entendons ce qu'a
fait la Commission et je pense que la
Commission a eu raison de de pouvoir
clarifier ce que le gouvernement a
essayé de faire en essayant d'appliquer
conseilétat j'ai proposé moi-même vous
l'avez vu sans doute un amendement à
l'article 10 qui est je crois j'espère
je dis au rapporteur et j'espère qu'on
trouvera une solution commune plus
claire encore qui consiste à prendre le
risque en effet de faire sauter
l'intégralité des protections sauf les
mineurs qui restent mineurs pour revenir
à l'écriture initiale du
gouvernement la difficulté que nous
avons et et je pense qu'il faut qu'on en
est tous conscient c'est qu'il a rien de
pire qu'une mesure comme celle-ci qui
est centrale dans le projet de loi qui
soit censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel alors moi je pense qu'on
peut trouver notamment sur l'écriture
gouvernementale une bonne une bonne
pratique mais en tout cas soyez bien
conscient que nous avons la même même
esprit que vous c'est-à-dire de pouvoir
faire sauter les protections et de plus
avoir d'exception et de de ne plus créer
ces jurisprudences àant plus finir vous
avez évoqué le délit de séjour
irrégulier que monsieur le Président
Hollande et la majorité de l'époque a a
fait a fait supprimer en décembre 2012
j'étais député et j'ai voté contre cette
disposition l'honnêteté me pousse à vous
dire que c'est malheureusement une
directive européenne votée par le PPE
qui a fait ce délit de séjour irrégulier
non non mais non mais je je je sais bien
c'est pour ça que je j'écoute ce que
vous dit ce que vous avez fait dans le
texte le délit de séjour irrégulier qui
a été certes voté par la majorité
socialiste à demande du président
Hollande faut quand même le dire c'était
une directive européenne qui a été
élaboré par le PPE donc je pense que
c'est pas ce qu'on a fait de mieux
ensemble mais j'ai constaté d'abord
monsieur le Président rotaillot qu'il
existe toujours un maintien un délit de
maintien de séjour irrégulier que la
police utilise peu et donc je leur ai
demandé depuis plus d'un an et demi par
voie de d'instruction de l'utiliser donc
c'est pas parce qu'il y a le dél de
séjour irrégulier qui a sauté que le
maintien saute donc d'abord c'est une PR
diretion du travail de la police et j'ai
noté que vous n'avez pas réintroduit des
peines de prison mais que vous avez
introduit une amende et je serais
favorable à cette disposition parce
qu'elle est copiée par d'autres pays
européens elle n'est pas contraire au
droit européens elle paraît
effectivement efficace pour l'action des
services de police ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui je veux dire au au président
buffet que je suis très attaché en effet
à disposition qu'il a fait introdu de
laisser passer consulaire contre visa
bien sûr que c'est pas la panassée
mais moi je constate quand je rencontre
d'autres ministres de l'Intérieur qui me
disent ah mais nous on pourrait tout à
fait le faire mais on applique le droit
de votre pays bien sûr vous êtes un pays
souverain mais il y a aucune disposition
de votre droit qui permet de
conditionner LPC et visa et donc je
pense qu'il faut utiliser cette
formulation que il est important de
pouvoir dire quand un pays ne délivre
aucun laisser passer consulaire bah il y
a pas de raison de lu délivrer plus de
visa que de coutume donc je pense que
c'est très important la petite
difficulté vous le savez bien euh
monsieur le le Président c'est que c'est
un sujet européen le président de la
République a été courageux en faisant
une restriction de visa très importante
sur les pays du Maghreb mais la
difficulté c'est quand l'Espagne donner
des visas évidemment les gens sa passer
par l'Espagne donc nous portons au
niveau européen cette disposition d'un
travail commun sur les visas et j'ai
bonne chance pour que cette année nous
puissions l'adopter on l'a déjà adopté
avec le pays qui est l'Irak il faut que
nous fassions avec les état du Maghreb
puisque l'Irak c'est c'est
malheureusement si je dire peu de gens
même s'il y en a qui sont évidemment
concernés par les visas mais il est
évident que ces disposition do être
aussi fait en européen sur les sujets du
Maghreb mais c'est pas parce que c'est
une solution européenne qu'il faut pas
le faire en France et donc je je
donnerai un avis là aussi favorable
terminé par Monsieur
patient pour lui dire qu'effectivement
je je je veux redire qu'on va traduire
en direct dans le droit et pas par
ordonnance pas par habilitation les
dispositions ultramarines hormis article
74 parce que velkonis et et Polynésie
connaissent un droit extrêmement
différent mais tous les autres
territoires ultramarins méritent un
débat en direct et pas un renvoi dans
des cabinet car obscur des des
ministères donc je suis tout à fait
favorable pour la traduction end dur ce
que nous allons poser et je remercie
d'ailleurs les services d'avoir
travaillé à cela pour que dès le Sénat
nous puissions en parler je suis
extrêmement favorable aux dispositions
maoraais vous le savez et aux
dispositions guyanaises et vous avez
notamment raison de dire qu' a un
détournement typique du droit d'asile
par le Brésil et donc une population qui
subit que subit les Guyanais et qu'il
faut donc qu'on change ça immédiatement
et je vous propose de le faire
évidemment sur vos amendements et je
veux aussi dire que c'est pas parce que
nousons des dispositions de loi lo
ordinaire pour la guillane et pour
Mayotte que des dispositions
constitutionnelles ne doivent pas être
adoptées notamment sur le droit du sol
ou le droit du sang puisque je pense que
notamment à Mayotte mais c'est pas
simplement le cas à Mayotte il y a aussi
des dispositions qui relèvent du droit
constitutionnel sont allé plus loin euh
dans euh l'aide qu'on doit apporter à
nos amis Maoris ou nos amis guyanais
bien bien bien évidemment voilà Monsieur
le le président ce que je voulais dire
en en quelques mots remerciant les les
orateurs et en permettant d'avoir un
j'espère un très bon débat dans les
heures et dans les jours qui viennent
merci Monsieur le Ministre la discussion
générale est clauses nous allons donc
passer à la discussion du texte de la
commission et ce jusqu'à 20h après quoi
nous ferons une interruption de séance
jusqu'à
21h30 article additionnel avant
l'article 1er a nous sommes saisis d'un
amendement 518 rectifié par Monsieur
ravier monsieur
ravier merci merci monsieur le président
ident monsieur Président Monsieur mes
chers collègues puisqu'il faut revoir la
philosophie générale du code